Uh,
do,
do five,
four,
three,
two,
one.
Boom.
It's over.
We did as chairs.
So chairs is now November,
November.
Here we go by the November,
Like that.
First of all,
who's fucking stupid idea was to do this
God damn fitness challenge Tommy Buns
last year we did a nice calm 15.
Hot Yoga is so awful.
Not even close.
Not even close to this.
No.
This was so much more difficult and I
didn't expect this,
but I like it.
I liked it.
I think it's fun to be competitive with
your friends.
Yes.
It's a fun thing to fuck around,
but like,
like isolating something like this.
Oh,
it's a year.
You get to see different sides of people
you didn't know existed.
Oh yeah.
Jesus Christ.
You worked out too.
You have no idea.
I don't think anyone,
anyone gets the real perspective when
joe is focused on something.
I've never seen anything like that in my
fucking life.
Well I know the funniest because like
everybody's competitive and this brings
it out.
But like the funny thing was like Bert
being like,
whatever joe does,
I'll do double.
Definitely he was like,
fuck that and that and the other thing I
didn't expect ever.
I thought Ari would just be like,
whatever.
I'm just going to walk in the East
village.
I was worried about him the most.
I didn't think you were going to do
shit.
Worried about him the most from the
beginning.
His brain.
Yeah,
I know I'm out.
Fuck this.
That's what you were saying that though.
Three days in which you were texting
like this is dumb.
No,
no,
no.
He says that this is what he's saying.
He's saying that and he means it when he
says it,
but he's also going to fucking kill you
scotch and then it gets really serious
and not serious.
But I was looking for loopholes in order
to trick you guys decide to like not
work out.
So I thought if I get like a bunch of
points,
like all to join in like seven or eight
days in and then you can be done.
No,
that I'd be like,
they'd be like,
what the fuck?
Like,
yeah,
I've been secretly working out,
but now we're too far away,
so don't try to catch up.
Oh,
right,
right.
Was like some psychological sneakers he
was doing.
He was saying you should just do your
regular workout and see what your score
is like.
Oh yeah.
That was a bit bigger than try to
control.
That was a big fan of that one to
regular fucking way because you were
entertaining that for a second.
Getting.
I was like,
this is so stupid.
This is.
But then I was like,
I can't lose.
And then uh,
then I thought about it and the other
thing I was thinking was this is what I
was,
this is what my plan was.
My plan was to keep up with you guys for
two weeks.
And then after two weeks to set aside a
lot of time and about and elap us.
Yeah,
about,
well,
no,
just go psycho.
I was like,
I'm just going to go psycho.
I'm going to put up pace that I don't
think anybody else can keep up with for
the last two weeks.
The last two weeks I just said I'm going
to put in some 600 point five days.
I put in 1000 point day.
That's that's,
that's when I.
that's when I stopped looking at you
for context.
I was looking at the.
When we started this month and I put in
my $700 a day,
everyone was a little bit like,
wow,
Bert.
I,
by the way,
I ran almost a marathon that day.
Have no fucking clue.
I was just looking at my goddamn phone
the whole time.
Just checking,
just checking the points.
I was always keep.
Some people don't know what the points
are.
Well explained.
If you get 70 percent of your max heart
rate,
that's three points a minute.
If you get 80 percent of your max heart
rate or above,
that's four points a minute,
so we all tried to stay in the 80 range.
That's where you get your money,
right?
That's where we work out for an hour in
that range of 80 to 100 a heavy workout.
It gives you 240 points,
so maxed,
maxed out.
That's just gives you context.
What a 600,
which was not.
I did a 930 cheese weight workout.
It was over after that.
I was in New York.
He'd call him.
He's like,
dude,
he's just fucking going dragging elk
around.
He has it all the whole time is dragging
us around.
That wasn't even that one.
That was the.
The the elk hunting day was mostly
hiking mountains day.
That was like a 600 point.
Oh No.
That's when,
when,
when you were there and you were
actually working out in the mountains as
well though.
I was like,
what the fuck?
You're like,
if I would've been like,
guys,
I'm.
This is.
I made the mistake of jokingly saying,
Oh,
I got them Joseph on an elk cutting
vacation,
and the hunters were like,
dude,
it's not a fucking vacation.
It's work.
And I was like,
easy guys.
Well you got a backpack on and you can
walk as money as the most I've ever
walked 12 miles in a day and you're
walking up and down in elevation,
you're going up and down.
Like I,
I saved it one day because it was so
ridiculous because I'd gone up and down,
I forget like 130 flights of stairs.
Some something fucking crazy.
But you ended up getting your.
What'd you shoot on this island with
1000 pound elk?
Elk.
You gotta like relatively quickly,
right?
Yeah,
on the first day.
Thank God.
So then I came back in those days,
came back,
but the nod in 35 point day,
that was my big was a thousand points
because I did 935 in the day and then I
did a podcast and then I did 100 later
on in the day just to see you guys
anymore.
Yeah,
that's what I was wondering if there was
like I didn't have,
there was a,
it was a part of,
it was time management.
I was suffered socially from the most
part.
Huge part was like who had the most time
to spend in the.
Yeah,
yeah.
I was here two Mondays ago,
last Monday,
and it was,
it was popping out at the comedy store
is going to hang out with everybody you
know.
And then it was like,
Nah,
it's 10:00,
I gotta get a couple of hours.
Then all your walls,
your workouts were so late,
so I got to say that fuck you with you
post in your goddamn workouts in the
middle of the night.
It was so deflating.
You go to bed.
I've got a two point lead and the wake
up and go,
how am I?
Six hundred points by.
I started to break spirit.
It was fun because that's the other
thing already went through when he got
this tracker and he found out all the
work workarounds.
So he would build up work in his tracker
and then he'd Bluetooth it in the middle
of the fucking night.
I'd also do the workout.
The workout is doing workouts at 1:30
AM and then I'd be like,
let me change and go out there two in
the morning.
Oh,
you're going?
Yeah.
I thought you were uploading in the
middle of the night.
No one can see the time.
The time that he was actually doing it.
Yeah,
it's the freaks route.
It was common.
I thought that because I already was so
out of shape,
his heart rate was just skyrocketing,
like Ralphie walking upstairs and then
already and I went on a walk on a hike
and I was in the yellow the whole time
and Ari was barely in green and I was
like,
oh,
he's in.
He's in really good shape,
and then you did that day with.
He bought that theory really hard,
that hit,
that hit that it was just that he was
out of shape so that.
And he was saying he was selling it so
hard and I called him.
I had to go on the hike.
He's definitely shaped them immediately.
It's a psychological thing.
You don't want to think that a guy who
hasn't been working out at all is in
good shape,
but I think you pushed yourself through
the first week or two.
Then you got in good shape and then I
kept going.
Okay.
First of all,
I had fought by plants.
Okay.
What was the plan?
Michelle Wolf offered to give.
Let me just have her wear the thing from
day one.
That was definitely the fall,
but I knew that was going to happen
regardless,
miles a day,
every day,
and when I asked her,
I was like,
hey,
would you wear this thing for me if I
needed you to do?
She goes,
I know what you're talking about.
Absolutely aware for you.
Whoa.
I will stay in the right zone.
I'll tell no one.
She feels left out because she thinks
she would laugh.
She goes,
this is none of this is what we do.
Like I don't do long cardio sessions.
I did five and a half hours on an
elliptical after running for an hour.
What?
Yeah.
Hey,
get one of those.
I got 935 points.
I ran for an hour and then I stayed on
the elliptical for five and a half
hours.
You would see it go and you check in by
fucking broken.
Got Three hundred points and then you
talk and he checked back in 30 minutes
later like,
oh no,
it's still going.
It's still going.
Yeah.
I just fuck.
Well,
I wanted to see how far I could go.
The thought was like,
when you're tired,
how tired are you?
Can you take another step?
Okay.
Can you take two?
Can you take three?
Can you just keep going?
I bet you can keep going.
Let's see how long I can keep going.
And then you get to this point where you
just just think about breathing.
Just think about what I was thinking
about.
I was just thinking about in and out,
so just trying to stay almost like a
meditative state.
Trying to stay in the zone and I was
pouring sweat.
I set off the fire.
Alarm was so much.
It's set off the fire.
It was like four hours in.
I feel like that's a story most people
don't get to tell about themselves.
You know?
It was madness.
This is not how I work out.
I work out for like maybe an hour at
most.
I hit the bag,
I'll do some
rounds.
I lift a little weights.
I'm not trying to kill myself like this
was.
This was very interesting because I
didn't.
I didn't know what,
how my body would respond to like a
month of psychotic exercise.
Did you do the things you guys do,
the things where you would,
you'd be like,
the voice would say you got to quit,
quit,
take a walk for a little bit,
then go back and do it,
and then if you just go like,
oh,
I'm at four point eight miles,
let me just go until five or like,
or like I'm almost at halfway through
this hour so let me just get to 30
minutes and will be downhill.
I can stop there.
It fucked with my obsessive
compulsiveness really bad.
Yeah,
because I get to the place where I go,
all right,
I just want to get to 200 points and
then I'd be like,
Oh shit,
I'm only at 950 calories.
I want to get to a thousand dollars.
It's like,
oh,
I'm right.
I'm right by 2:20,
I want to get to 20.
And then it gets to a point where you
get.
I believe it's like it's you get in the
zone when you go,
I'm just going to keep going.
I'm going to.
Everyone's asleep.
I'm going to keep walking and,
and dude,
it got bad with me to the point where I,
I mean we'll talk,
we should talk about physical breakdowns
and a little bit,
cause I know all of us dealt with some
sort of physical breakdown,
but I was having nightmares that you
guys have fucked with my tracker,
put it in that I was younger and lighter
so I wasn't earning the night in a panic
and checked my fucking stats.
But somebody got into your shit and
hacked it and I was like,
these.
No,
I wouldn't put it past them that yeah,
you get that printer.
Can I tell you my other treatment?
Okay.
I figured out pretty quickly that the
way they do your Max heart rate is your
age minus a certain number of minus your
age and then you get it from there.
Then when you actually run it will move
up or down from there.
But right away I was like,
oh,
okay.
So I entered my age and before I started
I wrote to the my zone people and said,
my idiot wife wrote my age in wrong.
I'm actually 74 was born in 44,
not 74 and 44 the other way and like,
all right,
we'll change it for you.
So yeah.
So you put the other 70 year old man
profile.
Yeah.
Hold on,
hold on,
hold on.
The whole month you are working on is
done that.
That problem is.
I had already set it as the other thing
and so it'll say you have to.
Then you have to have a brand new thing.
It didn't work.
Oh yeah.
It would've been great for me.
It'll just a walk around casually
earning yellow the whole time,
which I could have gotten.
That would have been insane.
Yeah,
that was definitely a good cheat my
mind.
That was,
that went wrong.
I was like,
fuck.
I feel like that one would have
disqualified you for sure.
I can still do that.
I'm still on the fence with these
fucking five hour hikes he was taking.
Well listen man,
hiking is work.
It is.
Work it fucking.
You're going uphill for log.
Fuck you guys worked hard.
No,
of course you did.
You did.
I saw him here on the rowing machine
going hard for an hour.
I've watched it on my hikes.
It's hard when you go,
go,
fuck it.
You earned it.
I'm not going to shit on that at all.
We should really,
really keep ourselves from judging.
How hard are the people work?
Every time I did somebody got a big
score.
I was like,
what's your.
Do you cheated?
How'd you cheat?
My hardest workout?
Scored the shittiest my hardest workouts
or running the hills and lifting
weights.
If I run the hills,
it gives me almost 40 points less than
if I just wrote a bike or wrote an
elliptical machine and you go up and
down.
You want the pause.
The way I do it is I run hard and I take
breaks.
I take like a deep breath when I get to
the top of strokes dick the whole time
too,
so that's difficult.
Rub My balls to tell him what my left
hand and I give myself another sprint
until I can't.
I have like these points where I know I
can make it too if I go full clip and
then I try to extend it a little bit and
I keep trying to extend it,
but when I do that I'm going into the
red and on top of going in the red,
um,
I'm with lifting weights.
Like you need recovery time and recovery
time.
Your heart rate crash is way low.
You could just do the elliptical machine
and just couldn't like 15 resistance.
So it's got some,
some give to it and you start sweating
and then you get into a zone.
You just get into a niche way easier.
[inaudible] it's a machine,
makes it all easy,
but you just get into a zone and you
just got to be strong.
I think the thing with those,
I mean,
even though like if you do the intense
workout recovery is gonna be,
you know,
you're going to need it,
you're going to feel it.
If you do those for like days in a row,
there is still a fatigue,
right?
That there's fatigue,
but there was no like in a week.
And what was getting me was the
pounding,
the running up the hills.
There's no counting on the elliptical
exactly what stays in it.
My feet were starting to hurt by the end
because I was running miles in the hills
every day with those minimalist shoes
on.
Which man,
those things they,
they,
they really do work like they really do
work.
But the way they work is they make your
feet work harder.
So if your feet aren't conditioned for
that Shit,
man,
you feet are like one of the first
things that wear out,
like a nice spongy running shoe is just
you just so much like smosh smosh.
Every time you step on things,
if you get that and it's gone and you
have this like really thin layer of
rubber with some tread,
it's just your foot hitting the ground
over and over and over again.
There's very little padding.
None.
Were you using the ultras as well?
The running shoe.
The ultra.
I was using one called zero and I was
using a one called Vivo Vivo barefoot.
They're my favorite ones there.
They're really good because I was
wearing the five toe ones,
but Jim and my toes into shit.
I'm running hard.
I'm tired because I'm fucking exhausted,
so I'm like,
I need something that covers all the
toast.
I don't jam one into a rock because I'm
too exhausted.
Walk me through what your.
What a regular workout it was for you.
I'd be curious of what everyone's
regular workout was.
What I would do is I would,
if
I would run,
I would run for an hour,
just an hour.
Just take my daughter hills there,
running the hills because it gives.
It's two things.
One I.
He needs exercise.
He's young.
He loves,
he loves to run with me and two,
it's a real good form of exercise.
It's like it's.
I know it's more beneficial than the
elliptical machine.
It made my ass bigger,
made my legs bigger.
Like they all got bigger.
Like especially like I could feel my
pants fit different.
Really?
Yeah.
Because I've only been doing this for
like two years.
Yourself up puts also,
nature has got to be healthy for you
too.
Before that I was doing just
weightlifting stuff with for my legs.
I would do like squats or do cleans and
presses and overheads,
you know,
do leg presses with kettlebells,
overhead and stuff like that,
which is all great.
It's all really good stuff,
but it's not sustained motion.
There's something about a sustained
motion of running hills that I think
boosts your vitality.
It gives you more energy because you're,
you're.
You have to work,
so to run a hill is one of the more
difficult things to do an exercise.
It's just,
you've got to fucking.
Just kidding.
You're basically doing like bodyweight
squats with one leg over and knocks when
you're going uphill.
I got a 45 man.
It's hard,
so beneficial.
When I went to hitting the bags,
what I would do is on days I would do
that.
I would run and then I would get on the
elliptical machine or I'd run and I'd
get on the bike or the echo bike,
which is like a beefed up airdyne
machines.
Things fuck you up or that assault
thing.
The assault fitness treadmill.
Like that one.
I love it.
It's fucking hard.
It's really hard.
It's not a treadmill,
it's not enjoyable.
It's an extra bump,
harder than running on the road,
running on the road,
much harder than making yourself to make
it harder than that because for real
self powered and it's really beneficial
for brother treadmill.
For that one.
It was a mistake.
It was not bird.
It was the right move.
It's harder than running.
I had that in my man cave was.
That was my go to at the end of the
night,
was good on that thing and dude that was
not forgiving.
Wear you out.
It's called an assault fitness trainer.
That's the air runner.
Air Runner,
yeah.
It's supposed to be shit at least 30
percent harder.
It's shit.
I love it.
I get on that thing.
It's like saw you got it,
and I was like,
you like that?
And you're like,
I love it.
I was like,
I'm out.
He doesn't hurt your knees.
It doesn't stop pounding.
It's got a good amount of give to it
because it's got this tread to it and
it's just got enough shock so that as
you're running you don't feel like it's
a big pounding on your joints,
but it's all self propelled,
so you'll really get a good rhythm going
and your fucking legs get tired.
What's Great Ford is sprinting on it.
You can get up and sprint.
You can.
You can end your sprints that really
raised your heart rate.
I think the key also,
here's a big key.
You got to be distracted.
You got to be able to either be
distracted by meditating and getting
into some sort of a weird breathing zone
or you got to listen to podcasts or you
got to listen to music or you got to
listen to.
For me,
it was books on tape did the best really
for when I was out in the wild.
If I was out in the wild,
I was listening to books on tape.
I'd like something thinking about
something distracted me from the
physical exertion of exercises,
but indoors it was a two things.
Helped violent movies and fights.
Watching fights.
You just get your get your heart rate
jacked up when you get your heart rate
jacked up and you're watching guys get
hit and you fucked it honestly
before know,
watching football and especially if the
treadmill and then during timeouts you
could like do whatever.
I would do the thing where like you just
kind of going,
going,
but I noticed that there was like a punt
return or it kicked off
when I watch gladiator.
There was a giant spike whenever there
was sword fights and I was like,
oh my God.
That's what I'm doing.
I'm getting.
I'm allowing myself to get so caught up
in this movie that I'm like fighting.
I'm a break.
Breaking them up right now.
Yeah.
I got to sit in the red dude.
I gotta give a shout out to run the
jewels.
Run the jewels is perfect.
Fucking can run the jewels.
Mit a killer,
Mike.
Dude.
Nice tools.
Fast.
Run them,
run them tools.
They affect perfect momentum.
I listened to nothing.
When I think when I think about this
month,
I'll.
I'll think.
I'll think of two things.
I thank God it's over and I think could
run the goddamned jewels because that's
all I listened to.
Running great running song and a great
running song.
We'll give you like 10 percent more
than.
Oh yeah.
It kicks into overdrive on some songs.
You're like,
oh wait,
it's this one,
and then you're waiting for the beat.
The drum,
the.
Oh,
you're just start going and going.
I get real excited.
Angry if like I'm going to fight
somebody.
If I put on a lot of public enemy,
just put it on a mix of public enemy.
I'll feel like that's good too.
That's good.
You don't got me through the first week
and with you guys was like,
Oh,
I think I'm okay.
I'm watching all your specials.
I brought the fucking necklace thing out
there.
I want you netflix special going.
Ha.
You write jokes.
Did you read any jokes while you were
running?
I don't think I did.
I didn't write any jokes about the jail.
I wrote so many goddamn jokes.
Really?
Did you really?
Oh fuck yeah.
I smiled at a woman when I was jogging
and I said,
uh,
the joke was that only smiling?
No,
I'm not having a stroke.
I'm not flirting with you,
honey.
I'm just trying to not have a stroke.
I went to a dark place to a dark place
and you took us with you.
Okay.
I was.
I was like,
I'm going to win.
I thought I was like,
yeah,
whatever you think you can do.
Let's keep going.
Let's see what happens.
That's a weird switch that goes off.
It's like,
let's see who's willing to die.
Well,
all my last week or so was dangerous.
It became a fight for my people were
asking me about.
It's just dehydration.
That's all it is.
Just dude.
People would message us.
By the way,
guys,
Joe,
Joe's going,
I'm okay.
I didn't get wrapped up,
but people,
some people were upset,
like they wanted me almost to get it
because I've always rag on these
crossfit guys to get it.
I have not ranked on them.
Would have said is that I have heard
some negative opinions about crossfits
from experts that are trust.
Like Steve Maxwell.
I'm not a fitness expert by any stretch
of the imagination.
I don't know whether they're crossfits
bad or good.
I bet it's probably based on your
application,
the way you do it,
because if somebody asks me,
is Jujitsu good for your body?
I'd be like,
well,
I've had a bunch of surgeries.
Everybody I know's had surgeries.
Everybody I know that does Jujitsu,
he gets up.
He didn't even get his blue belt and he
had surgery right before we started this
podcast.
Joe Did say those crossfit people are
tree hugging hippies.
Yoga,
black belt.
I want a yoga black belt.
I love it.
Yoga black belt.
I'm like a blue belt and yoga dude.
Halfway through the month.
I told Tom the other day and he laughs
and so I tried it on stage and a worked,
but I stopped producing semen,
just coughing,
dust,
dude.
My Dick had the dry heaves.
Just people ask me.
It's like there's your sex drive to go
up with Mike.
And I wanted to be like,
yeah,
but then I was like,
no,
no energy for that.
I'll be so tired,
so tired.
How about those sleep?
So I was sleeping like a fucking perfect
person,
like a baby most of the time.
You know what I noticed is a big one for
me that really might make me change the
way I live is zero anxiety,
zero negative chatter.
That's what I found.
There's a realistic view of the world
that you get from rigorous exercise and
this is my theory and it's.
I'm not a biologist,
but I think that there's.
We have too much of a history as a
species of constantly avoiding danger
and I think we live in a place that's
far too safe for our natural instincts
and so we're constantly looking for
things to be bad or looking for things
to be dangerous or confronting.
Confronting our own mortality and
putting it on the back burner and
letting all that weirdness manifests
itself in all sorts of other fears.
Fears about the government,
fears about economics and fears about
this.
And I think we're dealing with as human
beings all the time and I think there's
only a certain amount you can do.
And I think when you have rigorous
exercise,
it puts in perspective what that certain
amount actually is and what you can
control as a person that you can.
You can just chill your body out and
look at this whole thing for what it is.
It is what it is.
You know what?
We're going to be fine or we're not,
and then it won't matter,
but this,
this,
this whole thing that we do when we do
we do this because our body has a need
for exercise.
It has a built in neat.
It's got an engine that needs to be
pushed and if you don't push it starts
fucking you.
It
starts fucking with you and asking you
weird questions like,
what the fuck is that guy think he is
like,
he wants to start problems that wants to
get upset if things don't make any sense
to be upset at it wants conflict is a
part of you that wants conflict because
it thinks that conflicts are part of the
programming because it's been our way
for millions of years.
So whatever the fuck we were then to
whatever the fuck we are now,
there's been conflict along the way.
People have been trying to eat us,
things have been trying to kill us and
this is the only time ever that.
There's none of that and I think the
only time you could see things with
perspective is when you blow out all the
biological shit,
whether it's jerk off,
like how many times have you jerked off
and then had a totally different opinion
of a person above.
Because I gave George often not called
people like,
why would I call this person?
I'm sorry.
Just jerked off now I see.
I see what this whole is some weird
biological trick playing some stupid
game.
I'm so high,
high,
high school,
Dude.
I love a.
I'll tell you what this woman did for
me.
It got me back in spin class.
I love spinning classmates.
I love it dude.
I love it.
Good for you,
man.
Do you like music or know what to say?
Just make you spin it.
The task people.
It just close your eyes.
And you remember when we talked,
I said I had Bob Harper is my spin
teacher one time and the thing he said
about want me to go back and fuck people
I grew up with or whatever is Bob Parker
the coby Brian have spin classes.
Yeah.
But he's from biggest loser pow.
Okay.
And so I got.
Did you guys know who he was?
I have no idea.
Those are the big biggest loser fan.
Bye.
Like I liked the.
I liked the way they talked to you.
And it's fun.
I like closing my eyes.
I liked the first break,
a sweat I liked.
I love what I love and I have to say I
have to give props to people more than
anything with Ari doing that Rower,
redefine the way I had to look at
working out because I went,
he,
he was an 80 percent.
Like I know what 80 percent feels like
our on a.
it's
funny.
Some of them are harder than others to
keep it eight percent biking was way
harder.
I know you were capable of it seriously,
did you?
No.
I thought he was capable of running.
And stuff,
that's fine.
I could sort of do that,
that,
but I know quite how much.
Eighty percent on a rower.
He's angry person.
Yes.
Even when he's playful and that's my zen
spot,
but even when he's playful,
angry,
it's still energy.
Like that anger,
like the anger that he gave everybody on
that fucking podcast you did with one of
my favorite podcast ever.
Always hiking around doing a podcast,
talking shit about us.
Not Seventy percent.
It's brilliant.
It's brilliant,
but it's,
it's energy.
See that kind of anger that you have
that's either in you or it's not.
I knew already had it.
It's a matter of getting the whole
engine fired up again.
He's not too old now.
He used to play basketball law needs to
do when you buy.
One of my resolutions this year was to
go to the gym like once a week,
like something attainable and I still
hadn't done it until.
I remember when you did you Jitsu,
you were very enthusiastic about it and
I remember you were fucking trying hard,
you know,
and I remember one time you legitimately
swept me legitimate.
Yes he did.
It was a brown belt,
I was a brown belt.
People once in a while.
I do it just once in a while you'd be
like,
oh,
I forgot to tell you 100 percent the
truth.
This is what happened.
He was,
we were rolling together and I was like,
okay dude,
let's just do this.
I'm not going to hurt you.
Cool.
And we got into position.
I got on top of him and I just got a
little relaxed and all of a sudden,
boom,
Ari hip pops takes my leg out from under
me and he swept me and I'm like,
you mother fucker got a little poem,
and he exploded.
I like,
oh,
okay.
I see what's up.
So I knew a part of already that you
guys did know because already now,
by the way that he swept me right back
and so part of me that really wants to
experience like trying to roll with Joe
for a second after this contest and
knowing what he's capable of just to
feel true helplessness feeling it is.
This is why it's a good feeling because
if you.
If you can handle it,
then at least you know where you are on
this little weird food chain of who can
kill with their bare hands and then you
also know that whatever these people
know you can learn to do.
It's not a physical thing.
Like I know guys that are much weaker
than me that can fuck me up.
If we rolled together,
they're going to tap me 100 percent of
the time.
My friend Danny,
my friend Danny,
weighs a hundred and 60 something
pounds.
I've never.
I mean I tapped him when he was young.
He kills me.
He strangles me.
Just what?
Superior techniques.
That's way better than me.
Way better way more focused.
Been doing it.
You realize that sounds like to a guy
who just with you,
but here's the thing.
I don't have to listen.
You have to have the time to get serious
about something.
We have the time to get serious about
this for a lot of time to get serious,
but suddenly out of the blue.
By the way,
Tom suggested it like four or five days
before it started.
Yeah.
This was not a planned out thing at all.
Been wearing that thing for perspective
though.
I started January with it and like an
average one has been probably 2100
points or something.
How much you get this one?
90 five.
So talk about.
Talk about the percentages of how we
finished in the [inaudible] that
everybody hitting them up.
That blew me away.
Well they said there's a million
registered users first of all.
And zero point one percent.
Okay.
But hold on.
Most of those warranty didn't even have
it on.
I don't know about that.
Like we're going into November is now.
We're not really.
I'm not saying everybody was actively
all using a million users.
Yeah.
Well whoever is using it.
Well I don't know what the database.
How it's.
It's a good point.
All right.
That's a fair point because like we
really don't know what percentage of
those people actually keeping people
trying.
We know the killer was a d one athlete
though.
Yeah,
you're fucking.
Jim has a.
that's the thing that we can actually
pointed against people who were trying
to guess.
If we agree on a number,
would you guys say that like half the
people would use it regularly or no?
There's a million people with behalf.
Even if it's a quarter,
we're still talking about point five
will be point four,
point five percent percentile,
whatever.
90 nine point fifth percentile.
Yeah.
I wouldn't go up much.
Wouldn't go up much.
Even under a smaller variable,
but I think that what those other people
are at the top are probably fitness
instructors and that was.
That's what my space is my space.
That was nice though.
Yeah,
that's what my zones told me.
Oh,
that was my other cheap plan.
Go to the gym with $15 and say please
wear this and seen the sweet spot.
I.
It wasn't too much,
but I would have to do it a lot.
Fuck this.
I'll tell you.
Let me.
Oh,
like I'll walk you through my plan the
whole month.
What was your plan?
Do not get hurt.
That was number one.
I was like,
don't get hurt because if I get hurt or
get heel spurs on windows.
I was so excited at the prospect of you
being out anytime someone has you hurt
your ankle or something,
but when I hurt my ankle but cautious
and I knew this is not real.
You saw me slip side.
Then I saw her.
I swear to God.
I'll call my fucking wife right now.
My friend molly saw you in fucking spin
that day.
Expand the one exercise you don't use
your legs for.
Were you worried about them?
When I was sick.
Oh,
I knew.
I knew you were giving me the fuck off.
Oh,
I can't make this up.
Wyatt guys,
he told me he was sick and he took
photos of his medication and he went one
day and then you were right back to full
speed.
Thank you Ari.
Thank you.
Already.
That's not true.
What has it been crazy that a day where
I was like,
look,
I got to get something and then buy
something.
I was thinking $150 or so and that was
the beginning of or the second worst day
and I put it on.
I was like,
I'll just get that.
And I walked down the street and I was
like,
I felt so sick.
I got 40.
That's it.
Like a nun.
Okay.
That right.
Yeah,
true.
The next day I was able to get like,
I think a hundred and something and that
was split up into also.
And so then I was like,
I'm pretty fucked right now by the way.
Right at that point I was like,
okay,
burt,
we're not coming last.
So that's great.
There's just a casual attended.
Two of us.
Uh,
Tom's done.
That's great.
That's awesome though.
Took a deep breath.
I was like,
tell you something.
This is something that we should all
pointed out for health.
Like I've been over the last couple of
years,
I've been eating a lot of Kimchi,
a lot of fermented cabbage and a lot
Kombucha.
Real.
Yeah.
Real brutal,
brutal farts.
But here's the thing,
all that healthy like probiotic stuff
that has a big impact on your immune
system.
I mean really big.
I haven't gotten sick in a long time to
always take these.
And I started drinking them too.
They're always good to do the shit gts,
gts or the shit.
They're so good.
They taste good.
They're healthy for you at a whole foods
guy telling me like,
hey,
just so you know,
I saw your drink this in the thing.
It's five.
It's got alcohol so you can't.
You can't drink that in the,
in the store.
And I was like,
listen,
I'm going to do it every single time so
you can just try to catch me if you
want.
But for the warning,
you did your job well as less than half
a percent of right?
Isn't that what it is?
What is the number that they have to.
It's more than one.
Hold on.
My daughter's drink Kombucha in the
morning.
That's fine.
It's less than half a percent,
so they're not getting buzzed.
Some preposterous amount of alcohol.
I would like to see how many drink to
get drunk.
The whole history of it.
They used to sell them in the store and
then apparently what was going on was
they were,
there were,
it's a strong brew and they would sit
there fermenting and then when they
would test them after they had fermented
for awhile,
the alcohol content would get over one
half of one percent,
which is like somewhere around where
they need to draw the line.
Like if you get a non alcoholic beer,
it's got a touch of the blues in it.
Oh,
really?
Already touched with buck off.
It doesn't matter.
Fucking idiot.
No,
it doesn't make you still super sober.
I mean if you look fucking perk.
Well,
we're running.
We're getting high as fuck.
Okay.
There's A.
There's an endorphin aspect to this.
I this.
One of the things that I was saying to
everybody is that when this was over,
when the whole thing was over,
if somebody made a pill that made me
feel how I feel when I have those hard
workout days,
I take that pill every day.
That's what I was going to tell you.
What the fuck pill that I felt so much
relief,
but I felt like it was totally tied to
days where I really worked hard,
like one of the.
If it was like a medium workout without
good,
you and I went back and forth about
that.
Yeah.
I still felt good,
but on the days where it was like three
plus hours of working out and I was
totally spent.
Then I felt the most calm.
I mean I know a part of that physically
just got tired.
I'd had zero strength.
Question.
Do you guys think any of that's tied to
like while you're doing it,
you've got to be off your all your
technology for awhile?
I know you're big on that.
I think that's a possible.
No,
I thought about that.
it's a factor.
It's definitely a factor.
I also,
when you started talking about it,
I tried to start doing things like in
the morning waiting or waiting to look
at it.
No,
I like open the phone so like just do
not even work out.
I mean just do life things,
wake up,
have coffee and just not look at it.
So I had to think about it.
Yeah,
it's hard.
It's hard.
Yeah.
I wonder how much of that too,
because I felt sort of clear too,
but same way I do with skiing where it's
like you gotta take your mind off
everything in a way.
Exactly.
Ari Be skiing is a perfect example.
When you're skiing,
you can't look at your phone,
you're going down a fucking mountain in.
You're just enjoying that and that's
part of what it is.
They've got a great app and they'll have
a great app.
No,
no,
no.
Look at my phone while I'm skiing,
but there was an app that tells you how
fast you get going,
dude.
I got an up to 40 miles per hour on a
fucking snowboard and you want to get
down to the bottom.
I'm like,
real quick,
what's my speed like?
Oh,
I,
I've definitely.
I'm always worried about people wiping
out in front of me,
wiping out onto me.
But you.
But you film your kids skiing a little
bit.
Yeah,
but I got taken out by one dude on a
mountain once.
He just cut in front of me like way too
quick.
He was like,
you gotta control your skin half the
time,
like I should go away for your own good
watch out and you realize like you're
testing your health out with all these
other people and most of the time people
were doing their best.
Most of the time comes flying out of the
trees over your drug test.
When you get on that fucking ski lifts,
they don't test you for shit.
Do smoke weed when you're skiing now
you're doing it wrong.
No,
no,
no.
Every time I asked we'd go with you
guys,
but I ski with my kids.
Adults now.
I wish I could explain.
I have to keep an eye on those little
fuckers.
Get care.
I get what you're saying.
When you see with your kids.
You do that with my kids.
I don't smoke weed at the end of the day
when it's me and Leanne,
we go to park city every year.
It's the best and at the end of the day,
me and Leanne,
I'll take a rip and then we'll go down
one the.
That's one I fucking throw in headset's
a little Jane's addiction.
I'm coming down the mountain.
All my toes flying into a fucking corner
at 40 miles an hour.
Just going.
Just thinking in my head.
This could all really go bad right now.
Don't fall down.
Don't get hurt.
Don't get her.
Didn't get hurt.
Don't fuck with us.
Just barely have any control of our
bodies as we slide.
Barely,
barely in control pizza.
No control over joke and roll shoulders.
I'll tell you what,
I'll tell you what I want us to do right
now.
I'll tell you what I want us to do as a
group right now and chose the only one
that didn't get this happen.
What I want us to go to,
Kelly slater's wave pool.
That looks dope,
dude.
A foursome.
It's the safest place to learn how to
surf and it's just like a two hour
drive.
Does anyone know how to surf?
I took two lessons,
Indonesia and master it and retired,
but I can come out of retirement,
so that's perfect.
So you've had slightly more experience
was almost none.
That would be a good next year.
What learned a certain time
on a board.
I'm on a board over the whole month.
We'll get Kelly slater to design some
sort of board that we have to wear some
sort of heart rate monitor.
How much time on a board you could stand
up over the course of a month.
Artificial wave machines.
Shit.
I guarantee you.
Give Kelly slater time right now to
develop the board that has feet pads
that measures your feet,
your feet when you're standing up.
So at the time on a board standing up,
since none of us know how to surf.
Fuck time on a board,
standing up one of those artificial
weight machines next year.
Kinda hate this.
I love this.
I love this already.
So you just have to enlist and a place
you have to give up your life list in a
place like why he was Shane Dorian.
Where those fucking sue shame was just
here.
He was on the podcast right before you
guys.
Who you fucking kidding me.
Who's using the,
the uh,
Shane Dorian almost died at Mavericks.
He got held under for two waves and he,
I guess under there,
he decided to create these suits where
they have ceo to carf juices.
It Literally Changed Big Wave Surfing.
It's saves so many lives.
He was just fucking shut up.
I swear I met him.
He's my bow hunting buddy.
Yeah,
he lives in.
He lives at a big island in Hawaii.
Damaging Joanna was just do Kelly
slater's.
He and I go hunting every year.
We do the,
uh,
the spring,
a axis deer hunt on the island of Lanai.
Really?
Yeah.
So fucking cool.
It's the coolest shit ever.
What got you into hanging out with Kelly
slater?
Podcasts was fucking amazing.
Like brothers.
My favorite thing he said in that
podcast was when he goes,
uh,
you go,
what do you do for fitness?
He goes,
I don't push myself.
That's an,
that's an already thing.
Well,
here's the thing.
What we did was not healthy.
No,
this is what I wanted to talk about.
Not Sustainable.
I'm like,
no,
bullshit.
No,
not sustainable.
That's crazy.
No,
no.
I'm going to keep up spin class and try
to do on evenings.
Try to do the six mile jog.
That's a good thought.
Keep up the 31st.
Like I talked to you.
I talked to everybody,
but that last workout I was dead.
I couldn't,
I couldn't have gotten that much
further.
In all honesty.
After my pis came out a weird color.
I really did have phantom pain to my
kidneys.
I really was like,
maybe that wasn't just dehydration.
Maybe there something more.
Maybe there's something going on.
I really did have some weird phantom
idea that there was a pain,
but physically I felt pretty good man,
because the whole thing was a lot of
that Rhabdo.
And here's the thing about,
it's called Rhabdo.
My locis is that I said,
did I say it right?
Rhabdo,
um,
has actually been the source of death
for a few fighters where,
um,
guys
got really beat up and it crazy,
really difficult fight.
And the thing that did the men was they
were probably overtrained and they
probably did too much and the gym didn't
give themselves enough time to recover
and then had a really brutal fight.
Oh,
right.
So when you're young in particular,
you're,
you,
you're a little too wild and you don't
recognize that there's like this point
of diminishing returns when it comes to
training.
Oh yeah.
Well see we pushed into some weird
place,
but we did get through that a few times.
But here's the three will,
should have liked.
Thought I was too much.
We got to give up and we kept going and
then it became okay again.
Right?
But here's why
I think it works for us.
It wouldn't work for a fighter.
No one's kicking our ass.
So the thing about when you're a fighter
is if someone's kicking your ass,
you might push even past where we pushed
in terms of output in,
in,
in any particular hour or any
particular,
you know,
half hour,
40 minute session,
you might go too far.
Whereas we would just keep going at,
uh,
at 80 percent sometimes you get forced
into 90 percent sure.
Long periods of time,
especially if someone's better than you
or especially if you're tired from
training.
So a lot of these guys are going into
the fight,
especially in like younger guys who
don't have maybe the most scientific
coaches.
They're going into the fight stout like
November first.
They're going through it like that.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
They're going into it like that.
Not only they going into a fight like
that,
but they're going through a whole,
you know,
six,
eight week camp like that.
Like they might be broken down like real
early on.
They just push themselves through the
whole thing and then they have like at
the end of it,
their body's failing and they haven't
given themselves enough time to recover.
And that's what this Rhabdo shit is
your,
your muscles and it has something to do
with proteins that your muscles pull up.
The actual.
Because I'm given a really stupid
definition of what rhabdomyolysis is.
Am I pretty close?
What is it?
Breakdown of muscle tissue releasing a
damage protein into the blood.
That's it.
And it's very dangerous.
Israeli causes kidney shutdown.
That was crazy.
That like November second,
my muscles all felt sore for the first
time all month.
Mine felt so right away.
And then not again for not again,
I just was,
I would guess,
get back into them.
The thing in spin classes like when you
get out of the saddle and sprint is I
just got to a place where my legs were
always fucking wasted and I was like,
I want to get,
I want to try this again.
When,
uh,
my legs just aren't wasted.
They were always wasted.
I could now at the end of this like run
to the gym and back I got stopped like
three times in the way in her run for
like two minutes.
I'm like,
no,
like real running.
Oh,
I.
Then it was like,
no,
just do it.
Did I felt like such an improvement,
right.
Huge them through the month that I could
run.
I ran 12 miles on the fifth and last day
while you were on antibiotics,
psychotics and you were just going fine.
I gotta say Ari,
I always knew that you had a strong
mind.
I always knew you had a strong mind.
You have,
you have a.
you're an angry man with strong mind.
But I didn't.
I didn't appreciate it as much as I
appreciated this month for you to do it
as the most impressive out of all of us
because you didn't do shit other than
the occasional hike or fuck around and
play basketball for like 10 years
years.
Yeah.
But also I eat well.
You guys eat like garbage to you.
I'm not talking to you.
What do you were talking to those two?
Yes.
Seventy five to 80.
I should be around one 75.
That's what you spoke about.
What you and I and I should wait with 75
to 80 and then I got up to like 83,
87 last year after the.
We waited like significantly more and
it's like I'm not doing it.
You guys were actually working out.
You can keep fucking normal idiots.
Oh yeah,
no,
no.
I actually towards the,
towards the end I started.
I'd hear a problem.
Maybe I'm the person probably listening
to this podcast the most for you.
Hear people talk about health and how
they eat and you and an onion that
challenge to the very last week I
started going looking at food a tad bit
differently.
Going like,
I don't want to feel like shit.
I don't want pizza.
I don't want.
I didn't want carbs.
I wanted protein because I get done a
workout and I go,
let's do four eggs and some mistake.
Like I ordered a bunch of Buffalo steaks
and I was like,
what?
It's so crazy as I'd never.
I was like,
water.
Yeah,
I need water and food is such a crazy.
Did you get like with eating when it was
like really on those fucking plane when
they walked by with a little basket and
I was like,
oh,
I'll take l this shit during the two
workouts a day,
the two days,
which had a bunch of net.
Yeah.
When I did the whole five and a half
hours on the elliptical,
I ate a box of animal crackers and I
drank a cream soda while you were doing
it.
While I was doing great soda,
it was crazy.
It was like I was possessed.
I was in the craziest state of mind.
I was like,
I am going to keep this going like I'm
now.
I'm going now.
It's just numbers to me now.
It's like,
when do you get off at 400?
No,
500.
600.
No.
Eight hundred.
No,
and then shit started to feel like it
was failing like our body.
Yeah.
No,
no,
no.
Some misfires.
I had some misfires.
I had some,
like my body was like,
Whoa,
like settled down bitch.
It's like,
we better get off this thing soon.
I was like,
okay,
let's just keep going for a little bit.
Yeah.
Then you said things started to feel
weaker.
Like my hand started filming.
We started yelling racial slurs and I
started feeling numb.
My toes went numb at one point.
Did you nap?
No.
Oh,
I would not.
Napping was the feet on the floor nap
where you're just like sending it back
for a second and say like,
what?
I haven't.
I just go out like a light at the end of
the night.
Yeah.
The Hours.
Were you sleeping tonight
like a dead man?
Seven hours dead man dead.
Yeah.
How long after we started did you start
having the marijuana
dreams?
So you got,
did you guys get them?
Um,
I,
I knew it was coming so I tapered off,
tapered off all through September and
also I was on a lot of harmony trips.
The elk hunting trip in Utah was seven
days.
I didn't smoke on those no together
dreams on those a little bit.
A little bit.
But you decided early on with all that
stuff that I wasn't,
I just wanted to experience it as a,
as Electra,
natural,
human and I didn't want to ever be drunk
and I didn't really want to be high.
I don't want to take Beta blockers so I
don't get nervous.
I try to experience it as a,
as just experienced what it is.
I saw Adam Green tree like kill some elk
and wherever the fuck he is these days
and a bear claimed it.
Did you see that?
He shot a moose?
Jesus.
It just went on and on it and I dug it
out.
Con and a grizzly bear claimed it and
covered it with dirt right away.
The entire Moose?
No,
he,
he shot it,
they took part of it.
See what a moose is probably like 1800
pounds.
They're so big.
They're like a big elk.
It like a rocky mountain.
Elk is like 800 pounds.
That's a big one.
A Moose is a thousand pounds bigger than
that when it's fully mature.
So something that's what Adam shot.
He shot a gigantic moose so they could
only carry so much of it out like this.
Hundreds and hundreds and hundreds of
pounds of meat.
Eighteen hundred pounds moves might be
seven or 800 pounds of it is meat.
Fuck you.
So you have to take it out in loads.
So if you have two guys,
right,
you're taking it out.
Several loads.
So they took out one pack out and then
they came back and the giant grizzly
bear had claimed it and covered it up
and the grizzly bear was still in the
area.
He covered it up.
Dude.
Adam green trees.
One of my favorite people to follow on
instagram.
But I know that no one likes when
there's a lot of little bleeps in the
story,
but when I go on out of greentree and
he's got 100 little dots,
I go,
oh,
there's going to be a good one.
Yeah,
it's Adam.green
tree on instagram and he's a,
he's a bow hunter from Australia.
And Australia is an interesting place
because one of the reasons why it mean
he's,
he's just a real smart guy.
And he said he's the real deal,
a real deal in every way.
Now I'll pick them as a person.
Dude,
he,
you should see the floor.
He hasn't.
His hunting cabin he took.
Dude,
this guy is like across the board,
every part of a man you want to be.
How he met his floor in his hunting
cabin is fucking amazing.
And he did it himself by hand.
Let's just establish per capita.
Australians are more manly.
Oh yeah.
The Korean Americans for sure.
It's hard.
Like if you had to like to see what's
the numbers at,
uh,
there,
there's the uh,
Moose.
This is there.
Just a manly,
manly or breed of people.
And also you have to realize that
Australia was a god Damn prison colony.
So these are the ancestors of
scoundrels.
They all got big films,
big humans.
So this,
uh,
this is a big ass moves that he shot in
the Yukon and a grizzly bear claimed it
and so they went back to it and the
grizzly bear had run off because he saw
them coming I guess.
And so they just stole what they could
and got the fuck out of there before
they panicked
for it.
Came back.
And so they,
they,
they buried the unburied at the dugout.
They did dig stuff and take stuff out.
But they were scared while they're doing
it.
And they got out of there.
This is the second of my friends so
fast.
This is sex?
No,
no,
no.
This is a third of my friends that has
had grizzly bear encounters over the
last three or four years.
Them who is the one that it was on?
I saw it on instagram.
What's one of your buddies who got,
who got charged by the grizzly bear?
I was Adam.
That was Adam Green Tree.
That was was that same guy?
Yeah,
absolutely.
Was it that documentary?
Grizzly man.
Oh my God.
It's the craziest documentary.
That documentary.
That documentary is called a gay guy.
That doesn't have really good friends
who gets eaten by bears.
Dude.
I was with a guy.
Wanted to give him a hug.
That guy he has fucked.
Yeah,
she.
Why did she leave?
And there's audio and they didn't share
the audio.
They shared the audio fucking.
That was my friend Adam
with a pistol out wild grizzly bears
charging them.
Watch this.
Turn it up.
His voicemail.
Yeah.
That's a grizzly bear.
And he's got a gun player and she's got
her cubs and he might charge,
you know,
she might charge them the,
the scariest ones.
The females with cubs.
Yeah.
That's in real life too.
What about the pistol?
Yeah,
he's going to pistol out.
And here's the thing,
the pistol,
it was the wrong size bullets.
So wouldn't have racked normally.
So see how it is right now.
It looks like he's discharged all his
ammo,
like his guns out because it's jammed so
he doesn't even know it's jammed.
So He's standing out there pointing a
gun that the only way can get a bullet
in it.
If he opened up the barrel himself,
stuck the bullet in and then closed it.
So we'd have one shot no matter what.
So the whole magazine wouldn't fit.
It was off the.
The differences in the size of the
ammunition was off.
You didn't see it?
Nope.
He didn't notice because he doesn't use
guns.
He's a bow hunter.
You only got.
He got a gun just to protect himself
from that thing.
Those kinds of.
I cannot believe how excited I just got
right.
Then just talking to him about it.
He goes,
mate,
he goes,
monsters are reel.
He goes,
when he goes,
when that thing was charging me,
he,
I mean I believe.
Did he talk about it on the podcast?
But when you talked about the way it was
charged him with the hair was popping up
on it and you could see it.
I mean it's,
it false charged him.
So I've charged him and stopped within
like,
you know,
five yards of him.
Wow.
And it's a giant female grizzly bear.
And
that would just tear you apart.
The only one is trying to get you to do
leave,
trying to get you to live live
because he's trying to leave,
but it doesn't trust him.
It doesn't know him.
So it's closing in on him and looking at
him and deciding maybe whether or not
he's a threat and moving in on him so he
can't get away from it.
So he was stuck in this position where
he couldn't get away from it.
It had decided that he was a problem.
So he was trying to get away and he was
moving to a different direction.
It was cutting him off and he was like,
Oh shit.
And he's got his pistol out.
It's like,
get the fuck away.
Terrifying.
But thinks territory.
The Appalachian trail when I was in
college and not the whole thing,
but just a portion.
And Man,
that fucking.
I didn't know.
You're a good man.
Grizzly thing.
It's fucking scary,
man.
Yeah.
They're so scary.
I've never seen one in the wild except
once in Alberta.
I've never seen like a big one.
The one I saw in Alberta was willing
only like six feet wasn't a big one,
whether it was enough to look in his
eyes and go,
whoa.
That is a different thing because a
black bear doesn't look at you like that
man.
Black bears.
If you run into a black bear and that
was.
They looked at you like,
what do you,
what are you on the east coast?
It's.
So.
That's spot bear,
right?
Well,
what it is is there's brown bears and
then those are the ones that live on the
coast,
and then everything that's interior is
called a grizzly bear.
It's,
that's how he gets the name.
Yes.
It's the same.
Adam,
what do you mean?
That's how it gets the name.
Yeah,
it's,
they're all brown bears,
but it isn't like a straight up brown
bear always.
Usually bigger than a grizzly because
they have more access to protein.
That's the thought.
The thought is that the Kodiak Brown
bears that enormous ones,
which are the biggest tall,
still way bigger.
11,
11 feet.
Yeah.
My other friend who got attacked by
Steven Rinella and he has a podcast
about it.
Uh,
on a podcast called media,
that's his podcast and it's all about a
fog neck island.
It's a two part podcast.
It's fucking amazing.
I think they shot an elk and then the
same thing.
They hung some of it up and they came
back to get it and after they packed
some of it out and when they came back
at grizzly bear it claimed it and they
didn't know it.
So they were trying to pack out that
food or that the rest of the meet.
And when they did a bear charge down and
ran through their camp and they said it
was 11 feet tall.
Who was he with?
He was with my friend Yonis and my
friend Remy Warren Warren Warren about
it,
my other friend dirt,
meth and these and maybe one other guy
going know all these hunters and I've
never hunted in my life.
I think there's like cameramen.
There was a bunch of people and this
enormous 11 foot bear ran through the
camp and they said it was the biggest
fucking thing.
It was so different than anything that
could've expected.
They said it moves so fast,
it's teeth were so close to them.
They said this like Rinella.
When he describes that he rainelle is a
brilliant guy,
but he's also a very well read guy.
It's very eloquent.
He has a degree in journalism.
He's like,
he's super fucking smart.
So when he describes this interaction
between
them and the 11 foot coastal brown bear,
which like the biggest bears on earth
next to the Grizzly,
the polar bears bigger,
whether like the coastal brown bears of
Kodiak,
Alaska,
that area.
There's big as those polar bears,
just the fucking most by the scariest.
Everybody wants to save him because the
Klondike bars and fucking call you.
She had the most ever when they.
They can sniff out through ice that
there's seals under the ice and they'll
just.
You'll just see the,
the like the wildlife footage and
they'll just sniff ice and then they put
their paws together and they start
dropping all their body weight,
trying to crack to crack the ice and
then they'll jump in and just pull out a
seal.
It's fucking nuts.
Do you think we could tap into that part
of our brains,
like there's a part of a human.
I don't have any polar polar bears.
There's a reason why you have an iphone.
You get a nice car.
Polar bear genes.
Somebody out there,
a polar bear genes,
so for sure probably some of y'all
fucked by a bear.
I got fucked.
Get fucked by bear.
You know what's crazy about this month?
Now I'm fucking pretty fucked up.
Yeah.
What's crazy about this month is a
inspirational people on instagram,
like to listen to them and to really
draw inspiration.
I got one more hunter's last name.
I'll say campaigns.
Fucking shit man.
When you go and put them one of those
days and realize he's running a marathon
every day.
Marathon a day,
a marathon a day,
but let me just.
In his defense,
he would never.
He would step in and probably say right
now that's not sustainable for the whole
year,
but what he does is when he's ramping up
for a big 200,
200 plus mile race,
he does a marathon a day.
Go to the opposite side then.
Do you know the story of marathon?
Yes.
With a guy went to tell them of the
victory and
he died.
He died.
He did the marathon that died.
That's who we do it after,
but that guy was a pussy campaigns.
No training marathon.
That's all.
That's the main message is not that you
should do marathons.
The message is the best way to kill
pussies doesn't make him run marathons.
I've Read A.
I've read sweating killed.
I'm asked before and I liked that he.
I mean he's sincere and I get it,
but he has to pretend to be impressed.
People tell him I ran two miles today,
but he
go,
hey brother,
great job.
Even though he thinks six miles
point blank,
what do you think of Bourbon in the
marathon?
He goes,
dude,
that's impressive.
Too.
Cynical.
Being cynical about a dude who wears
cowboy boots.
Most of the days.
Don't be cynical.
Campaigns is straight up.
I'm not cynical.
I'm cynical and I'm saying that I read
those comments and I lacked because he's
like,
good job to the person that like I ran
around a 100 yards,
a guy.
He's a good guy to me,
running a marathon.
That's impressive.
Of course.
It's a real impressive trying to tell
you.
He's one of my best friends.
The guys,
the nicest guy in the world and he
started out not being able to run for
shit.
He started out doing a mile and fucking
dying and going,
how the hell could anybody ever run a
marathon?
And then he just kept doing it and then
he got to this point.
We could run ultra marathons.
He runs 100 miles.
You know why?
He would definitely think it's
impressive that you ran a marathon
because he knows.
He knows.
He knows running so well and he's run so
many.
He knows what somebody who can run a
marathon looks like,
and then when he saw you,
he was like,
that's fucking impossible stage.
And you go,
how long did you do?
She goes,
an hour.
You'd be like,
what was really impressive?
If you know someone,
they've been doing comedy for a year and
then they tell you they just did an
hour.
You're like,
wow,
that's impressive.
But if you just got back from Memphis,
I go,
how much time do you do you go,
I did it now.
I go,
wow,
that's impressive.
Impressive.
What?
But it is impressive.
If someone who's like maybe one of your
opening acts go does an hour,
15 minutes in Cleveland somewhere and
you're like,
dude,
I killed.
It was awesome.
Like if you tell me that you did that.
I'm like,
yeah,
that's what you do.
You're an asshole.
So I did an hour and you're like,
wow,
look at you like you're a really a Dick
for saying you act like you're positive.
Of course.
Say if you had big.
Jay was like,
I did an hour and Madison like,
Whoa,
wait,
hold on.
It's our hour to an hour anymore because
I know a lot to lot to less.
Lots.
Three,
45,
3:42.
When I first started at $45,
the number,
it was 45.
Those are time comics from 5:30
and 15,
15,
30,
45,
which is an hour and a half show,
which is most people what they think
their attention span is,
which is like honestly it's kind of
accurate.
I mean I,
I think 45,
we're just too short to.
Ours is pushing for people's attention.
So like I think a 90 minute show.
I think our show is is right.
Well I think a 90 minute show I'm saying
put everything is a great show.
Make the mistake
of doing long sets where I did a lot of
standup and it was rocking and rolling
for awhile and then I do like q and a's
with people and would go on too long.
You're going to agree.
I don't agree because I know for a fact
that like it's not right for me,
but for you a q and a will be
interesting.
Yeah.
It wasn't that we wouldn't be
interesting.
It would be more interesting if people
didn't see an hour and a half a comedy
first.
See if that's the problem.
The problem is not whether or not it's
good stuff.
The problem is how much good stuff do
you want all day long,
which you want.
Nobody wants their Dick sucked eight
hours a day.
Like,
stop.
I got to do things.
You a counterpoint if you,
if you.
If you did an hour and a really solid
comedy and then was like,
all right,
now we're going to do a q and a for
awhile.
It's gonna be different than me.
Well,
you guys have bought your ticket for a
show.
It's like a whole festival that we got.
We did the stand up.
Now let's have some fun time.
Dude.
I think that.
I'll tell you what.
I think the closer you are to 60.
If it's polished and good,
that's the best you can hang on,
but we're.
None of us are all.
No,
I'm not doing that right now.
I won't say I won't speak for everyone,
but I'm not doing that right now in that
I'm working on my 60,
so in order to work on my 60 I have to
do because you're figuring it out,
but that's the most of what we tour is
not finished.
It's not finished.
It's a work in progress is not that 60
is the number that you shouldn't pass.
The idea is that like when you think
about it as a thing where people want to
see what you've got,
it locked down perfectly from start to
finish.
You really want an hour and a half and
you want your opening acts to do at
least 20,
25 minutes,
15,
and then I take the rest of the time.
I did a two minute show.
Nothing wrong with that,
but I like to bring headliners with me.
Agreeing anybody,
any.
You guys are welcome.
I bring Tony Hinchcliffe all the time.
Ian Edwards.
Those guys are headlining.
It is so funny.
The funniest motherfucker doing he is,
I would say underrepresented central's
comedy guy because he should be a
household fucking name.
I've been saying that forever,
man.
I started Tony.
Tony's Wyoming to shit on.
No,
I didn't mean to skip over to Ian since
like 1993.
We did a pauly shore thing in Miami and
Brogan was like,
who are doing with.
I was like,
Oh yeah,
I don't have.
I was like,
wait,
from what?
It was like 84 years started out
together.
Here's the thing about Ian,
he's a.
he's a brilliant writer.
He gets writing gigs on sitcoms and all
these other different shows and one of
the things about writing gigs is first
of all,
it's very convenient.
You don't have to go anywhere.
He stay in town and you get paid a nice
amount of money.
You make good money.
It's hard to pass up on,
but the problem is you're not out there
building your name in different cities
and building up markets and you're not
putting out a lot of comedy specials.
You only have one cd on team coco
records.
It's called 100 percent halfassed.
It's fucking hilarious,
but really you got to see him live like
his timing is
fucking genius.
I've known that guy forever.
He's the nicest fucking person you're
ever gonna meet to what he has in his
job,
his job,
because he's got so many haircuts sold
as a person,
half,
half.
He couldn't be a better person.
Be a better person.
Like I never had a problem.
You know?
I like about him,
most of the person when you're riffing
jokes around a crowd and they rely on
someone getting offended sometimes when
you say something horrible,
but since it's all comics,
everyone's like,
Huh,
yeah,
no one gets offended,
but Ian is going to be like that.
It's out there like,
Oh yes,
I need that.
You know?
He and I did a lot of gigs together.
We did a lot of gigs together,
sexual special garment of all my gigs,
getting ready for my last Netflix
special world with Ian or with Tony and
a couple with Santino.
He's great.
He knows a motherfuckers on a mother
fucker.
I liked so much about the shoes he was
wearing too.
These guys are coming up,
man.
Tony Hinchcliffe was murdering it to to
kill.
Tony is legit.
A sellout show.
It's a legitimate.
She put 15 people in the room,
him and wrap him.
Dude,
they are selling out everywhere they
fucking go and brilliant idea.
First of all,
Tony is,
he's so good at roasting,
so I'm good at that kind of shit.
That kind of situation where someone
might be with some of bombs and does one
minute and he's a little murderer.
Dude.
He makes me blush sitting next to next
to him and a light someone up and you
hit them and you go three steps behind
you.
Oh,
you already said that one.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I feel I feel it down my back when he
starts fucking good show.
The format is so genius.
Perfect mix.
They do one minute at the end of the
minute.
Redband gives him a meow.
Like time's up bitch.
Fucking fucked.
The whole combination is great.
Jeremiah Watkins,
Jeremiah,
Jeremiah.
Fucking multi,
half fat.
Half an it happened in fast.
Whatever the fuck that one.
Jeremiah is a fuck.
He's all over the map.
Joe Rogan.
Hilarious.
He's so funny.
Okay,
so when did this change?
When things change?
Right now we're talking about comics
that back in the day when we were coming
up,
no one ever gave us props for being
funny and young and right now when did
that change in stand up where everyone
was like.
It became a community where I wanted the
people see people succeed.
Yeah.
When I came up I felt those,
this weird unnecessary competition
between people because I had come from a
world of competition,
so I was like,
why are you guys pretending you're
competing?
You're not competing like you just like
there's a few people that are going to
get certain roles and things,
but the way to look at it correctly was
not that you're competing.
The way they look at it correctly,
in my
estimation was that we're helping each
other.
Like when I see you,
when I say you kill,
I get inspired.
I see some new bit that's like really
well crafted and and and hits me and
surprises me.
I get inspired and I think that that
when you see comics in a vacuum,
like I remember when I was coming up,
I would go in these weird tours.
We do a weird show and some weird town.
They had a local scene and the local
scene was almost always hacky.
Like there's a few scenes that were,
weren't Hacky,
like Houston wasn't hacky there.
They had a lot of pride and not being
hacky.
Boston was very,
not hacky New Yorkers on Hacky,
but Florida was hacking.
Right.
There's a few places.
There's a few places like that.
By the way.
What I realized what it was like,
oh,
they don't have anybody good that
they're around.
And I remember how bad I was when I
first started,
how hacky my ideas were,
how shitty they were,
but I got lucky that I was around guys
like Lenny Clarke and Barry crimmins and
you know,
and then after that wave it was Louis,
c,
k and Mark Marin and there was an,
there was all these guys that nobody
ever heard of that were really good but
super ethical about their material and
like really sharp about you.
You're broke the fuck meter.
You said fuck too much.
Like when you say it,
it ruins it for everybody.
Like they would explain like comedy
theory too.
That was like really high level stuff
that I remember thinking like,
why doesn't everybody just do that for
everybody?
Like all over the place.
Like what?
Why does everybody like treat this as if
there's like a famine situation going on
and there's a small amount of comedy
fans,
no bitch,
you can't be in Cleveland every night
and I'm going to be in Denver and you're
going to be in Detroit.
We're supposed to support each other.
This is so stupid.
We're the only people that understand
each other in terms of like what a
bizarre human being it takes to be
onstage or broken windows,
broken spotlight,
talking shit.
People will know how to do it.
So what was the change?
The change is the Internet.
This is why,
because before the internet,
everybody was like,
I want to be the next host that's
tonight show and Jay Leno retires and
um,
the next cone and,
but I'm on cable.
Everybody had this idea of being one
person who stood out in a limited amount
of slots.
And then the internet came around and no
longer was there a limited amount of
splott slots instead,
if you.
It's hard to remember.
But when I first started doing the
acting shit,
it's hard to remember what it was like
back then.
No Internet and everything was on either
NBC,
ABC,
CBS,
or Fox.
That was it.
And there's a few like vh one.
MTV things.
It was famine,
but they can choose.
There's also one person or one of 20
people who say,
yes,
you're in.
Yep.
And then that's it.
Either you're in or or you're not.
And this was for MTV and this was for
Hbo Comedy Specials and this was for all
these things and it was in that.
The
people that got through were very high
quality sometimes.
Sometimes a lot of them,
if you look back at the comics,
that become,
became big off hbo.
They have the best record.
Yeah.
Hbo,
Of all time.
If you add a judge,
Chris rock had HBO special.
Louis C,
k.
I mean Carlin Carlin had one a year for
how long they you put out?
16 for anyone could ever see it again.
Impossible to comprehend.
He did a new hour every year
and I would.
I went to one.
I got to see him run the either the last
one or the second to last one at the
store.
No fucking I wish.
And he was,
and he would run it always the night
before,
I learned later at comedy and Magic
Club,
which I live nearby for awhile,
but he got to see him do it at universal
amphitheatre when that was still a
thing.
And for his closing bit,
he had it written down and he told the
6,000
person audience he's working at like it
was a fucking 80 person room.
He told 6,400
people.
He's like,
this is how I remember this shit.
I got to fucking read it.
Right?
So then he read the whole last bit
because it was really wordy.
Oh right.
I was like a monologue.
And he was like,
this is how I ended up memorizing this.
So you guys are gonna.
Listen to fucking read it.
I got to see him on the court.
He would.
This is what he would do.
He would write a new monologue
essentially,
and it would tighten up a little bit
over the course of the year.
I've,
I've thought this was a dog the whole
time for some reason.
So what is it?
Just a cord?
I thought it was a dog.
And I was losing my leg.
They really are.
I was like,
oh,
that's a nice dog.
As it was my thought.
Really thought there was a dog in a
second.
I did.
And then I just realized that was a rat.
He just so calm.
Freak out my house because our cat
brings rats in the house.
Isn't it funny that were so racist
against rats,
but yet girls get a free pass,
a squirrel on the house.
I'm trying to put a net over it and
bring the little fellow outside.
There is a rat.
I'm trying to kill everybody that's ever
met before the fucker.
Someone said the only there was between
squirrels and rats are their tails.
And that's not totally true because rats
carry playing.
And that's why we have an apprehension
about them to go fuck himself with a
shitty advice.
Scrolls forever.
Yo.
Fuck off.
World's team.
Squirrels on what were we just talking
about month?
Here's one thing that did happen to me.
I want to tell you guys,
this was over this month,
freak you out.
Like when it was over,
when it was all said and done,
like November second,
maybe I woke up and I'm like,
what the fuck just happened?
How did I go from living this like
completely normal life of podcast
guests?
You have cj to being involved in this
fucking insane battle to the death.
Yeah.
I mean,
you know what else,
what else occurred to me is like,
this probably doesn't occur to you
because of your history with working
out.
But I had that exciting but
disappointing thought of like,
wow,
you know,
I can't believe how much I was able to
do.
Oh,
I can't believe how much I'm able to do
and don't,
don't.
Yeah.
And that's like the last five years,
that's like a Merman.
Right?
To me it was,
I was like,
I could be doing a lot more than these.
Do you want to be doing a lot more?
I don't think the key to be.
It's definitely not.
It's definitely not to do what we did.
If I could get there for an hour of
running and an hour of weights twice a
week,
I'd be like this amazing ahead of the
curb.
Great.
That's health.
Yeah.
I mean a good number.
How many?
Two d?
Two days of two hours.
Two days to 40.
Five minutes.
Forty five minutes.
Two days.
I do too.
You know,
it's a bad idea for days.
At half hour.
Wait,
what are we talking about this for?
Just a half an hour.
Yes.
No,
no,
no.
This changed my whole fucking way of
looking at working out.
This is what I gotta do an hour,
but you can certainly can or if you're
being Tom,
you do.
You can do on our hard.
You could do half an hour hard.
There's A.
There's a DVD that I follow.
It's called the kettlebell extreme
cardio workout by this Guy Keith Weber,
who's a past guest.
Does the dude that is by himself in a
fucking room.
He says a couple different variations,
but one of them he did on a beach.
It's the one he did.
He just takes a 35 pound kettle bell and
you're like,
how hard could this be?
Thirty five pounds is not heavy,
but you do it for 40 minutes.
Forty minutes with that,
without putting it down to one of those
tests.
Yes.
Tommy,
give you a little breaks.
Bought this.
I bought this because of this mother
fucker going dark.
It's impossible.
But here's the thing.
After it's over,
I could barely walk,
can barely walk.
I was hobbled to my hamstrings and my
quads were destroyed,
but I did the second to last day I did
15 minute rounds with a guy with myths
up and down,
down.
You can see other people's stuff.
You'll see some yellow with the yellow
white stay above 80.
What did you think about when you were
doing it?
I thought about I was trying to get my
legs a rest and then uh,
so,
so that was what prompted me to start
it.
And then when I would do,
when it was doing it,
I would just think about points and burt
and then I would just point where it was
a great motivator.
Motivator.
Just one little,
just heads up,
seriously ahead,
so you're welcome everybody,
because all of you were beating me and
there was a part of me that definitely
felt very alone.
That's not true because I never thought
you could ever beat me.
It wasn't.
Here's what I was doing.
What I was doing was punishing you
because I wanted to take you on a dark
dark
of all of them,
your insecurities and all of your
thoughts of mortality.
I wanted to take you into a place
you could never travel.
We're going to go to the bottom of the
ocean.
Motherfucker.
As soon as I saw these numbers
and uh,
and you're saying going to do double,
I went,
okay.
And I told you I didn't get me mad.
You didn't get me mad,
but you,
you made me open up the door to the dark
place.
First of all,
you realize that when I was doing the
videos,
they were all for comedy of fact.
I understand,
but that doesn't matter to me when I'm
in competition with.
I did the video where I go,
Joe,
I saw your numbers.
I'm doubling them.
I came up with my dog and then I
pretended to lose my dog.
Everyone thought that was real.
I was like,
my dogs had five knee surgery.
She definitely can like the canyon.
That was so funny because he definitely
knew you were joking,
but he was like,
I don't care.
Just in serve me to think that you're
joking serves me right.
It serves me to take you very seriously
and to take her to the dark place.
I'll tell you what,
I heard you talked to Nikki glaser.
I heard that and I was like,
what?
I was trying to kill burt.
He goes a week after she was here in di.
Just put it.
I hope it doesn't die.
You did not say.
That's how I felt.
I hope this can be my new favorite clip.
What is,
but I should just be really clear.
We are right after bird his head.
He's going to double my score.
Right,
and I'm like,
you're fired up by this.
This is.
Hold on,
hold on,
hold on.
Listen,
listen.
Listen to him.
There's not a part of you that respected
the conor mcgregor.
Dare you compare yourself.
Hold on.
Greatest mixed martial arts.
You have all part of the entire nation.
You know conor Mcgregor,
you know how many people can you and can
I say that whoever the fuck is in
Ireland,
what were the connor would love bird
fucking.
If you said Connor,
you got one hour to party with one
hanging out with one guy.
He's picking me Bro.
Shit ain't asked me if I would like to
talk to them about a teacher.
I have some thoughts.
I want him on your podcast.
So bad man.
I Dunno.
We're supposed to do it a long time ago.
I had his trainer on really recently,
you know,
I hope he doesn't think that in any way
that I don't respect him or appreciated
him because fighters are like super,
super sensitive.
Like I've gone through that a few times.
Like I called Tony Ferguson who's like
one of my all time favorite.
Literally one of my all time favorite
fighters.
I said he was a brilliant Weirdo because
he wears like ankle weights.
When he got mad at me,
he got upset and I had to talk to him
and I try to sort it out.
I did it through someone else and I was
like,
what?
No,
no,
no.
Like that.
It seems like that,
but what it is is so
exposed.
It's what you're doing is so personal.
It's so insane that you like what we can
brush off.
It's way harder for them.
What will you.
If you lose a fight and someone
disrespects you or they they in public
sentiment keeps you from getting a title
shot like that.
So that's a significant part of their
life.
They're not used to dealing with public
reaction.
They used to dealing with his
competition.
So the public reaction thing of
celebrity.
It's an afterthought.
It's something an after effect of
competition,
right?
You become successful.
Then you have to deal with all these
people around you.
They want you to dance.
Well,
economy,
Mcgregor's and natural shit talker.
He's a great fighter,
but he's also a natural shit talker.
You want a buffalo bar?
Yeah,
Dude.
That's what I love about conor Mcgregor.
Conor mcgregor,
Bernie Sanders on.
That's it's a weird situation that you
haven't had either one of those people
aren't.
I tried to get Bernie recently.
He said no,
some fake Bernie contacted us.
Oh,
you say you got your hat,
right?
Yeah.
I was.
Had.
They got me and I said,
I'm a big fan of like a lot of your
ideas.
I'd love to have you on.
And then it was really not commodity
here though.
I don't think he wants to run for
president man.
Why would he show his ideas?
I don't know man.
You know what I fucking love by the way
about conor mcgregor is that he meets.
He made me really appreciate the
athlete.
Who knows they're also an entertainer.
Yeah.
I actually,
you know,
there's,
there's people that did that like,
I mean everyone would probably give
credit to know why it works.
I don't know why that's who he is.
We'll be talking shit and sparring.
Just guys that are just funny.
Locked on him is fantastic and he's
smoking weed.
Had Mike Tyson by the way.
Mike Tyson owns a god damn weed farm.
What is it called now?
Yeah,
what is it called?
Jamie?
Make that smaller place so we could read
what the Hashtag is.
I'm used to God.
Damn.
They used to say something about Tyson
something or another.
Did they edit it?
I didn't see it on there earlier.
I look.
Huh?
He's fun.
He has some sort of company.
They're growing weed.
Mike Tyson's growing weed.
That's wild,
right?
It's really tricky about the UFC because
I love Mike Tyson was building a 40 acre
wheat farm.
Bam.
Oh,
cabinets will be there.
Is that in Nevada,
California?
She kept California.
Just do that,
but I do have to tell you,
I just read the first one.
Boxer,
Oxford and rapist.
My clients say that.
It does say that it does that really
mean person.
Root stock come bro.
Seriously Bro,
I made to open your article here.
You.
Oh,
all bullshit aside.
There has to be some way.
That's crazy.
It's crazy.
There has to be some way for people to
bounce back from horrible things.
Right?
He did.
He definitely did.
He would be like front and center.
Very buried in it.
Like dude,
I met Marion bearing on the open,
the Anthony Show.
Yeah,
that's right.
And as soon as he came in,
I started asking them about crack.
You just went straight at him.
We were all staring at him and Joe was
like,
oh.
My thought was like I had someone
trapped in the corner.
Like I had a,
like a,
like a wounded thing in corner just in a
hallway looking for his next interview
and Norton rundown here and come on in
here with us.
I just brought him in.
They,
I like,
he's going to run,
he's Kinda run.
Would you say to him,
I said,
did you smoke?
Crack it?
No,
no,
no.
And I asked him about that.
What you said.
You said what a testimony to the
American spirit you are,
that you can come back from all these
things and managed to like reclaim
yourself and become mayor again of men,
of,
of uh,
of Washington dc despite everything he
went through yet.
And he goes,
what?
I go through.
That's right.
And he said,
that's when he said,
he said,
no one knows this in that pipe.
I go,
what did you say to me?
No one knows smoke crack,
smoke,
crack.
No one was.
No one else was in that Bible.
He didn't even say didn't smoke crack.
I think he'd already realized legalees
at that point.
So I don't think he said.
Did he say I didn't Smell Peter?
Who didn't know?
I think he said no one knows what was in
that pipe.
Yeah,
yeah.
No,
no.
This is some Jujitsu.
You just get under hooks on that are
frozen pipe.
Joe said,
well,
what did you think you were smoking when
you smoke?
Whatever was lit it up.
What did you think was going to be
there?
I knew we had took off where you left
off.
That's what he's like,
Eh,
you got me.
Good.
Well player,
we had to get them quick.
You got to get this guy quick.
This guy's kind of try to do a Tina.
I'm here to say hi to DC and house.
Thank you very much.
Vote for me.
Yeah.
Hi.
Come and say hi and bolt.
So I just had to grab them.
Can I say this?
That I got a letter when we registered,
I was like,
I don't know how to do.
I was so mad about doing this thing in
the first place.
I didn't want to get talked to the sober
October again and then we call me to do
it next year.
No.
Yes,
no.
Wait a minute.
Was there any.
Is there any penalty for this about.
Hold on a second.
I know everyone,
so everyone's.
Let me pee.
Pee.
You gotta drink piss.
He let me.
That recovery.
We appeal to your fiscal sensibilities.
What if next year we got a sponsor?
Like I just want to tell you guys,
this is like one of the most popular
podcast we've ever done by far.
It is this whole series of podcasts are
doing from the weight loss podcast to
last year sober October to this.
Why would you call it weight loss fat
challenge podcasts?
I'm trying.
Positive Bro.
Thank you man.
Be Body positive yoga man.
Sure.
Curve is exactly where it's supposed to
be.
This US competing random points either
like every quarter.
Okay.
But you guys,
here's what's your greatest show of all
time.
That's not going to happen.
I'm busy.
You're busy to quarter.
Once a year would be a fucking holiday.
What's he is?
We invent our own holiday.
Okay.
But you guys listen.
I understand.
I know what it's like.
You have babies.
It's okay because your life to other
things.
But I have fun.
All legitimately be doing fucking
November.
December,
January,
February.
So you're in.
This is ridiculous.
No one else in my life.
My life.
Mine too.
You were great this year.
You did great job Bro.
You did a great job.
I took the last day off.
You could have fucking 4,200
points.
He uh,
he told me,
he was like,
well you just got the last detail.
You just fucking sink up and just let me
know if I have to get back on the
treadmill.
Hold on,
hold on,
hold on.
You guys were all talking independently,
so just talking to the group here or
there.
This was last day.
Last 700.
Everyone against me.
Hey,
give me another cocktail.
Daytime dates out of workout.
I'll have that one.
It's Japanese stuff that's from todd
one,
all these fucking awards over the
Scottish.
They get all mad about it.
This is a shout out to my friend Todd
White,
who I do Jujitsu with,
who is now a head instructor of John
John Machado,
Todd White Jujitsu Academy in Austin,
Texas.
He's also a brilliant artist,
super famous artists,
and he sent me this because he's
beautiful.
That's a great,
great scotch.
Tried whiskey.
Nice past some of them.
Isis Thomas.
By the way,
I go to your mom's house whenever I want
to know what kind of weird nonsense is
floating around the Internet.
Who's eating shit?
I guess so happened.
People to death to hold right now is
garth brooks.
Oh my God.
Tom and Christina.
Cheers to this.
Uh,
this um,
what is it called?
Hold.
We shouldn't even have this.
Wait,
wait,
wait.
No.
Already.
Powerful purist.
What are you doing?
Okay.
That's good.
Thank you.
I'll do it.
I'm dealing with it.
I'm telling you,
you can click him.
Deal with his own thing.
The name of your next tour I'm dealing
with.
Cheers.
It was awful.
Guys.
Why would we not drink during October?
Doing it again?
Stupid.
Is it a New York City thing?
You've got to understand what it's like
there.
It's the best month to drink in New
York.
I would walk by bars and longingly
going,
I want to go in there now.
I don't know what that feels like.
The whiskey is good.
Did you really turn 53?
Shut up.
Wow.
Brad,
you and your fake news.
Hey,
will you say bird is 53?
No,
no,
no.
Well,
you know,
I'm lying.
Bernice,
for Joe.
Burdens burdens 53rd.
Meanwhile these guys,
I'm 51.
I know.
That's crazy.
He's two years older than you.
That's not set.
Bird is down 50.
They changed his birthday and wikipedia
and everything.
Who's going to win this Arrow when the
surf challenge next year,
because we're going deep.
We're taking the month off.
How many have you lost?
Now?
Challenges.
This is a second,
but here's what's important.
When nobody.
Nobody lost.
I couldn't believe they already put it
on.
Your computer is off.
You can suck my Dick.
Do you understand what kind of fake news
you're dishing out?
Oh,
you guys have to wish Berta happy.
Fifty third birthday.
The other day was yesterday.
Was it yesterday?
Two days ago to make me feel bad because
I'm 24 months away from what you're
making now,
but.
But it's already doing.
When I say I'm 51 is that.
First of all,
that's insane.
But you realize when you're 53
[inaudible] 55.
Oh.
Also other people were happy about that.
They're like,
it looks good.
You Dude,
I can't control it.
I cannot control fake news.
You try to because you're like,
hey man,
I'm not the fattest comic ever.
Performing status.
Spread some stuff about you.
Oh no shit.
You fucking aspect.
What'd you spread about them?
Nothing.
Everything you said was just reported,
fastened on necessarily bad.
If you got all your bases covered,
so much weight and still managed to have
that belly,
it doesn't make sense to lead a skit.
That mickey mantle gene crazy.
Stop saying that again.
Double down.
What I loved,
what I loved about tour by
the way,
will validate the Mickey Mantle gene
because birds tour is like 10 shows a
week back to back weeks me.
It's a real Mickey Mantle Shit.
A lot of shows where it's like,
I don't want to just lose my family.
I want to drive them away completely to
what I was thinking about.
How much fun would you have had a back
in the day?
I really think standup was totally
globally different.
If you were on the road with Joey Diaz,
Ari Shaffir red band in a tour bus,
it had to be more fun.
Oh,
you guys would've had a fucking insane
time.
Did we had so much fun for bus so we had
so much fun I've never had of before.
I don't need it to bring more fun.
Never hit a blunt.
You don't know like Ari and Joey and red
band and Dunkin,
like the road trips that we went on,
the fund that we had,
we didn't need more fun.
No,
we just needed to appreciate what was
happening.
What was happening.
We had with no one.
I'm good.
Damn,
no one wants to drink.
Do you want one tell you I feel.
Where were you being cited in the uh,
I did the bus this weekend.
Yeah,
I fucking loved it.
I love the bus.
I did.
I liked it a lot on accident,
son.
I've been.
Can we change subject?
Not in a bus.
Pretty common.
Yeah.
The plane crashes.
Oh cool.
Cool.
I know you're fucking with light tanks.
You know when you drive around looking
diner seat,
you're not wearing a seatbelt.
Bitch.
That's true.
Cool.
Miles an hour down the highway.
No seat belt.
The fucking 80,000.
But you'll just run through shit.
Bodyshots world tour every tour bus from
January till April.
She would feel like if you listen to my
voice and you heard it in your head,
the moment your face was hitting the lcd
screen,
that would suck the moment you were
flying towards this screening.
I remember this moment.
I didn't know that was going on.
Dude.
Just fucking take the day off and fly a
lot of it.
But you're looking at me.
I'm the one doing most of the time.
You're not going to craft.
That sounds pretty awesome.
Joe.
Come out on the road with me.
Listen,
bus.
God.
Goddamn stadium tour boys.
I'll do it to her.
Still drop my entire night.
Two thousand 19 toy.
Hold on,
hold on.
Hold on.
Why don't we do for kids to get through
grant.
Just start.
Giant.
Show a big.
I don't want to hear this.
Pull back.
No,
no.
Listen what I'm saying.
One giant show everywhere.
Madison Square Garden.
Forty five different cities.
Something show.
Listen,
we could do that tomorrow.
Here's the deal.
If each one of us did a half an hour,
we've got a two hour show.
I can do it half an hour right now.
Yeah,
me too.
Oh fucking love to do half an hour.
That's all I got.
I got 35 minutes,
maybe 34,
morning more.
We'd have it pass it are the worst
fucking friend.
I am the best friend.
I love you.
Do not love.
Love you.
Love who loves who more mirror you.
I love you.
Wow.
That's some bad shit.
Are you fucking kidding me?
You really didn't.
You love me more.
Who Do you think loves who more?
I don't.
I've never thought about that with you
already.
I haven't seen it already more than it
loves to know that I never thought
disorders of mood more than a low
volume,
but now they love him more than he loves
me.
Now.
What do you think?
You guys are both.
Faggots not going to be tied into this.
That's rude.
I feel like I don't.
I don't have a meter.
I don't have a love meter.
Burt,
love your job.
I would stop almost dying.
So.
Oh,
so tired.
Like run to the top of the hill or dope
or whatever.
Joe Goes.
You realize that?
Oh yeah dude.
I'm conor Mcgregor.
I don't think you understand.
Okay.
So.
So Tom went,
when we got this thing,
I was like,
I want to do this.
And Tom was like,
I'll register.
You can register.
Like I'll register.
Here's a number.
Get registered.
Yeah.
Um,
and then you didn't say anything with
burt.
I think.
Anyway,
I got an email about the 10th or twelfth
of October from some lady at snap
fitness in Shawnee,
Kansas.
Hey Kelsey,
you know,
you're accidentally registered in my gym
and we are doing an oct challenge.
Yeah.
Um,
so I think I should take your off.
Currently you're in third place and then
what did you say?
I was really sees me first place at the
time.
I was like,
I can take you out,
but I'm in a pot.
I'm going to podcast challenge with my
friends.
Rogan said Thompson Gaura and Bert
Kreischer and go,
oh,
Bert Kreischer.
He's in sixth place in our legit Jim of
people trying to work out for a second.
You were like,
oh,
Bert Kreischer.
It's
love him.
She just knows you is big be Christ.
That's my God.
Oh my God.
No.
I know words be on the leader board,
but I have to be honest,
as humble as I try to be.
If she said,
oh,
Joe Rogan Joe Rogan,
I'd be like,
oh,
she likes me.
I probably.
The way I recognize that because that's
exactly how I see this fucking name on
my board.
I'd be like,
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Anyway,
so I was like,
yeah,
you can take me off.
Just make sure my points,
I'll start over and she goes,
you know what,
actually,
that's cool.
I'm going to keep you guys on there.
Do you understand that?
We got better as a score in terms of
like how well we did in comparison to
most people with zero point one percent,
which is much higher because it makes
sense much higher than Elizabeth Warren
is claiming that she is.
That's what I'm saying.
Do you?
Not Crazy.
We did.
What we did was bizarre.
I shout out to impact fitness out here.
That's what you're registered with.
Did you ever go to the gym?
Work out there.
It is.
Keep going.
So Micah,
Brian and Sean worked out with them a
month.
Wow.
Did they do get personal trainers?
Yeah,
those were the guys.
Oh,
I met a dude yesterday,
Yogis?
He was like,
let me fly you,
put you on his legs like a baby holds
you up,
stretched you and shit.
He was like,
Hey,
do you know Bert Kreischer?
I would love to do that with him.
And I was like,
do you normally do with like two people
on one guy?
And he said,
what do you mean get him up?
He goes,
I for sure could not get them up.
That guy was anticipating a human
centipede on a trampoline.
Oh my God.
What's that one?
That swings.
Yeah.
Trophies.
Right?
When Santa Pete was the three of you.
I love that.
We all went to the.
Who Do you think?
Do you think we're not doing this all
the answer,
Tom.
Answer.
Rel.
Not Answer.
Do you think you'd love not joining
this?
I'm missing all my friends.
My friends like me.
You guys,
you're crazy.
We focusing on the wrong things.
I spend more time with red.
So if one of you try to attack,
are you?
I have a problem with that.
All right,
go ahead.
I,
I've been friends for too long,
but like that doesn't make sense.
It doesn't compute.
This is my friend.
We got to work this out.
We gotta figure out.
I don't know you as well as I know him
for a million hours to know you for
$400,000.
We did really well.
So what the fuck went wrong?
This.
That's just how we're all.
We all have to kind of be so I don't
love anybody anymore.
One of you,
if one of you,
if we're on an island,
you got to eat somewhere.
Oh,
you know the answer,
Bro.
Let me tell you something.
I'm starving to death for eight in a
year.
Yes.
One hundred percent kosher eating
cereal.
One body.
Tell me to eat me.
I don't want to stay alive,
man.
One hundred percent problem.
Pull you aside and be like,
who you want to kill,
bro?
Get the eyeballs.
Rogan's ass.
Problem is you don't want to die knowing
you ate your friend and it didn't
matter.
I don't want to die.
No,
you.
Here's the reality.
If you hadn't said this in this scenario
is real.
There's three of us would be so paranoid
about you killing us that we would
definitely kill you.
It will be like everything's cool and
you and then we would take rocks and
just.
No,
no,
no.
How do we kill that won't be touched,
but over here for the last seconds.
So tonight we got to throw.
I'll get the big rock and you get the
other rap.
Seriously,
we have competed against them.
How do you think we would go about
killing?
We would have to make them think that
we're definitely not thinking about that
and they'll be like,
hey guys,
we're still thinking about it,
but we would try to be slick about.
No,
no,
no.
We'd sit by a fire and then I would go,
hey joe,
when you eat marijuana,
does that break down differently or
deliver the number 11 hydroxy real
quick.
No,
you got to thick that.
He would be thinking the same thing too,
so he's like,
oh fuck.
I would never turn it against these
guys,
but for sure we're not thinking about
it.
They think if I could turn against him,
I would have to kill the king of Judah
immediately.
Got To accept the fact you're going to
starve to death.
That's what you gotta do.
You got to accept it because if there's
only four in the woods and we're stuck
on the top of a mountain and no one's
gotten to us yet,
what are the odds they're going to get
to us?
What?
How much time?
We have left,
like 30 hours.
If everything goes great,
truth is are you would wither away
first.
No.
Here's the real truth.
I've just been thinking about it.
He tried to say immediately,
guys,
I see what's on both of your minds.
You're all thinking of killing each
other.
I get it from both points of view.
If we do this,
we're never going to survive.
I propose a truce.
Joe,
go hot food.
Start to fire the cook.
Obviously Tom,
I don't know man,
cause football is just trying to take
you know a lot about that.
It was just us,
just us living in the woods world went
to shit and we're like on an episode of
life below zero.
We live in some sort of fucking house
and we have to put together ourselves.
We'll make it just like we got through
this weird month.
Okay.
This is fucking strange about being a
person is that you don't know what your
boundaries are,
you just know what you do most of the
time,
so all of a sudden when something comes
up that requires way more of what you're
used to putting in a more way more.
Jude,
but isn't that fucking with your
perspective at all?
Being a fucking tournament already.
We are middle aged comedians of course.
So you go like,
I'm not doing enough.
I think you already go.
I'm not doing enough already.
Okay,
so then when you have that thought and
you do a month like that and you go,
I'm really not doing it real.
Yeah.
What I try to do is eat healthy.
I fuck hard,
and then it's also a combination of all
those.
Fuck white chewing gum.
I thought,
that's fucking impressive.
Bazooka bubble pop.
No bubblicious even better than Bazooka.
Much stronger with the shoe store or
something.
You're like,
yeah,
y'all went up to the rest of the week.
Five Gallon Tub of it for my daughter's
softball team.
Fuck,
five gallons.
Good.
Damn,
dude.
Welcome to fucking drugs.
That's what I picture red biggly Chu
laying pipe bag bag.
I can't make.
I can't make it to where the fucking the
strap.
While I was going to ask you if you
were,
you said something about my cock fast
and hard.
That was the name of one of your posts.
Hold on the last day.
I put it on right at the end though,
but I was like,
you know what,
your heartbeat goes down fast.
Yeah,
yeah.
By the time of one,
kind of like one 70 12 points for sure
if you checked off in Phoenix for
jerking off to all points were jerking
off.
I got done the workout.
Went up to the room.
Heart rate's still on,
still in the blue.
You know what,
you shouldn't hide it again.
I sat down,
it got up to the green,
never gotten to the yellow.
But uh,
I had to,
when I was doing it,
it wasn't moving out of the gray.
His sit down,
you're watching.
I had to
watch it.
Uh,
interesting.
I had turned off the Bluetooth because
it was based on my headset,
so I just worked off and it cut off the
monitor and so I thought it was a dead.
Yeah,
it cut off the Monitor.
If Your Bluetooth was on,
it didn't register points.
Right,
right,
right.
So you can't have headset but you can't
have had sets.
No,
no,
no.
I cut off the heads.
That's how I got here.
The porn on my phone,
so I cut off the Bluetooth so I can
watch a porn.
Oh.
And by the way,
I had to sit down like a catcher.
I had to squat the Jack off to try to
burn,
to get some movement going.
So I was like,
I was like,
yeah,
so I'm squatting,
I'm pumping up a little bit pumping and
yeah,
12 points,
but I was afraid of him register
terminal.
That's a fun points.
Points.
Hey,
that's three minutes,
four minutes because you're in the
green.
I don't think I wasn't added wrong.
You know,
in a lot of those Kung Fu classes,
they make you do a horse dance and they
make you hold it a little while to a
horse dance stand like this and just
hold it really make you stand for like
40 minutes,
40,
40 minutes.
No,
no,
no bullshit.
Yeah,
there's a lot of really wacky ideas
regards to Kung Fu type training and
some people would just make up their own
protocols,
like standard horseshoe course stance,
stand there for one hour to put your
hand over the flame for as long as you
can.
It's also like,
it's also the same thing that happened
to us this month.
Like how much can you do?
It's crazy.
It was completely.
It didn't make any sense.
Psycho you fucked it up.
No,
no,
no.
School.
Go to the bathroom,
go to the bathroom.
He's got to pee in a bottle.
No,
no,
no.
I'm going to go to the bathroom while
he's doing this because I don't want to
go again.
Come on,
let's go.
Come on over.
Let me think about it.
Don't even think about it.
Think about it.
Did
you get to you joe,
are you.
There was a great month.
I couldn't believe I did.
I didn't that it was a lot of fun.
I,
I couldn't believe he did,
but I,
I,
I wasn't completely surprised.
Really?
Yeah.
I was happy.
I was happy that you showed me.
I always like we've been friends for a
long time and I've always said like,
he's just got this like very strong
mind.
Like you're not,
you know,
you're not a guy who gives up on shit
and you're a guy who thinks through
things.
We've had many comments about that.
So those last few days I was like,
I think if I can get like rafting,
they go to sleep a bunch of points and
then right after they wake right before
they wake up another bunch of points,
which was like into my beginning of my
life into my night,
I could break them mentally,
get like 700
above them.
Yeah.
Then you rubbed me right then like,
hey man,
you're pretty smart.
My key,
I think I just got them like the 29th of
October.
Yeah.
You got deep,
you got pretty deep,
you got in,
you went.
I mean,
there was one day that you ran 15 miles
and I posted that on my instagram.
I was like,
do you understand that already didn't
work out for 10 years.
He ran 15 miles and then he wrote two
kilometers.
Yeah,
yeah,
five meters on the 500,
500 meters,
five kilometers with rowing and then
biked for like 15 miles is ridiculous.
I put that shit on instagram after that,
I was only out of spite because the only
thing that can drive me,
it's just pure spite.
And what was the spike?
What was the motivation?
Hated all of you for dragging me into
it.
I already decided I didn't drag me into
this.
I had no intention of doing it.
My life was fine.
My life is fine too,
man.
My life's good.
And everybody's like,
first of all,
every one of these challenges.
It's just been a shit Joe Rogan to all
redoing the contest.
Bring this one out.
That's my surfing.
Surfing.
Surfing is going to be amazing for this
shit,
dude.
We're going to the pipeline in the
lineup.
This is it.
This is us.
There's already an the tracker and
everything for the fuck shot thing guys.
I live in New York.
Locked Ari.
Ari?
Ari is locked.
I think I might have logged it.
I didn't know that.
That thing locked every door right
before he goes through it for boogeyman.
I thought it just wasn't coming in there
and you were smiling.
I wasn't coming in.
I had no idea that I thought you were
not coming in.
I didn't know why.
I was like,
I don't get it.
how is that?
Not a bit.
I thought that was definitely a bit out,
but I didn't shut it.
I was saying births like every door he
goes through lucky,
lucky man comes through,
but it's not what I sound like.
What does that feel like to have.
Actually that actually means is you're
very distinct of everybody.
Everybody can do an impression
basically.
I don't know if that's the state.
The first person I've ever heard do it
was red band.
It really caught me off guard when he
was like me,
me,
me.
Me,
me,
I got to do an impression of you.
We can definitely do an impression of
red shirt.
Say Last Colt,
Colt,
Cabana,
wrestler.
Oh,
okay.
Really?
I thought it was some Jewish thing sort
of starved.
David Cole.
Shoot Scott the first podcasters.
Colt Cabana.
Really?
Yeah.
Yeah,
yeah.
Well who was the first ever?
Was Ricky Gervais' first counter into
the mainstream,
but what about um,
uh,
the guy from Adam Curry,
the God pod father.
Was He the first?
Yeah,
but,
but what does the girl was doing it for
awhile before we should probably
establish who is first,
right?
Like George Washington,
who was the first president.
We're all professional comedians.
Most professional politicians would be
able to tell you who the first fucking
president one idea.
We're like,
who's the first podcast here?
We really don't know.
Right?
Dude?
I heard radio,
radio,
and then it just became who?
Lewis first?
Between you and Marin?
Ma'Am,
for sure.
For sure.
Yeah.
I don't know.
I'm asking to stop.
Here's what I think that Adam hurry was
number one who's hurting.
Curry is vj from MTV and he is known as
the pod father,
but the guy that started podcasting,
the marriage model,
I don't know her,
his relationship history,
but I think he's the,
he's,
he's George Washington.
Who is Adam?
Adam Curry.
How early was he was up.
He faces number one then the first big
one where you were,
but no first one yet.
Uh,
I,
yes,
I would argue that.
Or is that Adam curry definitely is the
procedure basis according to Wikipedia,
which were basically always right.
Always right.
Which by the way list or a thing it says
53 fake news launching.
Keep up with these trolls.
Two thousand six.
But,
uh,
in June 2005,
apple added podcasting to the itunes.
So it was already going.
No,
no,
no.
Ricky Gervais' had a red,
a BBC show.
No,
no,
no.
His show was launched a year after Adam
Curry's,
after podcasting was added to itunes
where it was.
I was already going as a few talking
about.
Yeah,
right.
No,
but Ari's point is valid.
It was already there,
but it's not.
You're talking about different people,
right.
Started in 2004,
who's was two years before company
Libsyn,
which,
but wait,
you're saying apple was started and then
a year later podcast,
let's just google this for a goof.
Who was the very first podcast started?
That's how.
That's what I.
and that's where you failed at located.
Wait,
let me just chime in,
but the ones that come up with
information,
we don't have to get to start asking
more questions as I was looking through
this.
Excellent excuse making.
You're making A.
I prefer you get back to the doing,
which you used to do it for you.
Jamie,
back to celebrity.
Under correct thread to start off and
said it was Internet radio because I was
going to say I.
I was recording Internet radio talk
shows and you were a lot.
No,
no,
no.
Let me jump in right now.
So there's a different suite because
myspace was offering an app on a phone
where you could do a podcast.
That's where the money stop for a
moment.
Jamie,
if you.
If you had a guest,
who do you think was number one,
but by me?
What did you think of it?
Like Adam curry gets the credit for.
I believe it.
That's what I mean.
That's what the international podcast,
the very.
I think he invented the name podcast.
Oh,
my pointed to him and that wikipedia
article,
he invented the name,
I think Jamie.
Jamie,
something real quick.
He does the podcast with.
There was another guy was like a science
tech guy.
Some guy named Bob Doyle,
or sorry,
I had it.
He was a bomb,
but it should be noted that Bobby Kelly
definitely had podcasts way before this.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
That's the worst gets tricky is podcasts
were released on my space through an of
phone who's called podcast.
A memory.
I've had a podcasting.
Yes,
Jamie.
Jamie,
You've been here for,
I don't know how many podcasts.
Everybody loves you.
What is.
Do you have a favorite podcast?
Seriously,
because you've witnessed so many people
that I've.
That I've sat through and you've sat
through that to be number one in the top
three that comes to mind over here.
It looks like the one we did last year,
this was pretty good.
That's probably for sure up there.
It's one of the best.
First of all,
Yoga when we coming down.
Getting Chuck.
Come on.
Yeah,
that was fun.
What else?
One of those.
One of the first fight companions
because that started a whole series of
things,
so that's memorable to you for sure.
Anything else?
An individual at podcast now if they've
all kind of know.
How about a guest that really like you
go like,
Holy Shit,
like kid cuddy and Maynard was probably
my top two for like,
wow,
that's maynard's.
Maynard James Keenan had asked.
I'm sorry.
Listen,
you got it.
With these one of these have done is
enhanced our friendship.
Some work and get closer to your
friends.
Jamie's got fucking close to each other
this month.
Let's talk about this.
Especially with Youtube.
I really like you too.
I feel like I really click with you.
Fucking you fucking asshole.
During what time?
It was like,
Hey,
I think I'm injured.
We could bring the separator play this
fall.
You're putting in Nashville,
Tennessee,
right here in the place where we've got
inducted into the hall of fame.
Great Room right here in the country.
We're on the world tour today.
The stadium tour.
There's going to be fun.
I wanted to call it the big stadium
tour.
It's just stating to her above is all
the information on it,
but when we talk about today is we're
going to introduce five cities before
Christmas to on sale because
on insights rug you guys asked for a
longer planning dates so you can plan to
be.
Shows me,
generally it comes to cities.
St Louis where we're kicking it off of
man was weird.
Phoenix,
Glendale,
Arizona.
Cardinals play a stadium as well,
so those are the first two.
The other three will be announced here
shortly and again,
they'll all be on sale before Christmas.
And remember,
this is all about game day.
Show his guard thing day or garth day,
however you want to look at it,
your full color support your team.
Let's go have some fun and let's get
physical plan music and I like that.
So weird.
Here's the thing.
Three.
Jamie,
why you just take it by the way we got
to say this.
Garth is an amazing performer.
He's so many people's favorite.
He's the top selling act.
He sells more tickets than beyond.
Say that dude is other level.
They sold that Notre Dame stadium in
like under a fucking hour.
Like just unbelievable.
Like it's out of control.
He's been so famous for so long that I
think he really thinks like what are,
what are normal people like,
you know,
like how much does a bottle of whiskey.
He'd be like,
I don't know,
10 grand fucking have any idea,
and his social media is really awkward
and it's the best thing in the world
right now.
It really,
really.
It really is the announcement that
social,
that facebook one that you know,
was it,
you saw that one?
He's like,
well I guess it's official.
Christina just posted this video.
I'm obsessed with the garth brooks and
it's so fucking amazing.
It's amazing.
It's one of the best videos I've ever
seen that I watched over and over and
over again.
So you see your wife posted earlier with
the lady getting hit in the head with
the fish.
Oh my God.
This is one push post.
Hashtag.
Hashtag ask.
Garth asked me anything.
Okay.
Hashtag happy.
Hashtag.
Hashtag Mr.
Year,
what year it stopped this.
Jamie,
what does that stop this?
He does that thing where he does this.
He also knows he's so famous and his,
his wife's famous but she's not asking
why.
Wait what?
Yes.
Yeah,
Mr.
that's why he goes to Matt.
Mr Yearwood.
So he does that thing where he's like,
I'm Mr.
Year,
what I took.
My wife slept for the,
you know,
just to.
Because I'm just like y'all,
my wife's first name to married Trisha
Yearwood.
Yeah,
they've married for awhile.
Okay,
go ahead.
That's great winters.
He's just,
he's just.
I think he's very sincere.
I believe it,
but there is something fucking weird
going on there and I think he's got a
couple of bodies in the trunk.
I just don't.
I think there's something going on.
I think it's somebody.
You know how,
how there's something about like when
you watch,
when you were or you remember back to
Michael Jackson and you're like,
that guy got weird for obviously,
but also how in comprehensible is it to
be as famous as he is?
Like my was Michael Jackson,
Garth Brooks,
like for me the part that's,
that's a reach or whatever is that none
of my friends were ever like.
Amen.
Do you hear that new garth brooks track?
Like I don't have anyone in my life
talking about him,
so it seems almost like a,
like a foreign entity,
right?
Like I just go to the country fans.
Did you ever lie to save and stuff?
I don't know any of it come from country
to country.
Sure,
sure.
Of course.
Yeah,
it's,
it's everybody I know.
If you look at like all time fun
drinking songs,
that's one of them.
Damn.
It's close to number one man.
Tried to relax and not worry about which
fucking rednecks drunk enough to relax.
You have a couple of kilos in.
Yeah,
I can appreciate it.
Dude.
I have.
I want some clint black shit.
I have some Hank Williams stuff.
I'm not knocking it all together.
I'm just saying he's not somebody that I
regularly or that I even talked to
someone who's like,
I'm going to Garth Brooks in general.
So waylon jennings and his social media.
Is that special?
It is remarkable.
Amazing.
It's amazing.
He has a show where like he,
whenever he,
he's so famous,
they,
he'll just post.
He'll be like,
we're inside studio g right now.
He calls it studio g?
Yes.
Doing that with your,
your podcast.
I'm already doing.
I'm already.
He does funny,
like he does weird waves where he
doesn't know how to end a video,
so he'll just be like a CV at this
stadium this weekend.
You'll just wave.
It's hilarious.
It's the best thing I've ever seen.
It is pretty fucking amazing.
I'm obsessed with it now and I found it
through him and push.
Yeah.
It's a,
and I don't know if he's kind of video
yet,
but even,
you know,
Vic Berger,
the editor,
he's so.
He used to,
I don't know how he pulled.
He just pulls the best content,
edits it amazingly,
and he,
he put up a bunch of garth's instagram
stuff.
It's great.
Or just go to garth brooks story.
Just make your own decisions.
We should do a stadium tour where we
just get,
get comfortable.
Was that what he says?
What physical?
Physical for the music physical out
there while we're making you like what?
Let's get physical or doing comedy.
I like that.
You're like comedy.
Who Do I call comedy physical because
here's the thing.
He was like,
we're going to do this in stadiums where
normally use football teams.
So were your favorite football teams
uniform and then let's get physical
while we're making these.
What is weird about it?
You know,
like my dad would say.
Yeah,
go ahead.
Sorry.
There's a weird thing that happened for
a little while where if you,
if you were to theatrical comics would
get upset at you.
Like if you,
if you moved around too much,
you got physical.
He acted things out.
People would literally like shun you.
Like there's a few people have thought.
Yeah,
yeah.
That was a style for a while.
I remember hearing someone talk,
I want to say it was in the movie
comedian Jerry Seinfeld going,
if I have a bit,
I'll act it out because if it gets a
bigger laugh then that's the purpose.
And I remember feeling vindicated,
so super physical when I started.
Man,
it's a weird thing.
It's weird.
Why would any bell so embraced looking
like more shit than I do naturally?
So it'd be like if this shirt has a hole
in it where to do a set for awhile,
for awhile I was like,
oh,
you should look for some reason.
I don't know why I bought into that.
I was like,
you should just look at your mom's
house.
Fans are taken out of a batch.
Oh Shit,
you're right.
Wait,
why do you wear what you wear on stage?
I wear things that are curious because
um,
you but you don't like you,
you dress specifically,
which as a guy who's wearing no shirt
and people go,
oh,
there must be no thought in that.
I go,
wait,
no,
there's totally thought.
He had to wear a shirt.
Yeah,
she took me a second to recognize it.
yeah.
I'm the guy.
I thought that was the whole time.
There's another guy that's doing that
though.
How many guys?
Your official influencer?
Chippendale's,
joking.
How about the stars?
Network spots is a chippendale comedy
network rolling in every week.
Hold on.
You say you don't look it.
Do you put thought into what you were
though?
Yes.
I wear things that are a loose,
loose your,
your hand,
your wrist or never buttoned.
I want Lucas.
I want my,
my all the muscles too so to
be covered.
Everything to be like a non form
fitting.
That's like the opposite of me.
If I wear anything that's form fitting,
I get uncomfortable generally or just
for a taping on everyday.
Everyday.
Otherwise five were informed.
Pending.
Yeah.
People go,
oh,
somebody needs to fucking your shirts
that fit like I can't wear shirts that
fit.
You can't even find them.
They don't feel like I've tried.
They're like Joe Rogan's trial.
No,
I get that.
I know.
I understand that.
I'm saying from their,
but I get it because there's also.
Have you ever done like where you go,
I'm going to get like a bunch of clothes
right now and you put on something that
feels cool,
but then you look in the mirror and
you're like,
this is too cool,
too cool for this.
It's way too cold for the stage.
Yeah.
You got to wear something that makes you
feel cool enough and relaxed.
That's the main thing.
Comfortable loose.
You can just google wedding or something
where you could just cool among your
friends.
It's like,
I'm dressing cool,
but if you're like,
if you put it on,
you're like,
oh,
I look like I look like I'm trying to be
Jason Statham right now.
I'm going to be there for jeans,
man.
You know what I mean?
Like you're like,
you feel like you're like,
you look in the mirror.
That's who you think you are.
Oh my God.
What the fuck?
That's his voice.
Oh,
I love this.
I just hope that we do this.
This is so much better than fucking
elliptical machine for five and a half
hours.
That was worth it though,
but not fuck that.
Fuck that.
Most of the time,
most of the time it was actually go fuck
to add pressure.
Next year we're surfing.
No one serves.
No one can practice.
I promise I'm going to listen.
Can we get coaches?
No,
no,
no.
Me Garcia.
I want Brad Gerlach.
Whatever you want.
First name grew up wanting deserves.
Here's the deal.
You can do whatever you want.
Once October.
Get started.
If you want to hire a coach,
100 percent.
Yo,
if you wanted higher up here.
I grew up next to closest sebastian
inlet.
Exactly where that is.
I like you.
I never liked Keller.
What's up seven?
Seven to,
let's do coco case Kelly to Daytona,
Shane Dorian or Kelly Slater,
teachers surfing,
because all the time probably a ton of
real surfing instructors treat you,
bitch.
You ain't going to be a world champion
teacher.
I got to sit down with you and there was
like,
and I'd like to try stand up.
Can you help me?
Right?
Like,
no,
let's not do that.
Oh,
I wouldn't need another drink.
This is the best.
You know the drugs.
I remember one time with buzz when we
went to Hawaii.
Yeah,
and by the way,
true.
You did see that video
video in the universe.
I'll just tell you,
it's better if you don't see it,
Tommy.
I,
I'm Tommy shaves my back and then he
goes back and I go,
Oh,
I've seen that video I to,
to him.
And then he went in Hawaii,
his tits.
Beautiful job.
Oh,
that makes me laugh to this day,
man.
So a world tour and stadiums,
stadiums,
arenas is a good start though.
The place where we can get arrested for
ridiculous shit.
Where would you go?
Seriously if I said hey.
Um,
how's uh,
how's if we start in March,
you want to start doing some half our
stadium sets or arena set?
Let's say arenas.
Yeah.
Let's figure out where we're going to
go.
Let's get together and sort this fucking
thing out.
Boy.
Yeah.
That sounds to God damn fun here.
Let's start there.
Start there.
Let's have some.
God Damn Madison Square Garden.
Let's start there.
Would you want to do staples center?
Like what would you want to.
Have you ever had a calm and tell you
for real?
Not Joking.
Sincere that you can't follow me.
Oh No,
no.
In this room.
Oh No.
Wait,
what the fuck?
Who says you have been?
It's not good because I can't say it.
I'll tell you off my.
Just whisper it.
Map it to us and we won't say it.
Say this.
Can you say candyman candyman?
No Way.
We'll pass it to write it down and not
even a chance underneath.
Know how paranoid I am.
Of course that's not gonna happen.
Let's just write it down.
Hey Tom.
Good for you.
Keeping it together.
Fucked up and drunk.
We can better.
Totally.
About how should we have reservations
right now for ear whisper.
Whisper,
whisper.
Phone booth.
I'm not doing.
I'm not doing it.
I'm going to tell you bitches right now.
I take all my secrets.
Tommy first.
Oh,
now on hard core.
He's holding onto him.
You bitches are loose lips.
His fault doesn't mean I have a bolt for
both drunk.
Don't tell him.
Do not telling them no,
no,
no.
Fuck you guys.
I told you.
Seriously.
I'll go through fucking CIA shit and I
will not tell your secrets.
I promise you.
I believe you.
I believe you told me something was a
secret secrets.
It's ridiculous.
You told me this is a fucking secret.
People could break my fingers and I
wouldn't tell them.
I promise you.
What about you?
I'm not saying Shit for real.
I'll tell you a secret.
You could tell you.
Oh Shit.
I'll tell you the actual order of who
can keep a secret,
who cannot tell us.
Start with where.
Who's bad?
Who's the worst of the worst.
Honestly,
and this is not an insult,
you should tell bird secrets if you
wanted to get out,
but you don't want to come from you.
It's like a source source.
Yeah,
that's right.
Deep throats,
visual secret time.
Arctica and shit.
Bird.
That's trick and secret briefcase.
Full of bullshit.
I'm curious
what's next?
Blog.
Yeah.
He puts him on next that you did not
want to tell to Joe.
Rogan is next on that list.
I agree.
Keep a secret.
Sometimes.
Sometimes you cannot file it into
significance or it's possible though if
you don't make it very clear that it's
like fucking Goddamn it,
but I'm always looking out for your best
interest.
That is true.
He will always also a friend your
friend.
Yeah,
I agree with that.
Til this point I always thought then I
was the most vaulted,
but the way you talk make me think.
He might also be have my understanding
of what someone shared something with
you that just dies with you.
If you tell me that that dies with me,
I will never betray you.
Well that's true with it out once it's
out to everybody and be like,
oh,
just so you know,
I knew about that 12 years ago,
but there's also different levels of
people telling you something and there's
stuff where like you make the judgment,
you're like,
listen bullshit.
And then there's stuff where you're
like,
this is a little more serious for
somebody tells you something and it's
actually something that could affect
their life.
Yes.
And there's a zero percent chance I
would ever use your head.
Don't say that I ever told me something
like severe.
Yeah.
I promised you would never have to worry
about me saying anything to her after a
couple kids.
What's that like?
I've jumped off a couple of kids.
Fine.
Don't say it this.
Okay,
cool.
Can we talk about this?
But if one reality is that sometimes one
of your friends will say something
that's disturbing.
Yeah.
And you're not sure if you.
You have talked to somebody about it.
Oh,
like I think about killing myself or
like.
Yeah,
but I'm not thinking.
I'm not saying this in terms of that had
these kinds of conversations.
Do I talk to people?
Didn't understand how to deal with that.
I,
I didn't know anybody who'd,
who did,
who had gone to that place?
Yeah.
I'm close to killing myself.
Place,
you know,
I've,
I don't.
I've known people that have killed
themselves,
but I never knew anybody who confided in
me that they were thinking of killing
them.
Yeah.
I've never had that either.
No one is close.
As you and I were,
you and I had spent so much fun time
together.
So much traveling on the road together.
So many gigs.
We had a lot of fun,
so I.
I didn't understand.
I was like,
you were really hilarious comedian.
You're a professional comedian who doing
what we all want to do.
Everything is happening and then you're,
you're depressed.
I'm like,
there's a.
here's a situation going on.
I don't know what the fuck it is,
but it doesn't make any sense to me.
Yeah.
No,
I didn't.
I've never had anybody confide in me.
Like that's a different kind of
confided.
That's when you're like,
let me make the best one I think is the
decision instead of just going like,
I don't want to share this.
Yeah,
of course.
It's fun.
It was.
No,
that's it.
That's different than,
you're fine,
you're fine on that.
You opened up about some shit that I was
like,
okay,
I don't,
I,
I can't be responsible for this.
Just based on my own personal judgment
because I don't,
I don't understand this that well.
And I was like,
I got to figure out what to do.
And then I reached out to friends who
told me about psychiatrists and then we
got together and we.
But you're fine with that.
That's making the decision to like,
oh,
that's a good share information.
Yeah,
definitely.
You're like,
hold on,
let me think about that.
I'm talking about secret.
Yeah.
My thing is,
if you're going to make me find out for
myself,
I'm going to tell fucking everybody,
but if you tell me,
if I tell you you're going to respect
it,
I will absolutely spend.
I think you and I are on the same level
with that where it's not a question of
what the line is,
is just know if.
Exactly.
If some.
Especially like if I were to tell you
this is a no,
you've never fucked me up on it.
Don't even be a question.
Of course wouldn't come out.
Yeah.
Unless someone brings it up in
conversation and you're like,
oh yeah,
of course this happened.
If you tell me no barriers so much,
I don't even think about it.
I would sell you or sell you out.
I would not tell you.
I believe I've never send someone out to
exempt judgment calls
sentence whether here's the thing that's
true and I am here.
They tell me to not say anything.
You just got to be clear.
I appreciate that level of a friendship
to where somebody goes.
I will call you out on some bullshit.
I also,
I'll say this.
I think burt,
if you told him this is a definitely a
secret.
Yes.
He would definitely not sell you.
I high.
That's
great.
No,
no,
don't tell him that.
No,
no,
no.
It's been out one time.
One Times.
Bug Son.
One time.
I gave up already within 12 hours.
I've never ever told you this.
He told me to see her,
but I didn't understand it.
Like I understood that it was a secret,
but he didn't say it was the way you
wanted it to be.
A secret.
This time we went hiking and I was like,
Hey,
I have a secret height.
Can I trust you to not share the hype
with you that you won't share with
anyone?
And you're like,
yeah,
whatever,
man.
I'm translation.
What the fuck did you say?
A secret.
What?
Say it again?
He had a secret.
I don't know what I said.
He said I had a secret.
Who did you start sharing secrets with?
You told me a secret.
Well,
October and,
and he and he goes,
don't tell anyone.
And within 12 hours I told the secret.
I didn't even know.
I don't even know that I told it.
I don't remember that you don't care
about.
It's does not important
to me.
It's not a,
it's not a real secret.
You the other day,
I'm not gonna say who buy more on
everything,
you know,
but like I've told more secrets.
Should you not be about to tell me this
because it seems like someone's secret
and you're like,
I get what you're saying.
I'm going,
I'm going to say he did say that.
He goes,
maybe you should never tell anyone what
you're going to want to hear about us
and knows he's joined it.
Hear about it.
But just from your point of view for a
second,
it seems like you're worried about
telling this guy secret.
You being able to say nosy Jew is such a
beautiful thing because it lets you set
your nosy brow.
Really no one else in this room can say
it.
We're a nosy people,
but it's a,
it's a.
You have a free path.
A prepass too.
Nosy Ju.
Yeah.
No.
See,
I barely say it in reference to my
friend.
Me saying you saying it,
you get me in trouble.
It's not quite the n word,
but it is the j word.
It's like,
you know,
like it's like low in the my zone
points.
Straight red.
That's red.
What's yellow?
That's my favorite.
My favorite hands down.
What the fuck?
I just said show the uh,
going to be okay.
Folks Square Garden made my favorite.
Edward argument is when like the old
guy,
the old white guy goes like,
well,
why can they say it?
Green light or that guy's super racist
that he's like,
he's like,
I don't get it.
Give me an explanation.
Why do you want to just stop saying it?
But it's like,
why are you pretending you need that?
Explained to you what's the most
underlooked racist thing in this
country?
Asians and Harvard,
they literally just like this past year,
they literally make it more difficult
for Asians to get into Harvard.
Didn't than anyone else because so many
of them getting in,
which was amazing.
Super performance.
It'd be all Asian and then 23 percent
is.
That course is much of crazy.
I thought the men,
they'll remember it.
Was this like this when you were growing
up,
were like in my high school,
the standards for the,
like the standards that Asian families
put on their Asian children through the
roof,
they were,
we had a top 10 thing they give away.
It was 80 to 90 percent Asian.
Well,
you know,
I literally grew up from 15 to 21 around
a ton of Korean people.
Bertrand 53 last week.
Run a ton of Asian people.
Yeah,
they're worth work ethic is insane.
The way they problem solve is different.
So when we lived,
we went to a Korean,
uh,
grade school and ga and Eila would have
a hard time doing homework with Leanne.
And one time one of the Korean moms
goes,
why don't you just switch up?
That's what we do.
We never do homework with our children
because our children won't give us what
they need,
but they'll give a stranger what they
need.
Korean moms were switching up and doing.
The moms were different.
Kids to Asians are next level.
Next level.
Do you see Assad mythologist thing?
What did you say?
You play that back over,
sir?
I said you guys my registration.
Proof of insurance.
Hassan Minhaj fuck man.
Work with you.
Is he a friend of yours?
Why don't you know how to say his name
was?
He's great,
but party coming from birthday party.
The homicide,
he's.
He's a great comic is.
I don't know if it's funny per se,
but it's really good.
I haven't seen it either.
It's really good.
It's the thing on.
But that's what it is.
First thing is about a whatever.
Dude.
I'm fucking hammered.
Am I gonna?
Try to talk like this.
He said,
hey you guys,
have you guys seen I just want to go to
go to surf camp?
No.
No surf camps.
Remember,
we can't do any surfing until October
first.
Okay.
Let me ask you guys a question.
Shoot.
This is what Nicky said.
I want her to show after after this.
And she goes,
yeah.
She goes,
what's your say?
It seemed like these guys all decided
we're going to do some thing and they
called you and you're like,
what?
No fuck.
All of you know what?
What was the plan to come to Las Vegas
Pis and flying.
By the way,
everything was set until your fucking
ass.
Get on the phone.
Thanks.
Everybody was in agreement with voice.
Listen,
I've been a friend for a long time.
He's treating me out sometimes.
He realized right now you'd be on a Gulf
stream.
Fucking [inaudible] man.
Stop.
I turned to for advice guys.
I'll reward though.
We should have a reward.
I got.
I got something out of this.
We're going to present you with the belt
is working to get that there on the
stack of weed.
I would like to say pulp fiction bottom,
my instagram for more details.
Okay.
Actually,
let's present the pulp fit.
It's more like creep show.
That's without the werewolf that lives
under the stairs.
Creep shows they perfect.
That is perfect.
No damn crate.
That's the creative creep show.
Felt so bad.
Okay.
I would like to ladies and gentlemen
work for this people to present this
belt.
Thank you very much.
The ultimate,
by the way,
the fact that we actually did this was
nuts,
and I would like to
say on behalf of me,
one of the three non winners,
I won't say losers of the sober October
of fitness challenge Joe Rogan,
much like Jesus before him where there
was nothing,
and then there was winning Joe Rogan.
You have achieved the champion of
Sobrato October.
Physical Challenge.
I already should.
Fear presents you,
Joe Rogan.
This belt saying you are the champion of
sober October.
I just want to stay for the record.
I was most impressed by you and then if
you had been exercising as long as I
probably would have died trying to
defeat you.
Great job.
I.
Yes sir.
I was not impressed.
Come on over to present the belts.
Well,
it's already on.
I'll just say this.
I was a joe you showed us.
Definitely what time it was was all
second place and you definitely got
that,
so congratulations to you Ari,
but Joe,
your in better.
Here's a huge shocker.
You're in better shape than the three of
us.
I think that had a factor.
That was certainly a part of it.
How much energy you could put out.
We.
I'll put it in though,
man.
We all worked our ass off,
but it's ultimately is about trt.
Is that tight enough or not even like an
advertisement?
I'd love.
At some point we're like,
hey,
really does go to show you the steroids
could help it.
Athletic Challenges.
This is why it's illegal.
They have chemicals.
Now you've had doctors tell you get on
it.
Oh,
100 percent.
Yeah.
I've had several particular at a
certain.
There's a certain point you cross over
as a person where you go,
how much time do I have left to have 40
years left for 50 years.
Wait,
when did you first have that thought?
I mean,
I know you can have many times.
Let's say when you took it seriously.
Sleep.
30 something.
When I was in my thirties,
I would see my body not responding as
well,
and I was like,
oh,
where's this going?
That was when I really started thinking
about it.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Because,
uh,
I started seeing like I was working out
really hard and uh,
and as a boxing fan,
I always knew when a really good boxer
got into their thirties,
you had to keep an eye on them.
They might sour instantly.
Yeah.
They might get knocked out all of a
sudden and they couldn't take a punch
anymore.
There's this guy named Doug Dewitt,
he was like this bad ass middleweight.
He just could take a punch like nobody
else.
Man.
It was crazy.
Like this guy could just bang on the
Chin and people would be freaking out,
like,
how does this guy take punches like
this?
And then one day he couldn't take them
anymore.
They just,
it was a cumulative effect of all the
punches landed.
But it was also an age,
like almost all of the great champions.
They get into their thirties and they
just fall.
They start
to slide where you freaked out.
I mean,
at the or I don't know how much,
how much did you question hormone
replacement or anything like that?
Like did you freak out about the thought
of it or you know,
I didn't freak out about it.
I just wanted to see like what do smart
people who studied that think like what
do they think?
And they were all,
how was it there?
There's a bunch of things you can do,
like this is like,
and we talked about this,
we were talking about,
um,
if,
if you've got a good doctor,
they're not going to just put you on any
kind of hormone replacement first.
First thing they're going to do is
exercise you.
You're going to check your blood,
they get a check.
Your vitamin levels are going to ask you
what you eat,
how much do you sleep?
You know,
how stressful is your life?
They're going to try to sort things out
that way first.
That way your body is at a more optimum
level.
And for a lot of people that's all they
need.
They just need more sleep,
less sugar,
less processed foods.
You know,
do a little weight lifting,
do some squats,
dead lifts,
things that boost your testosterone and
maybe you're a 34,
we just tired after work and you can
kick that shit back into gear.
Cut out the milkshakes and all the
bullshit.
Yeah,
you could probably kick it,
kick it into gear,
but then there's guys that are like 49,
50,
51,
57 and they're just fucking tired.
They're just tired and they go and
there's,
here's your options.
You can keep being tired or you can get
your testosterone replaced and you're
not as tired anymore.
He feel like a person.
You feel like an actual person,
not like a decaying person because
that's a lot of what makes you feel like
a decaying person is a body's lack of
production of hormones and this is
what's really important.
They they think this is the case with a
lot of people that have had head
injuries.
I think this is one of the key factor in
depression for people that have been in
car accidents.
People who had been beat up,
people that have been,
that have had a lot of head injuries,
your by stopped producing a lot of your
hormones correctly,
[inaudible] your pituitary gland gets
damaged.
So for all those reasons,
like at a certain point in time,
whether it's 50 or 60 or 70 or 80,
you got one except your mortality and to
accept the idea that there are certain
things that have been discovered
scientifically that can enhance the time
that you have left.
Right.
So you either you either like dive into
them and listen to science and an
experiment trying to figure out what
works best for you or you don't know
it's up to you.
This month was a real introspection into
the like watching a.
I literally was like.
I was like,
man,
I think my lifestyle.
There's a lot of things that I could fix
before I added things.
You know,
if you know what I mean.
Like get off blood pressure medicine and
drink less,
but it's huge.
You would.
They would a good,
a really ethical doctor would go to that
immediately.
That would be the first thing they would
go to.
They would say,
you got to just fix that because listen,
you run a fucking marathon,
man.
Yeah.
It sound like you're a loser.
You're a fucking guy with an iron.
Will you figured out a way to run a
marathon when very little training,
you know,
and then you did.
What does that stupid Spartan race thing
that shouldn't say stupid ridiculous
Spartan race running around throwing
fucking sand bags and shit.
Like what are you doing?
Yeah.
Like you do a lot of Shit,
man.
I like to think I'm very goal oriented.
Like if I set a goal and I do go,
oh,
I got that coming up.
I think it helps me.
I'm not the kind of person that you just
kind of float in the water and not know
what I'm doing.
I think it helps everybody.
We're just unnerved by the expectations
of any kind of challenges that we
subscribe to.
We just decide,
okay,
we're all going to agree the whole month
of October,
we're just going to go crazy and do
cardio five hours a fucking day and try
to kill each other,
pushing each other.
It was great.
It was a 100 day.
I heard that one.
10 and one surfing.
Surfing,
surfing,
surfing would be really weird.
Did you discover anything through
sobriety?
You know,
here's what I discovered.
Sobriety thing is good.
It's good pipes,
but what's more important is
understanding how different everything
feels when you work out for four hours
or whatever it was.
The average.
If you looked at the whole month,
I probably worked out for hours.
Yeah.
No,
I mean I probably did.
There was not a five and a half hour
days.
There was,
um,
there was quite a few three hour
sessions,
three hour sessions at night and he did
a lot of weights also.
Which points but gave you like fucking
tons of time.
Well,
for me it wasn't even that.
It was like,
I just have to mix it up or I'll go
crazy.
Yeah.
There were times at the end of a workout
to where I'd be like,
I don't care if it's not,
I want to do fucking something else.
I wanted to some weights.
It was also was a.
It was a thing where I was in this weird
high state,
this weird post long workout,
and I just wanted to keep it going.
I just wanted to keep like flowing and
relaxing.
While it was like lifting weights and
doing kettlebell swings and shit.
I just wanted to do something else.
I wanted to do chin ups I want to do
something was just moving my body almost
as if I was a cooling it down.
After all that,
all that exercise,
it was bananas,
man.
After it was over,
I was like,
what the fuck happened?
What did we do?
It was like we got,
we got possessed by a wizard spell and
all of a sudden,
where were we?
We we hit zero point one percent of all
the people using this fucking thing.
I went down to that fucking gym and I
was like,
Hey,
I want to sign up for whatever it but
are things like I'm
just to start working out right now.
So logged me in.
Harvey knew too,
work it out.
I got it.
Is that for middle aged comedians?
Zero.
Zero point one percent.
I'm obese according to all the zero
point one percent plus metrics without
his nuts that we worked that hard.
So hard.
I can't believe it,
man.
All the time running in the hills.
Say that you were gonna double meat.
That's all I needed.
A fucking idiot.
This is a day of death
want.
Don't you want to tug on the Tiger's
tail?
Do you want to tug on the dog?
We're going to go down the dark road per
crash.
So there was a thing.
There was a thing.
When Tami goes back,
you got to play the Nikki glaser clip.
It's just,
it's,
Oh,
I'm guarantee you.
It's all my instagram.
I.
It helped me to have you around.
Yeah.
When Tom got 602,
so me and Bert,
when he got sick it was like,
okay,
cool.
He's done.
We both separated ourselves from buy
about 700 and then we're like,
hey,
we talked to were like,
uh,
looks like Tom's out pretty much were
like looking at the toms out.
It was like,
yeah,
that's cool.
So we're not coming last because it was
a big fear and then you say,
yeah,
I'm still gonna try to beat you though.
I'm like,
yeah,
I mean good luck,
but you're not going to fucking do it.
And it was just like,
oh,
okay,
we're still going to go on.
It's still going to be one with a
fucking challenge to you.
I can't,
I can't.
I have to pay more compliments than
anything in this because already should
fear really that you really changed my
perspective of working out like of going
the way I go.
If I get into spin class and the guard
sat on the saddle and you're paddling,
I go,
it will be still out right now.
Like that's the way your brain works.
It's different,
man.
I used to race with yoga too.
They're like,
you guys do all the poses.
I'm gonna fucking fat legs to get my
fucking feet around each other.
It's a way a person's brain works.
Can't do that shit.
Yeah.
I tell you the reason why I thought you
were dead last for sure.
Did you really think you were cheap?
Let's pay people workouts.
For me,
I knew two things were going on.
One Tom had been exercising on a regular
basis and even though he might have
carried a little bit of body fat,
he's actually a fit strong guy with a
strong mind.
I also knew that Ra wept being one time
that motherfucker.
I was on top of him.
I was a brown belt.
He's a white belt.
Once in awhile.
My motherfucking back.
I was like,
oh,
I thought it was oprah.
She was mad at you guys where you're
like,
we're going to vegas first cost center
thing.
I was like,
I was almost going to be like,
just to ruin it for you.
I'm like,
okay,
cool.
I'll write a check.
Tell me to write the check right now.
I'm assuming you're a fucking stupid
thing.
Listen already tried to kill me with his
bare hands.
Who's trying to kill me?
It was trying choked my neck.
Can I just say I know Ari now that we've
done this and to reward ourselves?
Yeah.
I say,
why
don't we do something that would be fun.
I love this idea already and I know what
it is.
Surfing until someone dies.
No,
I mean,
as we're going to vegas,
I had a boxing fight.
Would be fun watching any of you die.
Surfing would be the most fun.
Decrease.
The level of happiness I have with my
life.
Any sort of metrics show was Bert dying
are you can't.
You can't deny that you are very proud
of yourself for your,
your performance this month because in
my opinion,
and this is I'm being 100 percent
objective,
your,
your performance was the most impressive
exercise or not exercise.
I've been exercising my whole life when
I saw you just all of a sudden.
Thank you.
I appreciate that.
Nine point.
One day.
Yeah.
I did a bunch,
6:30
or something and I was like,
what the fuck?
When he caught right up and I was like,
oh fuck.
I was ready to coast already.
Given up,
I saw a marathon one time where a guy
went the wrong way.
He was in the elite,
are neck and neck with the guy went the
wrong way.
Everyone had a sec.
No,
no,
you're going the wrong way.
This is the last like 300 meters.
And then he was like,
oh fuck,
maybe a mile,
you know?
And he had to come all the way back and
they try to catch up,
but that wasted space that late and he
started sprinting and he spits it right
back to that other guy who was already
in first place because he fucking dug
down deep.
Yeah,
I didn't want to die.
I was dreading to coast.
And when you started winning I was like,
oh no,
I'm done.
And then I was like,
yeah,
I could do this.
Wow.
I'm pretty high too.
Yeah.
Can I just say though,
instead of a boxing match,
which I find boring,
I'll be honest with you guys.
Where do you like,
I get it white.
I understand where you come from.
Okay.
What do you like to swing?
Yes.
Kickboxer.
Let's go see kickboxing.
Is that what you wanted to say?
Yes.
That's what you were leaning towards.
Kick plus kickboxing.
Muay Thai.
We go to Chiang Mai,
Thailand,
Thailand?
Yes,
and we go see some kickboxing.
We can have cigars.
We can be an anonymity.
Oh,
we can just be regular people,
right?
Go to go to a couple of kickboxing
fights,
walk around in sandals for a few days
and band.
No time on Monday.
Went back on where.
What if I were a man?
I want to wear the uggs,
Bro.
I liked this.
Some Thai food.
We stay out of Bangkok.
How long we stay in one of the fucking
works are tying back in four or five.
I'm saying leave on a Monday.
We're back on a Friday.
You can go to your next.
You don't have to take off a Gig if you
don't want to go see some fights.
Have cigars,
some change,
some Chang Beer.
Watch some fights.
I really do like get drunk walking
around this,
so wait the.
But no.
I mean like have a good time after surf
week.
No,
this is way before
rich kids planning for summer.
It's going to be a fucking surf.
Surf.
Travel.
What does that do you think you'll be
good at it?
Surprising.
You really don't know.
I've ever done it.
So when I first started doing yoga,
I was amazed at how Shitty I was at it.
I was surprised it was it.
I didn't think it would be good at it.
And that was worse than surfing.
No.
Yoga.
Oh yeah.
Clip for with a Nike.
What does it say?
Our.
You're shifty.
I'll tell you something.
We haven't totally determined what the
loser has to do or he wants us to like
drink each other's piss
to drink your piss.
You might not lose right now.
Tom Seger is in the bottom at the
bottom.
Tom Is gonna try.
I think he.
I mean your obviously set to witness
thing,
but I think Tom's going to sneak up.
He's playing it down.
You looked at his wrist yesterday.
You Go,
what's that?
Thousand something.
Oh,
that's nothing.
Just the calories.
You burned the day.
A thousand.
Tom's Tom Sneaky.
A lot of people feel like that.
I really think he's gonna do something
on the.
He's going to be the one to to beat.
You got to realize though,
Bert ran a marathon.
He did run a marathon.
This is a.
This is fun.
I have to say.
Any one of you could pull ahead,
but you're the.
I mean,
can we talk about what you did
yesterday?
Yeah.
I worked out for three hours and 20
minutes.
I'm trying to.
Yeah,
I'm trying to break burt's will.
That's what I'm really trying to do.
Talks on this Mickey Mantle Gene.
Shit,
mother fucker.
I'm crazy.
I don't understand.
I will work out twice a day like that.
I will.
I will try to give you a fucking heart
attack.
Well too.
He's going to know how long he's going
to keep birds.
Very competitive.
Up to a point like the.
With the weight loss challenge.
Tom Stayed steady and Tom one in the end
in one big bird tried.
He tried to sprint towards the end,
but it was too little too late and Tom
was talking shit the entire time.
Like,
I know what you're gonna do.
You're gonna fuck off until the very
end.
Then you can try to catch up,
but it's going to be too late and he was
right.
Yep.
Bert,
I don't know if birds will can be
broken.
Has it been broken before?
Well,
it's not as well.
It's the discipline aspect.
When you're dealing with an entire
month,
you have 31 days of having to get after
it.
So how often do you get after it
normally?
See,
that's the thing.
The difference between me and Bert is I
work out almost every day already,
so for me it's just like those days off
don't exist anymore,
so what I've decided to do on my days
off,
it's just do shit that I wouldn't
normally do,
so I'll do the elliptical machine for
two hours or I'll do something else.
I'll do something else,
but the whole time I'm thinking I'm
going to break Bert.
I'm to break.
Think about when you're really trying to
get past that point where you're you
kickboxing or even on an elliptical.
Sometimes you got to get angry and you
think of bird.
Right now you're thinking about taking a
braking breaking as well.
I don't know if you guys are all in
different ways and this is so
interesting to watch because you're
right,
you already work out a lot,
you're extremely healthy guy,
but you're now going to take it your ex.
I can see the excitement on all of you
to take this to just an excruciating
level and because it,
it gets obsessive and it gets fun like
you can work,
but that's the thing I'm excited to talk
to you at the beginning of this when
you're still pumped up about it and it's
like you get a high from working out for
three and a half hours a day,
17 days from now.
I'm going to be a beaten man.
Yeah,
you are,
and you're going to get a surge at the
end when it gets close again,
but 17 days.
You're right.
That's not going to be a fun day for
you.
Well,
I don't know.
Who knows?
Did you ever see.
There's a really interesting problem.
Yeah,
it's weird.
How do you feel?
How do you feel this hilarious,
man.
I'm her physically.
Would you feel.
Do you feel like you broke me?
No.
Break,
did you feel your best?
You did your best when you talked to a
lot of crazy shit.
Shit.
Bird?
No,
no,
no.
It's good for everybody.
Dog Shit and those guys are doing.
I Talk Shit.
Listen,
I don't feel bad that you talk shit.
I'm happy to talk shit.
It was fun.
It's scary.
You should talk to your side.
Didn't,
but I didn't think that it would go
where it went in terms of like my how
much time everyday I was working out.
I never thought it would really get to
that.
It was,
it was crazy.
I thought in the beginning we would all
just have some fun workout an hour a day
and see whose number was higher.
Yeah.
It would be like real clothes.
No,
no,
no.
I wanted it to everybody.
I figured Tommy that we talked about it
with everybody.
The last week's gonna Sprint.
Yeah,
right.
of course.
I thought that was definitely going to
happen.
Then he made that video and I was like,
which video?
Which video?
I don't know.
When you said you a double major.
I was like,
I'm going to take those.
My dog.
No,
it was another one before that here,
and he was like,
Woo.
I gotta come in last.
I was like,
oh wait,
hold on,
hold on.
You know,
you know for a fact that I made those
videos I love.
Right.
I understand,
but I didn't listen.
I believe that right now,
but it doesn't help me to believe that
back then you don't understand.
You've got to say something like that.
Even if you don't mean it.
You said it and I don't have to get mad
at you,
but I have to at least acknowledged
there's a transference of energy right
now.
I don't want to call it anger and says,
we want to make sure that you don't ever
fucking win this thing.
There's no way we're going to go down
the dark road,
dark.
This is the difference.
Let's not forget about that.
This is the difference between high
performers.
Wait,
hold on.
Do you all.
Did you all recognize this?
Because I picked up on it pretty
quickly.
Mickey Mantle Gene.
I knew we were done pretty quickly.
You knew what I knew
done pretty quickly.
We were done.
I knew that when he was saying,
even though I understood 100 percent
understood,
he was his joke that he's like,
whatever Joseph does,
I'm going to double up.
You probably knew that he would
interpret that in a competitive way.
You should do your regular workout and
see if he still paid us.
I'm like,
yeah,
yeah.
Hold on.
Not Negative,
but not negative.
Not not like what you don't like me.
I.
If you really say I'm going to double
everything Joe Does,
Mike
Joe's not going to let that.
I realized is that I get to take a knee.
I don't have to interpret it,
and you gave him the.
When you gave me a thought in my head
that you're going to try to do that.
His daughter,
his daughter is not calling the cable
Guy Daddy because he's been gone so long
working out.
She has no memory of him because you had
to say,
I'm going to double.
You don't need to know if you're being
honest.
For me to know,
I pushed that aside.
I need to know that you think that
you're going to do that.
You think really you,
even though you really know that he
doesn't think he can do that 100
percent,
but fuck him,
it can allow.
You can't allow that.
I'm going to put some blinders on.
Doesn't matter to take a chance and
where they're going to.
We're going to go through the darkness.
Can I just say this,
that we all use burt as a motivation to
beat,
but let's not get lost in this.
You got to understand,
I got real,
real serious anxiety when you got sick
and know when I realized I could move
tuber when I realized I could recover.
That was like if I got worse,
I'd be like,
I'm super sick.
I wouldn't.
But when I realized I was getting better
and I thought I might lose.
Yeah,
I got real anxiety about it.
Yeah.
I got super nervous.
Yeah,
but you were the same as me.
Just don't call him Bert.
Bert.
Well,
that'd be nice.
Last terrible.
What kills me is that what you eat,
you,
you put a video out was what it was.
What was it or was it a twitter post?
Early?
It was like,
where do I put the built?
Yeah,
of course.
I want to just be very,
very clear,
very clear.
I did not enter into this contest to
lose.
I didn't think I was coming in.
They fuck up.
What was that?
Now before,
I don't know.
And we also have a fitness aspect.
That's right.
I'm challenging those gentlemen in
fitness and I'm going to beat them at
their own game.
And you're a good host.
We're getting a brand new porsche.
What do we got here?
We've got a 1992.
Which one are you?
The guy that doesn't have any clothes on
flops and shit.
I'll take it over.
Everybody.
Permission to.
How much was it hit me up and was like,
congrats.
That's a dope car for 24.
20.
Yeah.
He talked a lot.
I did talk shit though,
Bro.
Hey,
hold on,
hold on for real talk.
He talks too much shipper.
No,
I won't stop and never ever,
ever much one guy and one guy.
I don't want you to.
I want you to be.
So yeah,
it was fun.
It was fun.
Let me tell you something I'm missing
though,
is that all of us went to try to make
sure you don't beat them,
but you lost.
Yeah.
But I lost on purpose.
What's that going to Joey see you at the
store that one day.
Did you hear about this?
What happened?
Joey was here on the podcast.
He called me.
Yeah.
Was that you know,
no dog.
No.
He called me and said I did a video on
instagram stories.
I got recognized.
I didn't know person there were like
Bert and tried to tell me story.
Joe Is taught and then said that he
caught me drinking in a parking lot.
But if you saw the stories,
you'd know.
I wasn't drunk.
I was stone sober.
But yeah,
he called me and told me.
He's like,
I see you're tricking dog.
What I love about Joey Diaz,
he called and apologized because I guess
I didn't notice it,
but it got some big online,
something on my podcast,
but it was clearly.
Jochen knows.
He's like,
I don't know about Bert Kreischer
because I saw him walking in the street.
I waved at him.
He didn't wave back.
All I heard.
I heard that 80 percent tongue in cheek
joke called Joey.
Now trust me on my children.
I would never lie to you about any one
thing.
I did listen the last day when I hit you
up and I was like,
I'm out.
I swear on my children,
dude friends.
No one thinks you lied and here's the
blame me what you believe in.
What?
I believed him and there was still a
part of my brain that was like,
make sure just.
Yeah,
I would never do that.
I probably tell you it was back then.
It was a separate thought though.
It wasn't that I didn't think you were
lying,
but I still was like,
my brain would not allow me to just.
I know you didn't want her motel mode
and you get an extra workout.
I watched,
I saw and I went,
I can't believe he didn't believe I
believed you.
I believed you.
I was just like,
you can't be so stupid to believe in
fully.
It kind of,
yeah.
I was like,
what if,
what if it wasn't that he was lying?
He sat now he sounded so sincere.
Ecological Games.
Those games.
Yeah.
I like what Joe was like,
wait,
are you just saving up your points and
not registering into the system so that
you can like sand bags?
Yes.
You fucking idiot.
What'd you think I was doing?
Of course I didn't know.
I didn't know what to think when I spoke
to you.
I still believe Georgia
called that morning.
There's two.
I would never know it.
I will never make an excuse.
Georgia called that morning and I just
kind of spin class and I was going for a
12 mile run in my head.
I was like,
I'm set.
I'm putting clothes on.
And Georgia texted and said,
uh,
daddy daughter luncheon at Lou or
wherever she goes to school.
She was telling a kid dollar lunch in it
like 11 and you need to be there at nine
to help set up.
And I was like,
fuck.
And in my head I just,
all I did was wantonly wanted res life,
right?
He didn't have any responsibilities and
I just was like,
I was like,
I texted him,
everyone that at that moment I was like,
I'm out.
I'm.
I got softball practice and a luncheon
and I,
dude,
in that middle of that luncheon,
I was like,
I could go for a run right now.
Like in my head that this whole thing
was psychotic.
Made me psychotic.
Honestly,
I got to the point where I thought about
your lives.
I was like,
wait a minute.
I do have more fun at night usually,
but like daytime I have no
responsibility and this is a lot of
effort for me to get to this place and
do this time.
Yeah.
I don't know what you guys go through in
order to feel like this.
Take time away to do your life is very
different.
We kids are at school because your
school.
Okay,
that makes sense.
So you have this open amount of time
from 7:00
AM to 4:00
PM or whatever it is.
After that,
if it's an unusual guest and I just
scheduled everything in there,
that's a lot of time,
man.
I have that time to this thing has been
7:00
AM.
11 words,
man.
That's.
You have a gym in your compound like you
can do it.
I was jealous,
like Jordan's Jim in his porsche,
little treadmill and I can get here and
get an hour in before podcasts.
Now you did it right man,
but I never thought of it that I can
build this thing so I could win.
How fucking.
Let's be honest here.
Just to entertain this thought for a
second.
How much of a piece of shit?
What'd you feel like
it right now in the second telling you,
how upset would you say
worried about Ari?
I was worried.
I was worried about.
Yeah,
because even like the 30th
in the 30th when I know that the very
last day when he had a picture said,
do you believe in miracles like this
motherfucker's store and point?
Yeah.
The
way you believe America is just the last
three point where you say about this,
right?
A little bit.
Well,
I would laugh.
You would have to be humble because
here's the deal.
At the end of the beat,
me,
I almost killed myself,
so if you beat me,
what did you go through?
All of us.
Your.
What was your,
what was your final scores for 11,000,
11,000
something.
It's they're crazy too.
They let us know that you finished
324th,
I think 324th in the country in the
world and the world of registered users.
Three hundred and 23 other people
crushed him or,
or just be.
I mean,
you know,
there's one that definitely fucking
muscle somebody.
How do you know?
Like $19,000?
They wouldn't tell me,
but they would tell a lot the
milestones.
Guys said that a lot of these people or
fitness instructors that are doing five,
six,
even seven classes a day,
people out there that are in the shape.
That's amazing.
That is amazing.
Imagine teaching six spin classes a
fucking.
They don't do that.
Don't do that though.
Not even the regular person does that,
but could they do it?
It could decided to go from gym to gym.
Maybe they'd have to.
I don't know if they would stop them.
Who would say,
is there a like a,
you know,
at least to have that thing with
Oxycontin's in Florida where you can get
a subscription or a prescription for one
guy,
they go down and another guy.
Then they developed database.
They have a database on that.
On spec life is spending too much.
Yeah.
These people are spinning their ass off.
Were the chest strap and teach 100
fucking spin classes a day.
Should we do one more cocktail?
Are we going to eat or drink after this?
I'm fucking bombed.
I liked it with a six slash 20.
We're good.
We're fine.
We're good to go to dinner.
Food plans and a son.
Um,
wait.
Let's just all acknowledge I cannot
drink for a month,
right?
What do you mean?
When we started this whole thing,
everyone thought I couldn't do it
because I've been thinking.
What do you think will happen to you on
your tour next year?
Do you think you'll go?
Well,
I'm saying as far as your late night
stuff,
I don't know.
Yeah,
if you have a button for me,
so maybe you will not drink that much.
Drinking changed,
a lot of it's been three days or
whatever,
but like just in the things that would
trigger me of like I'm in an airport,
I have a cocktail.
Yeah,
I can totally fly sober.
Um,
I don't know man.
I really don't know.
You know me,
I'll be really honest.
Listen,
you clearly can take a month off that
can do it.
And you know,
one of the things that I,
I've been really wrestling with a lot
lately.
I had this Guy Tyson fury.
Do you know who he is?
He used to be the heavyweight boxing
champion of the world and fly to fight
the bronze
bomber,
right?
Yes.
It's about to fight.
Deontay wilder and I had him on the
podcast.
He was talking about depression and all
the shit that he went through and one
things that he said is that what pulled
him out of it was deontay wilder said
that he was finished and he decided he
was going to figure out a way to get
back.
So he decided to just get his fucking
shit together and start competition.
Competition won the world heavyweight
title beat Vladimir Klitschko.
And then went into a depression.
It's like,
what now?
Just didn't know what the fuck to do.
I just felt weird.
This guy called them out years and years
later,
drank in carrying on Kenton fucking
crazy.
And then this guy says he can never come
back.
It was like,
Oh really?
And then all of a sudden he decided to
come back,
approved this coverall and now he's off
medication wasn't even on any
medication.
They were trying to give them some shit
and fuck right is enticing.
Six,
six,
nine,
six.
Gigantic guy.
But he said he's going to do it with
goal setting.
He's an he hadn't,
he seemed happy and friendly and he lost
like a shit ton of weight.
I lost like a hundred.
What's the like 150 pounds or something?
Wasn't it something crazy,
Jamie?
Do you remember?
Spuds a big motivator.
It's a little bit of that,
but it's also goal setting.
Setting.
Yeah.
So the thing that he said that made me
think about this month,
this month,
it was weird.
When it was over,
I was like,
what the fuck happened?
He was trying to tell you,
man,
that day that I ran the 12 miles,
kind of 91 point 631 points and yet,
yeah,
forget what you got that it was like,
I really was like a backbreaker it was
it back there.
I was like,
I might be done.
That was a Sunday.
I got back in town.
Site was about you got to get even with
me,
but I was like,
I might be done versus what he looks
like now and then 135 pounds.
He was a great interview man.
When he talks,
he's a great guy.
I'm always saying just that I fucking,
I,
I thought I.
The whole time
time I would see.
I would look down,
see how far I ran and it'd be like 400
points.
It's not enough points.
Just keep running man.
Just keep running,
keep running.
Yeah.
Yes.
It's spite,
spite.
It was the fear of loss.
I wish everyone had poked at Joe a tad
bit because to feel,
to feel wrong.
Play No.
Why not?
Why?
Because we had a chance to beat him if
he just did like.
No,
no,
no.
Let him add.
Why do you play a game with Joe and feel
as the game is to win?
You don't always,
dude,
I looked at,
is it a win win situation?
Right?
He's too smart.
Every word that comes out of his mouth,
I have to analyze.
There's not a part of you that wants to
just like,
it's too slippery.
Starts talking to me.
Hey.
She just tried to like lift weights and
see what your score is.
Exactly.
The
score in his head.
It's like,
Oh really?
Oh No,
you want to win?
Try real hard.
Didn't I decided I was going to take you
on some thousand point desks were empty
here,
Bro.
Wait,
are we done with punch?
I know.
Try this.
Blanton's wouldn't we?
As everyone is fucked up as I'm pretty
fucked up.
Yeah,
we're pretty.
We're going to eat right?
Right.
Do you know who was who asked?
Bird bird.
Bird.
Yes.
I did.
Also,
by the way,
for this podcast this year,
Tom pointed out how to push those
$10,000,
so it was kids.
Let's set it up correctly.
What happened?
Please?
Let's have it.
What happened was this I,
you and I were joking about a marathon
and whatever.
Yes.
And then I booked.
You mentioned nothing of this ever
again.
A joking.
Yes.
Okay.
Then I booked a movie in Australia
again.
I went to,
I went to Atlanta to shoot the movie.
He doesn't care about them,
care about them.
First class tickets.
I was like,
I'm not interested twice in a row.
I love Australia.
I've been fucking kill yourself.
I don't know.
I,
I can't.
I went,
I went to shoot the movie while I'm in
Atlanta shooting this movie.
This fucking guy's like,
I'm at the starting line.
Whereas Tom,
he knows where I'm fucking.
He's like,
you're in Atlanta.
You're in Atlanta.
Changed the rules.
He's at Tom Hayes.
Oh,
he's tweeting a no show.
He's supposed to be here.
Did know the night before I posted a
video and say,
hey guys,
I'm sorry.
Tommy is not going to.
Government tend to do youth through me.
That's fake news.
So here's the,
here's what happened.
Yeah.
I call burden like I'm getting a fucking
lot of messages and it's all people that
are like,
you're quitting.
You're welding on this bed.
You mother fucker starts to become the
most yet.
He goes.
He goes,
yeah,
yeah.
I'm just around.
He goes,
hey,
to make it up to you,
if I finished this thing,
I'll donate $10,000.
I've never said that my entire life.
Joe.
He never,
um,
never said this in my entire life where
you heard him say that though.
When he goes,
he goes and he goes and he cited his
father.
He goes,
if I don't beat father time,
I'll donate 20,000.
By the way,
my father just ran the marine corps
marathon.
He did last Sunday.
I went 81 years old.
Eighty one.
Mr.
Fear.
Yes.
Great.
Yes sir.
I never said that.
Okay.
So he said that he bailed on those kids.
Kids finished the marathon.
You have to celebrate.
You took it upon yourself to get the
money pledged that,
that bird pledge to those sick kids.
You started fat Bert when six children
died and you were able to $11,270
for children's Hospital of Los Angeles,
La Children's hospital,
Los Angeles.
Uh,
the gofundme [inaudible] dot com slash
evil burt was very successful.
And during this month we filled it out
and I was able to,
because you call it to my attention,
Thomas,
because you called it an injustice to my
attention.
A lot of the kids died waiting for
those,
for births.
They actually,
at the,
uh,
cemetery there,
they have a Bert kids plus kids that
died under the time.
Wow.
It's amazing the money for these kids
know that this is real or it's.
My mom said,
my mom asked me about it.
I was like,
yeah.
And she goes,
can you tell Bert that he sucks?
My Orthodox Jewish moms say that
forensic,
he sucks.
I was like,
mom,
no.
It's not like where you think goes.
Hey,
tell him I think he's put a hole in the
sheet.
How many times did your pops done this
thing he's done?
He said he thinks without really
thinking hard.
10 marathons.
Three seven Marine Corps.
Oh Wow.
Good for her.
Last one was the 81.
First one was like $60 to run it with
him.
No,
but he worked.
By the way,
when,
when you mentioned that I was looking
at.
I was looking at the numbers,
I was like,
oh,
these are about to jump on.
He just ran a marathon with his dad.
That's what I thought I really did.
I was like,
he just did and I was looking at that
screen like this is about to jump to
like,
like 19,000.
I thought it was going to be and my dad
teamed up for the free,
like miles said about his dad and I was
like,
your dad did it.
Did you do it?
I,
and I.
It took me an hour to believe that you
didn't do it at any point.
Wonder whether or not your body was
gonna.
Hold up,
hold up.
I could do like 30 minutes.
And I was like,
I got to slow down.
I can't.
I never felt as weak as the last day at
night I spoke,
I actually had spoken to you.
I've spoken to you and the last person I
spoke to was Ari and he,
if you're going to do it,
will you just sync up so I'll know where
you're at.
And I was like,
yeah,
and then I go,
I'm not doing 700 right now.
That's how much I space.
Mine flew.
By the way,
I didn't tell you.
I traveled in the last day of the east
coast so I lost all but still when I got
there I was so exhausted that I was
like,
at first I was like,
I'll do 500 points right now.
You asked me to like,
do you think you're working on like if I
have from my point of view,
no.
But from your point of view,
yeah.
You should separate yourself a little
more from burt and.
Exactly.
And then when I got to like 2:50,
I actually,
I go,
could I go longer?
Yes.
Could I get to Ari?
There's,
I'll go.
I just feel like I'm going to die right
now.
You know,
I feel I feel almost sick,
so I was like,
if I am I going to do another few hours
until the cutoff.
I was like,
there's no way I wasn't there a part of
it in,
in that.
I'll say this.
I said,
when you woke up in the morning you were
like,
this is unquestionable.
I can do this.
We're gonna be October 20,
30 day.
Every day we did this.
There was a party that was like,
I can work out one more time.
I can work out.
You know.
I did think I was.
I really did.
Honestly think I was out when I texted
you.
He got sick and I was like,
I'm out.
Just no way.
I when I did 43 points,
so happy that made me so made me.
You have no idea.
I can tell you last year that me and
Bert,
me and Tom,
excuse me,
like day one,
I'm sober October.
It was mostly about the sobriety and
less about the yoga.
Tom and I were texting like,
should we just drank the entire time and
not tell them?
And we're both like,
yeah,
I don't think we either,
one of us totally trust each other,
not the route and the other,
but it would have been like,
let's just drink the whole time and then
be like,
yeah,
we never even started that.
It would be funny,
dude.
I was terrified.
There will be one prank coming my way.
You know,
when we're in the parking lot after yoga
class,
you were like,
let's get blood tests for your day.
Yeah,
yeah.
Hey,
you freaked out.
I was like,
what was the story about?
Trust us.
Somebody said,
wait,
did you have to get rid of Zz?
Wanted to do a.
I got a Lamborghini Lamborghini.
I don't even know if we said this last
year,
but I since I told him,
because I ran into him the night before.
The next day when we're going to the
15th last,
my phone reason is Joe.
And he goes,
are you in a white Lamborghini?
And I go,
yeah.
And he goes,
yeah,
you're right in front of me.
And he goes,
since you told me you got a Lamborghini,
I assumed that this fucking ridiculously
was yours.
So then I pulled in and we look for a
place to park and I was like,
he's like,
nobody's gonna fuck with this thing man.
But the whole,
it was so great.
The best part of this whole thing was
like a day after I had told Bert that it
was a joke.
He called me.
He goes,
I did look at motorcycles,
motorcycles,
because I thought you got to treat.
I got a Lamborghini.
I'm still like that too.
I want to drink tonight.
I want to treat that drink.
I want a treat.
I want to treat you ranked in a
Lamborghini.
Just a fuck would burn.
Oh my God.
It was great.
And I was like,
yeah,
I don't know if you know who the fuck
you fuck it up because you go look at
the registration.
You said that.
And I go look at it.
I told you that.
Fucking look at it,
look at it.
Oh,
look at.
Oh God.
Because that gross body I had that was
so far better than our other bureaus,
so much better do you think he inserted.
But my girlfriend was like,
my body was like,
oh wait,
what?
Let's put it.
How long did it take?
You can serve in a month standing on a
board.
How much time?
Wow.
That's a great question.
For 31 days to catch waves is their feet
get tired.
Here's the thing.
We always know that we ended up doing
the running order.
There's no punished.
I'm not trying to fucking run up on you,
but there is no punishment this year.
Right?
For coming in last year.
So next year.
Same thing.
Should be.
Wait.
No,
no,
no.
I don't want you all wanted to win this.
It gives us a pretty solid.
I'm just saying this,
I'm saying this,
we should do something to celebrate and
I'm just saying forget about winning and
losing for someone who came in.
Second number one in a non astrix I
would say
I do.
I have a full
Jose Conseco wikipedia.
I would say that my boat shoot carries
some extra weight and I'm saying to go
to Chiang Mai,
Thailand,
you really want to watch some fucking
kickboxing.
I think it would be from America,
absolutely.
But I think we can do to have the where
you would all enjoy your type of thing.
Also,
we don't stay at a hostel in a hotel.
Sure.
And just do that.
Smoke some cigars.
Get drunk on beer.
I think my vote is as number two.
Should hangs a lot with me.
Please take some time and think about
it.
But I like to travel agent orange.
Fear.
I do.
I do something like that.
I would have no problem with that.
So does this year's lost count?
Oh everyone something.
Oh No,
no,
no.
Do you think you get drank?
Drank.
Piss.
I gotTa pee real bad.
Mean Do pee right here for you.
He,
he'll drink it.
Burt drank at full Kombucha of pis.
But wait,
wait,
Joel,
would you really piss in it?
No I'm not.
I'm not drinking
piss guys.
I say,
you know,
drinking piss with.
Listen,
I need a car.
I need to give a treat to the team.
Lost.
I lost me.
And then I don't know what that tree
will be,
but it should be a treat.
You don't have to do shit.
But Hey,
for the hotel check in Chiang Mai,
it will cost you $700 for four days.
For each one of us have a room or in a
giant,
whatever we decide to do,
I'm going to get.
I'm going to definitely be a part of
that tree.
Do for land traveling,
trip first class tickets,
and 10 for fans that listen by those
dogs.
I'll tell you this right now,
if we do a,
we do Madison Square Garden for the
private jet to take us all to fucking
New York.
This private jet aesthetic is troubling.
You guys are saying you're such trash,
a fucking horrible,
wasteful thing to get to it.
Let's do it.
What?
What book?
Madison Square Garden.
I'll pay for the train your dragon son.
I'll take.
I'll pay for the private jet together so
I'll miss you guys.
Just the three of us.
How surprising was this month?
Hardcore.
For me it was very,
very surprising.
I keep surprising to you though,
where it went.
It went so competitive.
Nobody ever separated themselves,
fully accept you,
but even if you.
It was still like I could maybe catch
him if he stopped,
like when you went on a hunting trip
when you said I'm not going to be
working on for the next five days.
We were all like,
oh,
we got a chance to catch Rogan and pass
him and then when you worked on the
trip,
but like,
oh,
that's where we're fucked.
But like it was surprising that we kept
fighting the whole way.
It was,
it was unrelenting.
It wasn't anything I could relax.
No,
that was one time that I went to Vegas
for the UFC.
I took three days off and I came back
and I was in last place.
I was like,
whoa.
And then Bert,
you helped me there too because he
tweeted that he tweeted that I was in
last place and you even posted the
numbers on instagram and I was like,
oh,
okay.
So that really motivated you.
One hundred percent stupid.
Here's why.
A silly boy motivated by everything.
That can be a motivator.
I don't let something not motivate me.
Why would I do that?
So to not know who you are.
I'm like,
Oh,
oh,
what am I,
I never,
I never hear what you say and say,
well,
birds,
a great guy and you know,
I know.
He was just joking around and doing this
for publicity.
I'm like,
I can do that later.
That doesn't help me right now.
Right now it helps me have you tell me
that you're going to beat me.
And I'm like,
Oh yeah,
that's true.
Okay,
here we go.
I did a cruise at the beginning of this
month with Bobby Kelly and I thought,
I told him about the whole thing started
and I'm looking at everyone's numbers
for the first time and I said,
yeah,
Rogan's in it.
I'm taunting him.
And Bobby goes,
why would you ever do that?
I always show man.
And he goes,
no,
I don't think you know Joe.
I go,
no,
I definitely know Joe.
He goes,
never taught him.
And then halfway through the cruise I
was like,
I think I fucked up man.
He told you.
He told you stupid dude was a good month
though.
It was like,
would it not be like I got it.
I went in like 10 years cooler if I had
just been like super country and
respectful.
If one of us could have no,
I do not like the fucking game play.
I liked this bullshit of like talk shit,
man.
Be As loud as you can be to support my
fucking Chiang Mai idea.
Came in dead last supportive.
I'm in.
I'm in trying to go to a show.
You like those kickboxing fights.
Loved them.
I love.
Listen.
I even did some commentary for
kickboxing in California really?
For Moy.
Tai.
Yeah.
Way back before UFC.
Before I ever did UFC commentary.
I did come from in the moment bikes
because I can take her to some cool
places was do it.
You're the only wild card.
You don't seem like you would go to a
place.
I would go really for a short term trip.
Yeah.
Orchard April?
Yeah,
Monday through Friday.
On first.
How long you guys think you could serve
for a whole month?
This is for our competition next year.
How might someone get Kelly slater on
the phone and let's find out how long is
it?
Sounds respectful,
so I don't wanna throw out big numbers
right now,
but I'm thinking four days.
Sebastian,
what's up bro?
For days,
I don't think it's possible.
Stay in one of those things for too
long.
Are you interested?
Even surfing.
Never been scared of sharks.
That's why we go to Joe.
Joe,
Joe hates all monster.
We can.
We can all go and surf together like we
did with the hot yoga,
but we're all trying to catch better
waves.
Monsters are real.
We would have to enlist and Kelly slater
surf camp for whatever.
No Bro,
Bro.
We got this.
We got this guys.
Or I can spend five days on a search for
750.
To be honest.
I liked putting it aside every October.
This is my challenge to you.
What's your challenge?
That scared off social media for stupid,
stupid.
We all just agreed with some of us got
to sell tickets for a body shots world
tour.
No,
no.
I already know what you can do.
You could agree to.
They stay off social media and if you
have anything that you have to post
about something,
you send it to some sort of a manager,
they put it up for you.
You can do that thing.
Yeah.
You sent it to people to send him an
email and say,
hey,
send this tomorrow or send this to you
soon as you can.
If it's after 10:00
PM,
Cet,
wait til it's a good move and you don't
check it.
They only move.
It's not the only move,
but it's a good move.
I think it's not just a good move for
us.
It's a good move for everybody,
like you shouldn't believe off the
amount.
Limit the amount of variables you have
to process because if you don't,
you will process them correctly,
so you'll be dealing with a bunch of
information that someone would get.
Some of it you'll get right and some of
the it'll get wrong,
but you never know what the real
balances because too much of it is
coming at you all the time,
all the time.
Can't stop and think for a second which
you love it,
which I don't mind it.
This is your wheel house.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Dude,
let me tell you something.
The same thing can be argued about
podcasting.
People go,
hey,
we're talking too much.
We shouldn't be talking this much,
but it's something that our fans dig and
I dig.
Look,
dude,
this doesn't affect.
That doesn't affect your own psyche.
It does.
It gets you start getting angry.
Don't look at.
Don't read comments.
Don't look at likes.
Don't look at it.
I argued I would too many people dig it
too.
Not to walk away from it in my opinion,
and I know I dig it.
No need to walk away.
I think already saying more like breaks.
Take a break.
If you guys could totally deal with a
month off of all that Shit,
you more than anybody and then you and
then you have just like not being on
that.
Not letting it affect your opinion.
Just walk outside and view the world for
what it is for a month.
It wouldn't kill you.
No,
I agree.
But you could get your business shit
part done just by email or post this for
me and then never looking at it.
I don't know.
I'd argue against it.
You could do that.
I know.
I definitely could not and I don't want
to like it's different.
I.
Dude,
I dig.
I dig listening to you talk to Kelly
slater.
I thought that was.
Gives me joy.
You can have a podcast.
No,
no,
no.
You're talking about getting rid of your
fucking phone.
That's all of it.
How would I know Joe had Kelly slater on
social media?
Yeah,
but I would say probably the best way.
A great flip phone for a month.
Yeah.
If you can get off all social media from
moms that would help you a lot.
I.
There was never a moment where I thought
that you guys are cheating.
Like you really didn't stop that
classes.
Oh right.
No,
no,
no.
I never know.
Or even this month I was like,
you know,
the worst case scenario would be
somebody to be holding back where they
weren't releasing information,
the system.
But I had already prepared for that.
You got so far ahead.
I wanted to save up for like seven days.
I couldn't trust that my zone thing.
It said 13 hours,
13 hours.
It lost a good 40 minutes.
One time.
I think you're looking at social media
in a bad way.
It overall it shifts your to the
negative.
What you need to do is shift that and go
like,
what are my positives or negatives?
It's the same as a podcast man.
There's no difference in instagram and a
podcast.
There's no difference.
Why?
Because it's information man is sharing
cool show,
but it's what you're looking at.
No,
but I feel like sometimes you haven't
been the fan that may be the outsider.
Has the person lives in this right now
goes to die.
Like when you do instagrams like that
instagram you did about you eating drugs
and smoking and drinking.
It gave made me giggle post for me,
but I don't have to be looking at the
responses at minute by minute.
We're all agreeing on that.
You're saying get off your phone,
get off social media saying that because
of the impulse to look at the responses
and.
No,
I agree.
I hear somebody go and like Joel said,
he said he brought a response to
something I did.
Maybe even that video is going,
oh,
you should probably kill yourself.
And he said it.
One hundred 68 lights,
a lot of lights for a comment and then
he said,
some people are like,
how dare you?
You don't know that guy.
And he's like,
oh,
you just don't.
It's like,
I'll just delete it.
And it's like,
well no,
that time.
Fuck you bring it down because of
responses on fucking instagram.
Do that.
What did that whole.
It's the whole thing.
Five Dude.
I have people just block people.
Yeah.
Well you know,
there's a lot just getting your mind out
there.
They just don't.
They don't feel good and they want you
to feel shitty too.
Even if they're right about some things.
The way they address it is what the
problem is.
They're blurting out and oozing anger
and disproportionate amounts and it
affects everybody around them.
And it affects all of us.
There's,
yeah,
there's that.
And there's also just the amount of time
Tom,
you saw him,
you said you like,
let me just try to wake my kids up
before I check my internet or what?
Exactly.
It's just a matter of time or spending
on it too much.
It might to you good to see what it
seems like for a month off it where
you're like,
oh I think have a lot of time in my day.
It's overall positive to do it the way
you're describing.
I do think that it definitely for sure
plays a part in our business.
You need it for certain things.
But like you could do the thing where
you go,
yeah,
like let me find a way every time I
think I need it for this.
Like okay,
but can I.
is there a way around that?
I don't know.
Just when I see someone make my life
less happy it.
But then there's also people that make
your life happier.
There's a lot of really hilarious shit
online.
Adam Green Tree,
man.
Fuck everything you're saying right now.
I like watching his life like and then
I'm just.
I'm just Cam Newton man.
He does those running videos next to the
car and I go,
I gotta get out there and do something.
There's been Cameron Hayes or Cam
Newton.
Goddammit man.
He took from the panthers,
quarterback for the panthers.
The fucking lead singer of Steel
Panther.
Yeah.
Runs about his car with his half mask.
Hammered man.
Shout out to Cam Cam.
Both Newton and it's hollow,
Bruh.
I can't believe we did this much.
Working out your guys'.
That's fucking nuts and think about how
much more weight we're carrying.
Then you seriously?
Yeah.
That's one of my favorites was burt was
like,
oh,
red heartbreak.
It was be going up because he doesn't
work out.
It could be.
It could also be that you're lifting 70
pounds more than me with every step you
take.
That's a possibility to think about my
impression of already.
Hope guys would more rest with he's
going to try to kill you,
but we all did it.
Who you think you could tap out someone
first and I had no training.
He definitely has the most training in
Jujitsu fight.
If you could get on top of it,
you could do something to me,
but if I could stop you from doing that,
I would for sure be you.
He understood our.
He understands what's happening.
Probably wouldn't be.
You wouldn't know what to defend.
I've seen him choke people.
Exactly the case dude.
Next year we should do.
Let's propose it.
Let's go to worlds.
Let's do the surf.
We cut.
We got a kit.
In my opinion.
Can I just say,
well,
I need to cut the surf contest in half.
We should do in six months from now
because you know Kelly slater can get
this lined up and the weather will be
perfect when w in six months from now,
later when we suck so hard.
We'd never surfed was he would not want
any doing this or I know I have no
interest in this list number.
Wait,
let's do this and Kelly slater on top of
this.
Let's do also.
Wait,
will you do one round,
one round?
Yep.
I'm in MMA.
Like UFC rules fight against Ari.
Oh No,
no,
no.
I would never do that.
I'm down.
No,
no,
no.
We have fun competition,
Kimmy.
No hitting.
Okay.
There can be no hitting.
Here's the problem that you can choke
each other.
Want one,
choke each other.
The problem with hitting is that shit is
permanent.
The damage is real.
All right,
fine.
When you're in your forties,
you don't want to be getting punched in
the face or one of your best friends.
He knocks you on surfing.
Jada shocks much combat Jujitsu.
That snow hit each other.
I'm sick birds.
How old did you turn for real?
40 six.
For Real,
for real,
for real age.
Wikipedia page.
Now what's the real age went?
Come on.
Tell them the real age children.
40 six.
When your brother was in the Vietnam
War,
Truman went on TV and said,
when he said,
did your whole family freak out or no
backup?
When Kennedy was assassinated,
fake media,
man.
I'm 42,
47 years old.
Where did six?
40 six?
Forty three.
Forty one.
I'm 41 years old.
Joseph one.
I know.
This is what it says on his blood
pressure medication.
I don't want to have a stroke.
I don't know.
I mean I know I'm going to stay on my
blood pressure medication until the
doctor says to get off it.
I stopped you.
Is there a path to office?
Should I be going on to lose weight?
How much?
I probably have to get to two.
Oh,
five.
Fuck my blood pressure medicine,
I think.
Right.
What are you on now?
I was 28 at the end of the contest.
Yeah,
probably no joke.
Probably to 35.
I'm guessing.
Two.
Oh five.
What were you at the end of the
challenge will look to.
I don't know.
I don't really remember to be honest
with you.
I think Jamie pulled that up less than
that buddy.
He was 13.
Then final way in score was two.
16 to 19 right now.
Tom,
what are you at right now?
Because you don't want to put it back on
after the photo.
Okay.
Yeah,
sure.
Whatever.
First of all,
don't forget this.
Don't forget this.
The way in was with a dramatic for
nonprofessionals dramatic water cut.
Okay.
Fuck.
Yeah.
Yeah,
I know.
So we basically,
you can throw on not just one day,
I know,
but you can throw on 10 pounds
essentially to what we weighed in it as
our real weight,
you know?
Oh my God,
this is fucking crazy thing we did last
year or the year before with this
challenge.
And with this one we didn't really take
into account our own personal health.
Yeah,
good point.
That's to do it.
But he really honest.
I had phantom pains and my kidneys.
I was worried on this one.
Yeah.
The last day,
the last few days I did like somewhere
in the range of 535 points.
You were worried about attaching it.
You're sneaky.
Sneaky disrespect,
slippery Joseph's back.
And even if you couldn't take about that
the same way I really thought bird was
asked to try to double me.
Same feeling like I can't believe you
really thought that care.
You don't understand.
I don't care if it's a rehab.
It happened.
I don't care if it's real,
it's just you set it so it made it real.
Even if you don't believe it,
it doesn't matter.
It doesn't help me to think that you
don't believe I would love.
It helps your brain every now and then
believe it helps me to think that you're
trying to double my score and I'm Mike.
We're going to the dark lands.
Yeah,
what going dark Bert Kreischer.
But to answer your question,
I think that we put on our water.
I put a.
We put on our water weight and I think I
only gained a few pounds on top of that.
After October.
Thirty percent stayed consistent.
That's a lie.
That's the way you think.
Your 2:16
right now know what I said was to be
fair.
That's what Joe said.
What I said was that we probably gained
10 pounds back from the water.
I agree with that to 16 will put me at
26.
I said I probably gained a few pounds on
top of.
I would say right now if everything your
2:30,
I love you.
You're an awesome person,
but the reason why you pushing back
against this as [inaudible] your concern
that it's going to sweep back.
I knew having gained me telling me
regardless,
what's he doing at a beach?
He's gotTa Piss Man.
Even alone families in the social
justice warrior,
Joe Rogan.
He's pissing and wave like this bird
comes back.
Just remember that Greg came in last.
I can't tell.
You can't.
You can't give people motivation.
You don't understand.
I don't need it to be real.
I just.
Oh,
I heard it.
I decided to.
I'll just decide it's real that.
So you have to understand that you came
and fucking last.
Tell him about Jean for real.
Shut the fuck up and listen.
I think that Mickey.
Well Jeanne,
thank you.
He didn't say anything on to.
I want to say this to the Sandy Kofax
Jean.
I want to say Mickey Mantle Jeans.
Oh my God is real.
Not because of this.
It's because the mickey mantle gene is
this crazy son of a bitch.
Could go out Wednesday,
Thursday,
Friday,
Saturday night until three in the
morning with fucking,
you know,
a hundred and 80,000
beers.
Sunday.
He was like,
let's do a shout out fucking fine.
That's Mickey Mantle.
Jane true.
Not True.
This shit.
It's a lot of pis,
I think he's confused about Piss,
what it tastes like when choke it down
and you're going to treat them.
No,
I'm not drinking.
but Tom,
you got to get mailed to him and you
don't.
And then that's all that we need to
know.
Why do we tolerate it at all?
I did more workouts on you doing the
same work with less points of you.
That means that a far more workers from
you,
Bro.
He didn't work out at all for 10 years.
It's hard to fuck with that,
but I do the same workout and then it
was after doing the same workout with
you.
I was down 50
points we started with you that we are
missing is what Tom's saying is that if
we all had partied at the same level
every night and then tried to work out,
you definitely have that.
Yup.
To the feeling that I got with a molly
kicked in and fucking whatever time
Wednesday night.
Halloween night was just like this.
John felt so good.
It felt super.
Woke up the next morning,
my ankles hurt when I got out of bed,
my knees were there were all stiff and
sore or something going on with one of
the muscles in my calf and I was just
walking.
I take a piss.
I was like,
what happened?
What did we do?
I was,
while I was walking around with my kids
on Halloween doing the trick or treat
and deal,
I was thinking to myself,
thank God it's over.
Like what did,
what were we doing?
We all went crazy.
It was crazy.
I showed up at the comedy cellar and put
up my shirt on,
did my thing,
and Liz was like,
what are you doing?
I was like,
to run here because I'm in this constant
challenge with my friends.
So I had to run across town to a calm
response instead of just wasn't cool.
Two other people go like,
hey man,
why are you going to the gym right now?
Twice?
And didn't go,
oh,
I kinda liked it and I,
and I know it might be the only one,
but I liked the that I'm in a fight with
my friends.
And then going in and people going like,
you got this bird tell.
Show them you can already.
People knew all you dummies and said you
got this Bert.
Thank you leslie.
I was more angry about you people to
when I was like,
oh great.
So many people on the last time I let
down so many people.
The second to last,
they're dreamers.
The dreamers.
The dreamers?
No.
Or they believe in God.
The one who chose here for you?
Dude,
I would draw.
I would jogged down here.
People in their truck.
We got.
You got this bird?
No,
I got that job.
I'm gonna.
Wait,
hold on one second.
My Buddy Eric,
who's you can tell you.
I went hiking and Runyon Canyon and two
guys were like,
hey man,
you got this bird?
And I was like,
I was in.
My head was already over.
I was like,
the job's already beat me.
Really bad guys.
What did you think the.
What was the final,
the final is that you got 11,000
something.
What?
You got?
Just over 9,000.
Ten thousand 16 until I got right up to
$10,000.
I was just over a thousand,
basically she had 1100,
1200,
something like that,
but it is getting $10,000.
It was another one where it's like,
let's aim for a line.
Get there.
That's a good line,
man.
That's a good line.
Eleven to three.
Good for you,
man.
Just to put that respective cigar.
Nine,
five,
three,
three workouts amongst of the hardest
relayed,
the tiniest percentage of the people
using these things.
I don't.
Legit.
Jim.
Where's our snap fitness in Shawnee,
Kansas.
Crushing.
We came in first and third and you beat
a fitness instructor who's giving class
killer?
I don't understand.
All of us.
Literally lost her.
Fucking mind.
Lost her mind.
We went crazy.
Now I like it too.
We're going to serve next year.
I'm into surfing.
Listen,
I'm going to die.
You're all going to die out there and
what I'm talking about Bro,
we can all come up with all the stuff
that keeps your ankle altogether.
Just everywhere.
Dogs shock,
shock.
That stuff that keeps your ankle from
moving around.
That shit's just give it a break.
Tiger sharks.
How long are you going to stay on that
surfboard?
Nurse?
Sharks.
How long?
Shut up to Kelly slater.
How long have you got in?
Yeah,
Kelly be my coach.
Kelly's going to pick up my podcast.
Joe,
compassion and let bro.
Don't forget.
Fuck both of you.
I'm going Brad Gerlach then.
Fine.
Fuck it.
Who's that guy is A.
Trust me.
I'm a big fan of surfers.
I just can't serve at Joel tutor guy and
that guy,
a jujitsu black belt master surfer.
I actually think Kelly slater is a
pussy.
I don't know.
Once you lose,
never risen to the top of your
potential.
No interest,
no interest.
You as a coach,
I'm looking for success.
Not for what has been.
Oh,
I'm looking for the top.
If you could help me not.
This is Kelly slater.
Garbage.
Don't be wrong.
How dare you?
He's looking for the wind to join on
this guy.
That guy that criticizes the girls.
Wait so that he gets started dating or
like gets under.
Her name is Kelly.
Don't fall for a man.
Don't fall for Indian River County.
What's up?
Let's hang out by these losers.
Fuck it.
I'll take your brother.
Evan.
What's up,
brother?
If you really had to be honest,
being scientific about how much time do
you think?
How much time do you think you could
spend on a surf board?
I got this 31 days in,
in,
in one day.
Even amount.
Thirty one days.
If if I did the math right and I could
for sure we did a work decision for
check.
No offense,
definitely seven days.
Seven full days,
full days.
Twenty four hours a day.
I would take a lot of work to get to
different places.
Just so you know what you're talking
about.
Six hours and about 15 minutes a day on
the earth.
I'm wrong.
I'm just glad I'm here to do the math.
Okay.
What did I say?
Seven,
seven days.
Four.
Four days.
Six hours plus a day?
Some goddamn accountant.
Logic and six hours?
Yeah.
Ninety six hours in one month.
Mm hmm.
About almost four hours a day by the
way.
This is what I do is talk shit.
So like.
But there's no consequences for you
talking shit.
Do you feel bad about that?
I have no problem with him in ways
buying dinner.
Okay.
Does it feel weird about dinner?
I can't believe became a last man.
Oh yeah.
But that's what I do.
I was so worried about coming in last.
I came in because you're afraid of
consequences.
I'd like to live loud.
That's the difference between all of us
is said when,
when,
when we're in a liquor store in Atlanta
and kissed her and,
and,
and print starts playing both you
fucking hide in the corner until burt
makes it big and then one person makes
it big.
We all like to make it big.
We want to start dancing.
Never liked it because I was forced into
making a big big.
And you loved it big.
We all loved that big.
What?
Well,
when we did the,
uh,
video when we were all partying in
Atlanta and,
and Prince came on to you do that.
We did that because we were like,
you seem to like this.
I'll let me join him for like 10 seconds
of dance.
We have fun.
It's doing you listen.
I would never need a guideline.
Joint pain.
You definitely changed the tone.
You really do.
To change tone changed the party
atmosphere.
I like to get loud.
I know that it drives,
does drive people nuts,
but with my friends I trust it that
it'll be fun.
No one's going to.
I don't.
There's no mean spiritedness in it for
sure.
One hundred percent.
I wanted that belt so fucking bad.
Oh,
can I try it on for sure.
For sure.
You have your coach?
No,
I don't want your coach billy.
Billy brought other girl or a Kelly
running coach.
I wanted that belt.
So bad soda.
I though unfortunately press a joke.
Sorry.
So heavy.
She just couldn't keep up.
Right.
Do you think there was any point during
the month we had a pace that you think
you could have kept up where he had been
like,
you know,
hitting those 500 point day,
like day after day after day.
It is like what we already had planned
for the month.
Right.
You know,
if you had that,
you had that cruise.
I had this hunting trip,
which fortunately ended fairly early,
but if you were just going somewhere,
if you had somewhere that you had to go
for 14 days and you couldn't get a
workout in,
you are fucked.
If I had just stayed home that whole
trip,
it would've been very different contest,
but I live without my gym.
No,
I agree.
We all experienced that.
I'm not using that,
but it's about just saying except that I
would have loved to have been not on a
cruise.
It was because I get seasick working
out.
Bobby Kelly as your motivation.
Just Bobby Kelly sometimes.
I thought he wanted to go by that,
but it's the other way work together.
Wait,
you guys know you guys did not work out
so fast that the calories are not
working for me and him just smoke cigars
and that was a hindrance in me is that I
spoke to about scars and so then when I
got back to Tampa for like one day to
work out,
dude,
I was like,
I was coughing up bullshit.
I smoke cigars on my way home to the
comedy cellar.
Seven nights of those that I was home
of,
the 20 I worked out after I came home,
supposed to change,
went to workout.
We're different people,
so bs on you.
He's definitely a different genetic
makeup than you know.
Some people are allergic to peanuts.
Yeah,
that's true.
The Kelly slater did this.
Conor mcgregor,
Jane,
we did we.
This is how we did it.
We did it because we didn't plan on
doing it.
We did not plan on doing.
When Tommy pulled up this idea and we
were like,
what?
It's like,
yeah,
I wear a heart rate monitor and it's a
fitness app and we're all like,
okay.
We were just looking for something to do
some quantifiable.
We started out thinking it was going to
be yoga again.
Right.
I remember that.
It was done.
I.
It was loved though.
I would have done it.
It was the fourth and all.
You guys were mad at me so mad.
It was on the road.
What the fuck's up with these?
Get punched her in the red zone.
Are you fucking kidding me?
These fucking guys are so pissed at.
You were about anybody.
They just attack them like,
who?
Anybody,
whoever's Brown,
here's let me be on whoever's plan.
I didn't read into this stupid shit
at all,
so when I got the APP and I put the
heart rate monitor on,
I'm like,
well,
we'll just run to the death.
I was like,
we're just going to run into the
nineties as long as I can in the
nineties
like,
let's see.
I thought you were so upset when you
found out you don't get more points for
90.
It didn't make any sense.
I'm like,
you,
you get as much points for 80 percent of
your Max heart rate because you do.
Yeah.
That didn't make any sense.
It shouldn't be quantifiable,
but Tommy nailed it.
He's like,
that shit would probably be like high
highly litigious.
Oh yeah.
There's some lawyers over at my son that
was like,
you can't incentivize people to go to
the danger.
What's interesting about that,
about
that though,
and this is actually changed some of my
opinions on training because I've never
done that where I didn't just do a lot
of like really go all out.
I did as little,
even slow down the pace that I run up
the hills,
but when I would get on the heavy bag,
when I would do kickboxing,
I had way more endurance,
like way more endurance and it was
interesting.
I was like,
this is crazy or this is all I haven't
been.
I maybe did over the course of the
entire month,
maybe 10 kickboxing workouts,
but by the end of the month the
kickboxing and has gotten way higher.
It was all just from running and from
doing the elliptical machine rowing
machine and doing all that other shit.
All that other shit.
Just it.
You don't.
It's not as exciting to do,
but if you do it,
it ramps up everything around running
hills.
You know,
you gotta we gotta keep going.
Do it once or twice a week.
We got to keep going.
We have to keep going.
Keep looking at it a little bit.
Yes.
It's so hard to get where we're at.
We're getting better.
You guys were too,
right where you started picking like a
lot of sugar now because it's going to
fuck over the conquest,
but here's the thing and we should all
talk about this and maybe we should have
a coach come on and talk to us about if
we decide to do this again,
what are our nutritional requirements?
Because I had one workout.
There's 4,000,
700 calories.
That's an insane amount of food.
You know what I never got from like
nutritionists and people like that.
Workout people like legit workouts you
can do.
You know what I mean?
Not like this is the best thing.
It's like,
all right,
right,
but for my real life,
I'm going to do it twice a week.
What can I really do and what do I got
to eat a little bit more often that
would help me instead of like an all
this diet.
We all talked about this as
unsustainable.
Totally level was my joint,
so that was what if I told you you had
to do 11,000
points this month?
November?
No,
hold on.
What if I told you I can beat you?
Do it.
You could do it.
I could do it.
What time is it?
What is it?
Where are we at?
Fucking brave.
Broken.
Fuck yeah.
Can get a thousand a day.
You don't think I could do it?
No,
not from here on out with a a thousand
dollars a day.
You get there,
you suck my Dick.
Fuck you mean it.
But if you don't get there,
you're like,
dude,
y'all care at all about Gimme.
GimMe.
What?
You can do it now.
You can do what you did before.
Minus five days.
Hundred percent.
How about the.
I took three days off.
No,
I took four days off.
I took three and another day.
You don't take it with.
You already did last month.
Hold on right now.
Let's do that right now.
We get one day next week because I'm
going to Europe.
That's crazy.
Who Do you think you get the most points
him today?
Wow.
Who's gotten the most points way?
Probably.
Nope.
Hardest or second?
Seven hundred 40.
Oh yeah.
Tom,
do you think you could've got 260 more
points,
but after lose a toenail to reason.
I stopped,
I gotta be honest with you.
I don't.
Six 40 something,
something my gut on a one off.
I didn't ever sit down because I had
some days where I definitely did like,
so let's put let's possible
that I did more than that and here's the
two workout days outside of this shit
talking,
which is always fun,
but here's what we should really think
about.
We definitely got our all of ourselves
into a really,
really good level of fitness,
right?
I mean,
thinking about the shit we did.
You ran 12 miles,
you ran 15 miles and then you rode five
kilometers.
You,
you ran a shitload.
You got 700 fucking points in a day.
We went crazy boys.
We went crazy.
We,
we achieved some very bizarre level of
performance over the month in comparison
to the average person that wears these
things.
It's very weird.
Yeah.
Okay.
So it's not that we should pat each
other on the back,
but it is.
We should look at what we did and go,
what happened?
That was possible.
Like Thompson.
It is possible.
So let's stop and think about that for a
second.
It is possible.
Here's the other thing.
It happened and I feel great.
Feel good.
I look in the mirror and I'm like,
I like that dude.
When you were doing the rowing machine
and I was getting video naked on stage.
It's exactly his and his dick has
literally a hundred percent outreach
from his pubis.
Tom and I,
but Bush standing,
I thought I really thought I was like,
this is a movie montage.
When I watched his fucking perfect
position of Ari's like I got to change
my life.
I'm going for it.
Like he's really buying into it.
I was like,
he was changing his life going forward.
We've got pockets of like kind of work
out of your fucking super gym for an
hour or two because I got to look at it
in.
It's a perfect because apps look at
those abs.
It's a perfect pull.
The ABS,
they never looked at it as much as they
got fucking yellow Sun after the surf
camp,
after Chemo Surf Camp,
we're going to beat them so bad.
I can't go on a surf camp.
The is.
We don't do anything until October
first.
Me and Tom versus jewelry.
Damn,
I liked that body.
Look at that fucker checked.
You still jacked nipples,
but total pounds on Mexican food.
That's it.
Deal,
Bro.
But here's the thing,
it's not the thing,
but here's a thing.
We pulled it off like we really did.
Well,
all of us did something you never
expected.
It's very few that we did this workout
in a gym in Kansas.
You crushed them.
Here's what's crazy.
If you think about the points,
four points a minute is like hustling.
You see that tower?
You're in the tech.
What Sally?
Did they send you an email of your
monthly tally?
All the institute.
No wait,
I'll say I'll read your mind which will
give you perspective on your worry about
it in the middle.
Yeah.
So hold on,
hold the number of calories you burn.
Shit.
Oh postrace.
But what's interesting is we didn't
anticipate is this.
I thought it'd be like an hour or so.
So the $3,000
to happened hundred minute.
So it says for the whole month.
First of all,
it shows me the whole year leading up to
October and then it says the 95,
38 meps,
which is the measurement,
right?
Yeah.
Three thousand 726 minutes.
I work.
How many hours is it?
October.
That's funded by 60.
What?
Sixty hours.
Oh my God.
Wait,
I'm sorry.
Start over.
I was the day he said he worked out 60
average?
Yeah.
Average effort.
Seventy percent for the whole month.
Oh,
uh,
calories burned for the month.
Forty 7,000.
$800 for an average heart rate was 1:31
bpm.
Wait,
I'm going to send you this because I
said to these guys are ready about what?
Pussies.
We are [inaudible].
There was a guy who went.
He swam around the UK.
That dude?
Yeah,
like pull that up.
This guy to fuck around the UK.
Wow.
He swam.
He burnt a half a million calories.
This guy's crazy.
His tongue was falling apart.
I was reading that yet with the salt
water in your mouth.
Oh my God.
His fucking tongue was falling apart and
this guy swam around the UK.
Hundred and 57 days swimming.
Twelve hours a day.
We're going to will be on the Rogan
podcasts in two weeks.
He can't talk son.
He did good man.
His ticket got eight and barn roles.
Yeah.
What Bert worked out.
This is birth recap.
He did 4,098
minutes of working out 66 percent
effort.
Burned 46,250
calories.
Average heart rate.
One hundred 20.
You know it's brutal.
Man is hard.
Jesus weightlifting workout didn't keep
any so that that muscle expenditure is
like way more severe to direct myself
for 45 points.
One day I was like,
oh,
it was.
It was different to when you got into
running like legit running because I
would run 10 miles at night and I would
only get 200 points for it.
Do that.
I just get up in the middle of the night
points.
I know.
Yeah,
because my heart rate wouldn't get over.
One 30.
Thank God for 24 hour germs or your own
weight lifts and kill it.
You were killing it.
There's 24 hour gyms are interesting
because you're dealing with psychos and
like every,
every piece of equipment you get or if
you have your own place,
obviously every time is your own place
or maybe it was kimberly trebek run into
some person's working out at 3:00
in the morning.
It's like a genius could be just can't
handle people.
Could be through some moments that he
worked at Gold's gym for a while and
he's just see that the
difference between 4:00
AM to 6:00
AM between the tweakers to slowly become
like the winters were getting like a
free work workout.
Yeah,
and it was such a quick shift of like
type of person coming in.
Where are we going to dinner?
What do you want to tell people on the
Internet?
Oh,
we wrap the shit up.
Do you want to wrap it up?
Did we learn anything from this?
Because I find it interesting.
Let's go around room Tommy buttons.
What did you learn from this?
I,
I think I confirmed that I love a
competitive event.
It brings me closer to you guys actually
like you guys more.
Even though I really liked you for,
I'm serious,
I feel like it makes me like you guys
more because I'm like,
oh,
it's Kinda like that comradery of being
on a team.
It feels like a team thing.
Um,
and I,
I,
yeah,
I'm,
I had that moment where I'm like,
oh,
I'm capable of more than I thought I was
capable of.
Which is a,
like a saying.
It's encouraging and then it kind of
fucks with you too.
Alright.
What did you learn?
I learned one that I actually am capable
of working out.
I needed the competition to actually get
to the gym.
Like I said,
this infant killed January.
You can.
I hadn't gone there till October.
I also learned how many people got into
this.
It was nuts.
It was a lot.
I went to a jets game.
People like,
shouldn't you be working out?
And by the way,
my favorite spots is in one of these
things like how sober October going to
any family walked by,
I could just go,
go fuck herself,
eat shit.
Kill yourself.
That's what you would say.
Yeah.
All the time.
Hey you enjoy me?
And silver,
why don't you go fucking kill yourself
and your wife.
It was the best Jesus.
They went perfectly with it.
I'm like,
fine wine.
Yeah.
And I realized that actually can work
out a little bit and maybe I should work
out a little bit and that's awesome.
I do it.
I didn't remember it.
Also on the 30th,
the second last day I was running,
trying to get.
Just get points.
Yeah.
And a guy in a construction site was on
a cell phone and he did not look like
somebody I would think would say
anything to me.
And he's like,
yeah.
And then he turns.
He goes,
hey buds,
I'm pulling back.
That's great.
So many people knew about it.
It was fun.
It was fucking my kid's school.
Dads were coming up to me and so.
And I'm doing sober October to know shit
at one more day.
One more day.
Wow.
What did you learn?
What'd you learn?
What do you feel like you learned?
The competitive drive was fascinating.
I didn't anticipate getting that crazy
because I just didn't.
I thought it was just gonna be us having
fun.
We'd work out like last year,
15 yoga classes.
It's not that extraordinary detail.
The latter for sure.
The latter part of the month,
right.
We all did together at like the 28th
one.
What?
I learned something last year though,
honestly to carried over this year that
I decided to do nine yoga
classes in a row to finish off my
session.
I had like a bunch of weeks,
like a week plus later to go.
Like if I wanted to make it to the end
of the month,
I just want to get the 15 in.
And I started decided to do nine in a
row and when I realized somewhere around
like number seven in a row,
I was like,
oh,
you can just keep doing it.
What did you think?
You need time off,
but you don't really need time off.
He just needed to keep doing it and
maybe you'll slow down a little bit.
Maybe you'll you won't have as much
energy,
but then you just keep doing it.
Your body will eventually adapt,
but this is way more demand.
But this is what,
what,
what happened with this too?
So what I realized last year by doing
nine in a row,
like your body just sort of adapts and
then once I started doing like us are
ramping up the cardio sessions and I was
like,
okay,
if I just decided to get off now I can
get off now.
I can just stop now.
An hour and a half.
It's a long time.
You'd be like 300 points.
What's better?
Five hours is better.
We'll see if we can do five hours.
Like we did an hour and a half.
We just got to do an hour and a half
again.
Then we're almost there.
Then we're at three and then we do an
hour and a half again.
There were four and a half.
Then we're all,
oh yeah,
with this is all bad.
This is why psychos like Lance Armstrong
win the Tour de France.
It's not just because the steroids,
because he's a fucking psycho mind of a
werewolf.
Funding figures out a way to win.
So part of this daily workout right now,
like whatever lands does today,
fucking blow your fucking mind zones on
that guy.
And it's over super hyper competitive
mental part of this,
not just to go do it,
but actually go,
you need to go,
you need to leave your apartment,
your house,
and you do go over there.
I know you want to do this,
but you've got to go do it now for a
couple of hours.
That part was like one of the hardest
parts about anxiety in the morning.
You would go off and I'd worry.
I'd check.
Check your scores.
Scores.
The only message.
What'd you learn?
What'd you Limbert Oh,
fucking mail.
No,
I was.
I was asking you.
But what'd you learn?
Something?
I learned A.
I learned that I have a lot more in me
than I ever thought I had.
You know,
I learned that already is a sneaky fuck
with a lot more strength than I ever
thought.
I imagined.
Get angry that they were sandbagging.
You said I got angry a lot.
Yeah.
You didn't want anyone to out of the
same shit you got into.
I got into two.
But just with you.
I just thought it was a joke.
I didn't think you were really upset.
I was scared of you halfway.
You don't understand.
I didn't think it was real.
I didn't think you really believe you're
going to double me.
I never thought that was real hard,
but I didn't.
I didn't have to.
I heard the words and so I decided to
believe them.
Dude,
I used to think,
believe that you think I was going to
beat you already know.
I never knew you
would be.
You never went.
I never knew Tom will beat me.
Beat,
you know,
way.
Uh,
no,
not,
not at all.
I thought you were sort of shape.
I thought it was a misjudgment of the
system.
And then when we went on a hike
together,
I was like,
oh fuck.
oh yeah,
of course someone that's 100 pounds
lighter than me would be in better
shape.
That makes sense.
Thank you.
Fifty pounds.
But yes.
Yes.
There's a lot.
I learned a lot.
I learned.
What did you learn a lot.
I learned that I number one thing is
that I need this comradery to better
myself.
Like when you get challenged by your
friends and you have this fun fuckery
that just happens every day.
Fuck it points you into a place that's
better for yourself.
My opinion.
It's also really fun
fun for people listening.
I got a lot of people that came up to me
and said,
man,
I wish I had friends like you guys
because you guys are so silly and
stupid.
You're both.
You're all of you rather or just like
goofing on each other constantly and
everybody's laughing,
howling and it,
it gives everybody that's listening to.
This is bizarre sense of comradery.
Let's get.
We got through this fuck stupid fucking
month when we're doing insane amount of
exercise saying I'm at the end of it.
We,
we're talking about trying to.
When I called her one day and I was
like,
you know,
we're not athletes,
right?
Like,
what was the best?
We're not all trained athletes,
bro.
Tell him.
He goes,
we're just comics.
I went,
no,
we're not,
bro.
Yeah.
That's time competition.
Would you have in second or third in the
final scores had a killer.
That's crazy.
J One d,
One athlete.
Crazy and she probably teaches a gang
classes,
but also she probably never gets out of
the grange probably in super shape.
She's probably doing it forever.
She'd probably bury all of us.
That's the thing.
It's like what we did was we just did a
one month chaos run.
We all survived,
but I think we should be careful about
this because there is,
there is really a potential damage your
body doing stuff like this.
It's really fun for sure.
But there's a weird potential for like
when you hear about stuff like Rhabdo
and you're like,
what?
What happened to tell you about for the
positive is so much outweighs the
potential for the negative that it's
like,
just do it.
I'm not saying that this is one of the
big negatives,
but I don't know how any of you guys did
with cramps.
I had um,
unbelievable muscle cramps,
the last plan for that.
So I took a lot.
Yeah,
yeah.
I totally.
A lot of electrolytes.
I took more than I needed.
I took them with him.
I added Himalayan salt and water and one
of the things that I realized when you
add too much Himalayan salt to water,
your body processes it like food,
so all that water comes right through
your butthole,
like a runaway train,
like a semi with broken just shit and
water
up gets 34 ounces of water coming flying
out of your asshole at mach one.
It's crazy,
dude.
Your body,
when you drink salt with water together,
your body goes,
oh,
this is food.
What is this?
We get it Outta here.
Get it out.
Woo comes out like water.
My ass was blown out for a lot of those
workouts.
It was hard because the amount of time
that all of us,
we're pumping our legs.
It's crazy.
She's Christ.
That's it.
Make any sense.
It's just the fact that we got close to
each other.
We'll all of us were preposterous.
Burt,
you were.
You were all of us for postrace in terms
of a normal month of exercise for sure.
Basically everybody,
it's more than I ever seen one of those.
I'm one of those boards for 10 months.
I've never seen anything.
I knew that was the 11 five digits
getting 11,700,
7,000
and that,
that was pretty nuts.
11,000
is taking to a terrible,
terrible place to get to $11,000.
It doesn't.
It was only because we were all sort of
pushing each other where it's like,
oh fuck,
he's doing.
We want to lose.
To be honest with him,
he's right here.
600 something.
It was like fuck.
But there was also like,
wait,
I could do at least that one day I got
one more day in me of that show is beat.
Bert and Tom,
tell me what you and I talked about.
I was telling him on the 31st I was
like,
fuck,
I got this.
I just,
I just flew to Tampa.
I go,
I got the next day and I.
So I,
I didn't even tell you guys I didn't
know how it's going to effect.
So I was like,
alright,
can we had a cutoff of 10 eastern?
I just got to the hotel.
I checked in,
I go right to the gym and I was like,
man,
this has been a fucking motherfucker.
And I got to work out right now.
I didn't know how.
I knew you were six,
700 points ahead of me.
I just started and I was like,
I just,
I can't lose the bird.
Right?
I was like,
I can't,
I can't.
And I had major anxiety.
I didn't think like,
oh,
it would suck to lose the bird.
I had like crippling anxiety about it
and I was like,
all right.
I just kept going and I had a few
hundred points.
I was already at least I didn't know if
you'd sinked up.
So I was at least 307.
Oh,
sick was a real worry.
Yeah.
Seeking was a real way to make rules if
we do this ever again.
First of all,
we got to get blood checked.
Why is a real concern if we doing drugs
or alcohol,
you mean?
No,
no,
no.
I mean rob doe.
I mean people die.
Oh,
it'd be cool to do this with doctors if
we ever do anything like this again.
I really think we should do it with
doctors because there was a point where
I said like at the end there I was,
I was having like phantom pains.
It just just felt 31st was a bad day for
me.
That travel day.
That was what you call Joe?
No,
no,
no.
I called to talk to him first.
He Jealous First.
I worked out in the morning.
Mother fucker.
By the way.
You talk to everyone in here bumped me.
I talked to you.
You just don't call me.
Oh,
you fucking liar.
I worked out in the morning,
flew to Tampa.
I'm 31st landed,
went to the fucking gym.
I actually talked to you and then you
and then an hour after you.
I spoke to him and I was like,
I see that he started 300 ahead of them
now.
Two,
$300.
If you don't work out,
he can catch you on 200 more,
which makes 500,
least 500 at least that I can see.
Yeah.
Which is two and a half hours and I
tried to know and I was like,
what's up?
And I really believed them.
I was like,
I hear him.
He was like chopping.
He's like,
I'm cooking right now at the house.
Friends are over,
blah blah,
blah.
He's like,
I swear I'm done.
And I was like,
all right man.
And I hung up and I was like,
I got to go for at least another room.
I said to you,
I said,
I know where my children have done.
I go,
when I say I'm done,
I'm done.
And I go,
we got friends over.
I had to go spend the day with Georgia
with her thing.
I don't have time to workout and I'm not
going to do it now I'm ready to get
fucked up at midnight.
Well,
what I knew to was that I was not going
to go another 500 to cash.
Payments are going to go.
Can you please just tell me so I can
actually take this dancing when I'm on.
You know what I'm fucking out of it.
Part of it was very nice when Georgia
power.
I got back from spin class,
Georgia was at school,
texted me,
she goes,
uh hey,
I need you to do the daddy lunch in,
set up at nine,
and it was like 8:00
and I looked at Leanna was like,
I'm done.
I don't,
I can't.
I got really angry.
She was,
honey,
he lost,
you're working.
She goes,
he lost.
He lost that.
Go of it to hours.
So competitive.
I was so competitive about it and I
went,
I,
I give it really hard today.
I can definitely,
she goes,
just like have it be a dad and I,
I couldn't.
I had to go lay in bed and just go like,
I'm gonna give myself 15 minutes to lay
in bed and get my head straight.
Well maybe we should consider this.
Maybe we should think that this
competition is more of a time constraint
issue in like how much time you have,
how much time you have is a lot of.
It's not just being able to do it,
but it's like making time for it.
Right?
Yeah,
it was,
it was super hard at times because you
were social functions where you're like,
I want to be able to do this.
My friends right now.
Yeah.
I can't go with working out.
Yeah,
that doesn't matter because I know Joe's
got two young kids and I would go,
he's right in there.
Five hours.
I go,
fuck it.
I would make amendments.
That's everyday genius.
I booked my podcast whenever one.
What I did was I just scheduled a time
where I could work out for at least four
hours before I had to be at the podcast.
She come in here and do it till 20
minutes before shower and get ready.
Sure.
So if a noon
podcast,
Mike,
you know,
the kids get up early,
I'm out of the house at seven,
seven.
I'm coming to the gym or I'm going to,
you know,
work out in my yard or I'm going to run
the hills.
A lot of run the hills a lot.
I want to run those.
The your daughter mom,
man.
Fun.
I got a few different routes that I go
to.
Mix it.
Yeah.
Some are more steep.
One of them is way more severe in the
beginning,
one of them starts out with a real heavy
pitch.
It's like real steep,
steep,
steep beginning and then it gets harder
and harder than the end of it.
You're,
you're running more of a downward slope
down.
So yeah,
it's,
it's hard,
man.
There's something about running hills
that I really think it's like,
it's,
it's a survival thing.
It's like if you want to get away,
what are you going to do?
You gotta run,
you gotta get your body after you can't
get your body out of there.
You got to survive,
motherfucker.
It's a scary thing running those hills.
Sure.
Ron.
Hey,
do you have a place,
uh,
that you could pretty hammered?
No,
I'm just saying run,
run.
Sorry.
I've placed.
We can.
What?
By Elk?
I give you some,
you know.
No,
no,
no.
I got a lot of it.
I know.
I felt like I was this whole time,
this whole month,
this whole month I would look at your
meals and I go,
I want to start eating melt elk.
Okay.
But no,
no,
no.
But I meant like I in like,
is there a place that someone listening
right now can go by?
You can't find a place to buy it?
No.
You can buy some of it from New Zealand.
They'll sell it from New Zealand.
But you can't buy North American game
animals in North America.
They can't.
That I couldn't find it for.
Saved my life.
Yeah.
That's because it's not for sale
commercially.
They raise it in.
What's up?
Hey,
what's up?
Let's go.
We're going to go have dinner.
They raised them in New Zealand in
particular.
You know,
New Zealand has a giant collection of
uh,
I forgot this one thing sober October.
It's that thing you've said before.
I thought about it a couple times
throughout the month.
The,
uh,
the,
your inner bitch thing.
Conquer your inner bitch.
We talk about quit that day to quit.
But everyday.
Here's the thing.
I didn't even consider an inner critic
voice everyday.
I was like,
these,
these three fucking cock suckers are
doing.
So I definitely have.
And I was doing a lot of,
a lot of the month.
I was doing two a days.
Yeah,
me too.
It's crazy.
Crazy.
I know.
So I'm saying like that's.
That was one of those things,
but it's funny when you have,
but it's interesting to me was like when
you have friends involved,
dude,
the consideration of even let's just lay
here and chill wasn't even a
consideration.
Just seeing Bert with that strap on
talked and he was like,
whatever it joe scream into the night
bird.
I want to get it bothered with cab.
I want a Pinot noir.
Let's get like bone in rib eyes.
We're going to do it up tonight as
fucked days.
But here's the thing that already
pointed out that I think is really
important for us to honestly think about
as human beings.
We got to a very good state of fitness
and we should really keep it.
You really keep it.
You don't have to do this crazy stupid
fucking thing where we compare our
points and we have a prize and a belt
every month,
but if we stayed on this system or
another system,
you know,
to just find out what's the best way
possible and good for you and here's the
thing that's really important.
I think it'll help other people too.
There's other people would go like,
oh,
what a beet red.
I want to be Joe.
I want to be Tom.
I wanted to be.
I want to beat these guys.
I want to be a part of this.
And then what they'll do as long as we
emphasize this idea of don't fucking
kill yourself because I don't know how
close we got to kill ourselves,
but we definitely got close to breaking
ourselves.
Yeah,
you got the closest for sure.
Body broke down.
Well,
I,
I don't know what was going on.
See,
here's the thing,
like if it was Rhabdo that shit super
serious,
but my urine was starting to turn
darker.
I was like,
okay,
we've been talking about you broke the
bottles,
break a bottle,
a bottle,
but I'm telling you should've seen some
of my workout sessions.
They were confusing.
They're confusing.
It was like my,
my.
My whole brain had shifted over to this
a weird combat mode.
It was very strange.
Very strange man.
That's very strange for all of us,
I think.
I think all of us,
when I looked at Rod,
when red hit 479 points in a day,
I went,
Oh shit,
this is war.
It was going forward.
She's gone for like five,
six days.
I was like,
wait,
I don't need Michelle.
I think I could actually do this.
Do you were really going to put the
strap on her.
There was no question and she had no
question about keeping quiet.
I trusted her,
so when I.
What would your plan have been?
Just give it to her all the time.
All the time.
She runs 13 miles a day.
That's what I run.
Yeah.
When would you,
when would you have drafted on this that
you did that?
Never about a year later.
I year I would've kept up on this
podcast or I might've said during this
podcast is like,
Hey,
guess what?
Would you have felt like cheated the
whole time?
Would you have felt comfortable saying
it only if you'd come and let's say
second or even if you had one you
probably want,
especially if I want and you guys had to
pay for some fucking fancy trip that you
guys all decided on that have no
interest in July.
Gladly
I would give my heart rate monitor to
campaigns and then it would make a
separate account for yourself,
a couple of count for myself and I try
to beat you on my provisional ball,
but if I can't,
campaigns definitely beat you and then
I'd be super humble about it but came in
and did a great effort.
How about we just tired?
I would give him my strap to burt.
We've got like three real again and say
all you guys join up and just fucking
show your stats and we serve to the
death.
I'm into this surfing thing too because
I don't know how to surf at all and I
have two surfers on the month.
Really?
I had Kelly,
Shane,
Shane Dorian on just a couple of hours
ago.
They sit in the,
in the,
in the the beach,
and they push you and you start actually
surfing.
It's fucking fun and surfers have the
best body and the guy's going.
Gambling.
I will send a sound.
What's his name now?
What's the big wave surfer in Maui?
Oh,
fucking laird.
Hamilton has.
I have to get him on his bass player.
Hamilton's doing underwater toward the
work.
Have you seen him?
Oh my God.
They're all beasts.
Surfers or like a very unusual athlete.
You're.
They're wrestling with mother nature on
a fucking dropped off a helicopters onto
the weight.
Laird Hamilton is next fucking level.
There's a lot of those guys out there.
There's so many,
like really fucking powerful big wave
surfers.
I want him on your podcast.
Bad Man.
He'd be a great one for Gabby reese.
Reese when?
Florida state.
Yeah,
she did volleyball thing about surfing
too is you also have monsters in the
mix.
Sharks,
Kelly slater didn't want to talk about
sharks like I listen to podcasts.
He was like,
he was a little bit.
I didn't think he emphasized it because
I don't think he thinks it's as big of a
deal.
He's definitely drew as a listener.
He emphasized that they were there,
that they are all there the all the
time,
but he kept like dodging it and I was
like,
man,
it is one of those weird things where
you look at a guy who spent that much
time in the water and never had a like
had to deal with it and then his friends
have.
That's fucking insane,
man.
To charts are fucking fault that
imagining me,
you have no control in their world.
You're,
you're,
you're agreeing to being a,
like a movement in paired entity in a
struggling alien world.
Like you can't figure he could barely
get by for thrash in your arms and legs
and a shock could just wiggle up and
slap.
Take a big chunk out of your leg and
you're dead in the water with a great
white open water.
Open water.
I was,
I didn't have a snorkel on,
but I had a mask.
I was just looking down at them.
No,
no,
no.
It was in the water with it.
I was out of the cage and there's a
great white dude you find this on.
I'm sure you can find this online,
but it was,
it was all I knew is that it was the
only animal I'd move with it and move
with that much intention.
Like everything they did was like,
so like the way you get attacked by a
cat ever been attacked by a cat and
you're like,
motherfucker,
I can't stop it.
Did you like think at any point in time?
Like this could be how I go in the water
with a sharp.
No,
I've been in.
I've been in the water with great whites
couple times.
No,
no,
no.
Fuck.
If you went to overwhelming man,
they really are not like that now.
Now it would be a fucking killer video.
Like now that all the Shit I did before
I fall,
I fall pairs.
He did it all.
But like now if I did that,
that would go viral to do it and do it
now.
Just to stand up now.
I just do standup comedy shots,
world tour.
Everyone knew dates added January 10th
until April first.
We got to find out about.
Go to [inaudible] dot com.
Joseph,
are you international?
It's going international.
It's going through the UK,
Scandinavia,
Australia,
New Zealand.
Those studies haven't been released yet,
but man,
I am so happy and so excited per per,
per.com
with ease.
And Tommy,
you got some dates?
I have some dates to.
Yeah.
I'm doing a bunch of dates.
Thompson [inaudible] dot com.
That's what it sounds like.
There's a new theater guys.
Are She feared what you've got booked?
Well,
I got a Netflix special call.
Double negative is always,
but I'm shit shit.
Some European tour.
Elwood Opat,
November 16th through December ninth.
Brussels camp and Hagan.
Amsterdam,
Berlin.
Tons of places.
Oslo,
you say camping.
Haven,
Copenhagen.
I'm camping haven people.
They're like,
what?
Dcs Is.
No,
no,
no.
Let's go eat.
Let's go eat a lot of really doing the.
Oh wait,
we should do it.
Let's do something big.
Let's do Madison Square Garden.
Yeah,
we can do something like that.
Break even.
Let's just show us.
I think it'll be fun.
Red Rocks in Colorado.
That was the cool thing though.
I got an offer for like two years from
now.
One of those two.
Yeah,
but I'm saying like that's how.
All right,
let's sign up for 20 fucking weasels
land.
I can do a bunch of shit.
Listen,
we can have a lot of fun.
Especially like right now,
like where we only have to do 30 each.
Oh,
let's do it.
Let's do it.
I'm in.
I'm at 100 percent.
One hundred percent fun.
I'll do it.
It would be cool to that.
Pick a place gentleman.
All bullshit aside.
Really fun month.
It was,
it felt,
made me really happy.
It was fun.
The comradery was appreciated.
It was exciting.
It was ridiculous.
It was fun,
but it was hard,
but it was hard.
It was fucking hard.
But it was also,
it was fun and it felt good and they
like.
Even though I was like,
you know,
fuck,
this guy's going to kill him.
God Damn there was ice still was like,
wow,
I can't believe what everybody's doing.
Everybody was pushing so hard.
I would've never went as hard as I did.
If it wasn't for you guys.
There's not a chance in hell.
Not A in hell.
There's no way I would've gone that
hard.
No,
I've never gone that hard in my life.
If you had a point any 31 day a month in
my life and you put out like how much
effort I put forth,
that's as crazy as probably more.
I've probably been a bit of better
fighter if I train that hard back when I
was competing for fucking three
nonathletes and one guy was running away
from the memory of his father due to
fucking go to school and listen,
we're all fucked up,
but what's important is we showed human
potential.
We show its potential.
Yeah.
We showed that whatever we thought we
were capable of,
we're capable of so much more.
Now.
The question is whether or not we should
continue to put out that kind of effort.
I say no,
but I do say that we've reached a really
healthy,
powerful level of fitness.
We should definitely keep up some of it.
We've got to try to do that.
It was just something totally different.
Totally.
Whether it's ballet dancing,
we should compete each other.
A burst gonna drink rep right now,
right bird is going to drink rsp bottle
or dancing with the stars next year.
A MOCHA.
Alright.
Dot Com.
Thomson [inaudible] Dot Com are the
great.com.
Joe Rogan.com.
That's it.
It's a wrap.
We did it.
We will see you guys two weeks late.
Just champ champ on that.
Go Fund me.